AFTERNOON EVERYONE. I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. OF THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
I'M BILL QUIRK AND CHAIR OF THE
STM. TO MY LEFT IS OUR NEW VICE
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH ALL
ASK HIM TO MAKE A COMMENT AT
THE IN A MOMENT. AND TO MY
RIGHT IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY
AND HE- IS ALSO A NEW MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE- AND ALL THE I'M
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE THEM BOTH
ON BOARD. ARTS CENTER ALAN AND-
ARE JOINING US- BY- THE WEB
TODAY. ARE NOW GET TO SELL
PRACTICE SOLUTIONS SO WE'RE- IS
A DISK SCENE THE IN THE HEARING.
AT THREE THE CAP BUILD TO RALLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LITTLE NUMBER
PEOPLE WATCHING. PARTICIPATED.
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRE THAT MAN
WORN VISIT JUST BEING. BY ALL
MY OF THE PUBLIC WHEN THEY TEST.
THREE DO NOT REMOVE OR LOWER
MASK WENT. WE HAVE YOUR COOPER.
BECAUSE OF OUR SPACE LIMITS BY
THE WAY THIS IS THE AUDIO
PROBLEMS OKAY ON THIS. GOING TO
GET CLOSER THE MICHAEL. ALSO
WORKING OKAY. SO WE PRETTY YOUR
COOPER BE OF OURS LIMITED. WE
HAVE SOME COMMITTEE THAT ARE
WE'RE NOT HAVING THE PROPER-
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE TAKE AT
THE OF THE YEAR HEARING AT THAT
TIME AND MEMBER OF PUBLIC
HEARING THE ROOM- WILL- WITH TO
PROVIDE PROP COMMENT CAN RAISE
THEIR- THE LAST REPROACH THE AT
THE TIME- IS RIGHT OVER THERE-
YOU EXIT THE AREA ROOM ONCE
DAUGHTER RETURNED SEE. WE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE THIS. ALL UP
LEAVING CAPS HILL CLUED IN THE-
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PER TO. FOR DIAL IN WITH. HELLO
BE USING MODERN TO SERVICE
PUBLIC COMMENT. CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS YEAR IS. EIGHT SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO ONE THREE ONE
FIVE I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT. THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. FOUR TWO ZERO TWO ONE FIVE
TWO CUES ME I'LL START AGAIN ON
THE ACCESS CODE. FOR TWO ZERO
TWO ONE THREE ONE FIVE. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING END
PLEASE LEMONADE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE
SIX FIVE. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. TODAY WE'LL
DISCUSS THE PREVALENCE OF
MICROPLASTICS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. PLASTIC POLLUTION
IS A PERSISTENT AND GROWING
SOURCE OF POLLUTION NOT ONLY
STATEWIDE BUT WORLDWIDE- IT
AFFECTS OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
SUCH AS THE QUALITY OF OUR
DRINKING WATER AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. WELL PLASTICS HAVE
UNDOUBTEDLY MADE OUR LIVES
SAFER AND MORE CONVENIENT. FOR
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGIES TWO CAR
SEATS TO THE TAKE OUT TO
PACKAGING RESTAURANTS. ARE
USING- DURING THE PANDEMIC-
THEY ALSO BECOME A PRESSURE
POINT FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION AND
WASTE GENERATION. THE UBIQUITY
OF PLASTICS IN DAILY LIFE HAS
LED TO A GROWING SURGE OF
PLASTIC WASTE. THIS INCLUDES
SINGLE USE PLASTICS LIKE COFFEE
CUPS AND LIDS. PLASTIC BAGS
CIGARETTE **** BALLOONS STRAWS
PLASTIC BOTTLES PLASTIC
PACKAGING AND EVEN SYNTHETIC
TEXTILES. WELL WHEN PLASTIC
WASTE IS LITTERED STORMWATER
CAN CARRY IT OUT TO OUR RIVERS
BAYS AND COASTLINES. LAST EXIT
GET WASHED DOWN THE DRAIN. FROM
THE GREYWATER OF RESIDENTIAL
WASHING MACHINES AND SINKS GOES
TO WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANT.
AND WE HEAR FROM THE- FOLKS TO.
RUN THE WASTE WATER TREATMENT
THAT THEY CAN FILTER ALL THAT
PLASTIC OUT OF THE VAST
MAJORITY BUT THEN IT ENDS UP IN
THE SLUDGE AND THE SLUDGE GOES
OUT EVER CULTURAL LANCE SO WE
ARE. ALMOST CERTAINLY WHEN WE
USE THE SLIDE. IN AGRICULTURAL
LANDS WERE POLLUTED WITH
PLASTIC MICROPLASTICS. HOSOE
PLASTIC WASTE WHEN IT GETS INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT NEVER FULLY. I
HAD A GREAT PLASTIC BREAKS DOWN
INTO SMALLER AND SMALLER
FRAGMENTS. UNTIL THEY ARE WHAT
WE CALL MICROPLASTICS
MICROPLASTICS ARE FOUND
VIRTUALLY EVERYWHERE EVEN IN
THE UMAN BODY. SO WE ALL HAVE.
WE KNOW SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
PLASTICS GO INTO OUR OCEANS
CENTER COMING FROM DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
TODAY WE'RE JUST GOING TO FOCUS
ON CALIFORNIA'S CONTRIBUTION TO
THIS GROWING POLLUTION SOURCE
AND WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT IT
HERE- THE U. N. IS IN THE WORLD
BANK OR LOOKING INTO WHAT THEY
CAN DO. AND IN THE DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES IS LARGELY A MATTER
OF. THEY HAVE NO TRASH
COLLECTION. THE PURPOSE OF OUR
HEARING TODAY IS TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT MICROPLASTICS ARE. WHERE
THEY COME FROM HOW THEY'RE
AFFECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT WATER
QUALITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEAR ABOUT THE DIFFERENT PIECES
TO THE PUZZLE WE NEED TO
ASSEMBLE TO MANAGE THIS
POLLUTION SOURCE. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE WITNESSES THAT WE
WILL HAVE WITH US TODAY.
THEY'RE ALL TESTIFIED REMOTELY.
AND AS A RESULT THEY'RE HERE
FROM AROUND THE WORLD-
INCLUDING LONDON. PLEASE NOTE
THAT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
SHARE THEIR VIEWS AGAIN AS WE
SAID BEFORE AT THE END OF THE
HEARING WHEN EVERYONE WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES. TO MAKE A
STATEMENT. BEFORE I GET TO THE
FIRST PANEL. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REBEKAH BAUR CHANGED HANDS THIS
YEAR IN PERSON. AND I WOULD
LIKE- FIRST VICE CHAIR IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT OR TWO OF. CITY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS A
FRESHMAN LEGISLATORS NEWLY
ELECTED I'M HONORED TO BE THE
VICE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND ALL OF US IN THEIR
STAFFS SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
OUR ENVIRONMENT STAYS CLEAN AND
FRESH FOR THE FUTURE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE PRESENTATION
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DOLLY. THANK
YOU I'M ALSO HONORED TO BE
JOINING THIS COMMITTEE IT'S
VERY RELEVANT FOR MY DISTRICT A
FARMER MYSELF AND- LOOKING FOR
TODAY'S PRESENTATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC BECKER REBEKAH BAUR. THE
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TO THANK
YOU IN THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
CAN THIS HEARING TODAY IT'S-
DISCUSSION I REALLY WE'VE BEEN
TAUGHT ABOUT SINCE I JOIN THE
LEGISLATURE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
AND I KNOW AN AREA THAT YOU ARE
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT BUT IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF BOTH. OUR ENVIRONMENT
OUR OFF SHORE- ANIMALS AND THE
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT THEN CONSUME
SOME OF THE ANIMALS THAT LIVE
OFFSHORE SO WE NEED TO GET A
HANDLE ON WHY. THE RATES OF
MICROPLASTICS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA A LOT ON THE WEST
COAST OR SO HIGH AND DO WHAT WE
CAN TO REDUCE THE PREVALENCE OF
IT SENSE I KNOW OTHER COUNTRIES
SUCH AS FRANCE ALREADY TAKEN
STEPS IN THAT DIRECTION AND I
BELIEVE WE WILL BE NEXT. TO
LEAD THE UNITED STATES I THINK
YOU. ALL ON ONE TO ASK MY STE.
IS THERE WAY. THAT ANY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARTS. THE TO
SAN WHO ARE REALLY IS THERE ANY
WAY CAN- MAKE. STATE. RELATED
READ ONLINE. YEAH OKAY YEAH.
YES SHARON THIS IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALBERT'S WHICH YOU CAN
HEAR ME. YES OKAY. WONDERFUL I
JUST WANTED TO SEND MY
GREETINGS FROM BEAUTIFUL
TORRANCE CALIFORNIA AND GLAD TO
BE HERE THANK YOU. GOOD TO HAVE
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. OKAY I WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS HENRY STERN I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M ALLOWED TO AMUSE MYSELF I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW VIOLATED
SIMPLY PROTOCOL RIGHT OUT THE
GATES. BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
COVERING THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC IS- SENATE
WATER CHAIR- WERE VERY KEENLY
INTERESTED IN THIS IS YOUR
MICROPLASTICS BOTH AS IT
APPLIES TO CONSUMER AND PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT ALSO TO AGRICULTURAL
HEALTH WE'RE SHARING. OUR NEW
DATA OUT EVERY DAY AND YOU
STUDY JUST ON IMPACTS ON
AGRICULTURAL SOILS FROM
SYNTHETICS AND IT'S- A TO
MYRIAD AND CONFOUNDING ISSUE
THAT I JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON MISTER CHAIR. WE
OBVIOUSLY OF A PANDEMIC TO
FIGHT IN A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
GOING ON BUT THESE GENDER QUIET
LURKING ISSUES IN THE
BACKGROUND CAN CAN REALLY JUMP
UP TO BITE US IF WE DON'T STAY
AHEAD OF THEM AND SO THANK YOU
FOR STEPPING UP IN AND TAKEN
THE MANTLE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR. WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR- BEING HERE.
ALL RIGHT AND FOR ALL OF THOSE
WHO ARE LOOKING AT REMOTELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
PART IN THIS. ON TO START THE
HEARING OFF I'D LIKE TO INVITE
DOCTOR SCOTT COFFIN. WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TELL US ABOUT THE STATE
WATER BOARDS WORK TO IMPLEMENT
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. AND
THE RESEARCH TO FIND
MICROPLASTICS IN THE CONTEXT OF
DRINKING WATER. I'D LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD
THEIR QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END
OF THE PANEL WHEN WE CAN DIRECT
QUESTIONS TO ALL THREE SPEAKERS-
ONE EXCEPTION WOULD BE IF YOU
REALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND SOME
TECHNOLOGY TERMINOLOGY THAT'S
BEING USED- AND TO GET MY
ATTENTION AND WILL TRY AND ASK
ABOUT THAT I KNOW THAT CAN BE.
I AND I'LL ASK THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SPEAKING- TO- AVOID THE
WORK OF AKRON DEVOID ACRONYMS
AND- AND JARGON AND TRY AND
MAKE THIS- UNDERSTANDABLE TO
ALL. SO DR PROFIT- PLEASE START
YOU HAVE UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES-
FOR YOUR PROTECT FOR YOUR ROUND
PRESENTATION. TWENTY CHAIR-
DOCTOR QUIRK AND IT'S A
PLEASURE TO SPEAK TO YOU ALL
TODAY GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC. MY NAME
IS DR SCOTT KAUFMAN AND I'M A
RESEARCH SCIENTIST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. I'M
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
STATE WATER BOARDS
IMPLEMENTATION OF SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. WHICH
DEALS WITH MICROPLASTICS IN
DRINKING WATER AS WELL FROM
OTHER RELEVANT COMPONENTS THAT
CONNECT TO THIS ISSUE. BY THE
END OF THE STOCK YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND THAT PLASTIC DOES
NOT JUST GO AWAY. AND THAT THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING THROUGH.
THIS BILLS IMPLEMENTATION WILL
ALLOW FOR MORE CONCRETE ACTION
AND SOLUTIONS. PLASTIC I'M NOT
SURE MY SLIDES EXCUSE ME WELL.
THERE WE GO. THE PLASTIC WASTE
CRISIS HAS RECENTLY GAINED
ATTENTION IN THE MEDIA
EVERYWHERE WE LOOK WE SEEM TO
FIND THE SYNTHETIC PARTICLES
FROM THE DEEPEST PART OF THE
OCEAN TO THE TALLEST MOUNTAIN.
IF WE CONTINUE WITH BUSINESS AS
USUAL. WE WILL DOUBLE THE RATE
AT WHICH PLASTIC ENTERS THE
ENVIRONMENT BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY. I SHOWN IN THIS TEAL
LINE ON THIS GRAPH. PLASTIC
DEGRADES IN THE ENVIRONMENT
INTO SMALLER PARTICLES CALLED
MICROPLASTICS. PLASTIC
PARTICLES MAY CONTAMINATE WATER
THROUGH MULTIPLE ROUTES
INCLUDING FOR STORM WATER
WASTEWATER AND ATMOSPHERIC
DEPOSITION JUST TO NAME A FEW.
ONCE IN WATER MICROPLASTICS MAY
SINK AND BECOME SETTLEMENT AS
WELL AS GET RESUSPENDED INTO
THE WATER COLUMN WHERE THEY BE
TAKEN UP INTO WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS AND DRINKING
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WASTE
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS ARE
GENERALLY HIGHLY EFFECTIVE AT
REMOVING MICROPLASTICS WITH
REMOVAL RATES BETWEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AND 99% INTO SLUDGE AS
SHOWN IN THIS DIAGRAM. REMOVAL
RATES VARY BY TREATMENT PROCESS
SEES AS SHOWN HERE WITH THAT
ADD MORE ADVANCED TREATMENT
PROCESSES ARE MOVING MORE. AND
WHEN LOOKING AT THIS FIGURE YOU
MAY BE WONDERING WHERE THE
SLUDGE CODES AND AS AS
MENTIONED EARLIER BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DR CORK- SOME OF IT
ACTUALLY GOES TO AGRICULTURE.
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT NOW SO AFTER PROCESSING A
PORTION OF THE SEWAGE SLUDGE IS
GOOD IS OFTEN CONVERTED INTO
BIOSOLIDS WHICH ARE NUTRIENT
RICH ORGANIC SOLIDS THAT ARE
OFTEN APPLIED TO LAND FOR
GROWING CROPS COMPOSTING OR FOR
DEEP WELL INJECTION TROUPE
PRODUCED RENEWABLE ENERGY. DUE
TO THEIR POINT NATURE AND
PERSISTENCE IN THE ENVIRONMENT
MICROPLASTICS CUMULATE AND TOP
SOILS AND ARE FOUND IN HIGH
QUANTITIES AND FIELDS WITH
APPLIED BIOSOLIDS. ONE RECENT
STUDY ESTIMATED THAT BETWEEN
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND AND THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TONS OF
MICROPLASTICS INTO AGRICULTURAL
EVERY YEAR IN NORTH AMERICA
ALONE. I SHOWN HERE THE OTHERS
THE MICROPLASTICS IN COMPOST
WHICH MAY ALSO BE A RELEVANT
SOURCE FOR AGRICULTURAL FIELDS.
NOW WHAT HAPPENS CHIU PLANS
WHEN THEY'RE EXPOSED TO
MICROPLASTICS AND SOIL. WE KNOW
THAT PLANTS MAKE UP TAKE AND
ACCUMULATE SMALL MICROPLASTICS
THROUGH THEIR ROOTS AS
VISUALIZED BY THESE GREEN
FLUORESCENT LABELED
MICROPLASTICS. EXPOSURE TO
MICROPLASTICS BECAUSE REDUCED
PLANT GROWTH. DUE TO ROOF
DAMAGE AS SHOWN IN THIS RECENT
STUDY IN TWENTY TWENTY. AT HIGH
ENOUGH CONCENTRATIONS
MICROPLASTICS HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
MATURE TOMATOES HOWEVER MORE
RESEARCH IS NEEDED TO DETERMINE
WHAT IMPACTS TO AGRICULTURE
EXIST- AND BASED ON THIS
LIMITED EVIDENCE IT'S CLEAR
THAT WE CANNOT DEPEND ENTIRELY
ON WASTEWATER TREATMENT TO
SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
MICROPLASTICS POLLUTION. AS
DOING SO MAY CREATE ADDITIONAL
PROBLEMS WITH ACCUMULATION AND
AGRICULTURAL FIELDS WHICH MAY
THREATEN FOOD SECURITY. SO DUE
TO THE WIDESPREAD CONTAINMENT
OF MIKE CAN DUE TO THE
WIDESPREAD CONTAMINATION OF
MICROPLASTICS IT IS
UNSURPRISING YET STARTLING. AT
THE FIRST STUDY TO MONITOR FOR
MICROPLASTICS IN TAP WATER BOND
SUCH PARTICLES IN 83% OF
SAMPLES WORLDWIDE AND 94% OF
SAMPLES IN THE UNITED STATES.
THESE FINDINGS CAUSED CONCERN
FOR POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO HUMAN
HEALTH. AND PROMPTED THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO PASS
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WHICH REQUIRES
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO FIRST
DEFINE MICROPLASTICS BY JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY. IN
ADOPTED STANDARD ANALYTICAL
METHOD PROVIDE ACCREDITATION
FOR LABORATORIES CONSIDER
ADOPTING HEALTH BASED GUIDANCE
LEVEL. AND A DOCTOR PLAN TO
REFORM FOR YEARS OF TESTING AND
ANALYSIS BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MICHAEL IS NO
TRIVIAL TASK AS THIS
CONTAMINANTS. IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE IN THE NUMBER OF
PARTICLE SHAPES SIZES COLORS
AND ASSOCIATED CONTAMINANTS
THAT OCCUR WITHIN THIS MISS
UNIVERSE OF MICROPLASTICS.
DESPITE THESE DIFFICULTIES THE
STATE WATER BOARD ADOPTED THE
WORLD'S FIRST REGULATORY
DEFINITION OF MICROPLASTICS ON
JUNE SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY. THIS
DEFINITION IS BROAD AND
INCLUDES PARTICLES BETWEEN ONE
NANOMETER AND FIVE THOUSAND
MICROMETERS WITH AN ADDITIONAL
SIZE BASED CLASSIFICATION
SCHEME SHOWN HERE. THE POLYMER
IS INCLUDED IN THIS REGULATORY
DEFINITION INCLUDE PLASTICS
WITH NUMBERS ONE THROUGH SEVEN
ON THE BOTTOM SHOWN HERE. AS
WELL AS SYNTHETIC POLYMERS THAT
MAY NOT BE TYPICALLY REFERRED
TO AS PLASTIC INCLUDING
SYNTHETIC RUBBER FIBERS
SILICONES BIOBASED AND
BIODEGRADABLE POLYMERS AS WELL
AS CELLULOSE ACETATE WHICH IS
COMMONLY FOUND IN CIGARETTE
FILTERS. WHILE THE STATE WATER
BOARDS DEFINITION OF
MICROPLASTICS IS THE FIRST
REGULATORY DEFINITION FOR THE
PURPOSES OF DRINKING WATER HE
WAS INFORMED BY ATTRACT
DEFINITION IN EUROPE. IN
CHEMICAL AGENCIES DEFINITION
WHICH IS DESIGNED FOR PROPOSED
RESTRICTION ON INTENTIONALLY
ADDED MICROPLASTICS TO CONSUMER
PRODUCTS. PROVIDES AN EXCLUSION
FOR BIODEGRADABLE PLASTICS THE
STATE WATER BOARDS DEFINITION
INCLUDES BIODEGRADABLE PLASTICS
BASED ON A LACK OF EVIDENCE FOR
HUMAN SAFETY. RATIONALE FOR
INCLUDING BIODEGRADABLE
POLYMERS INCLUDED IT
UNDERSTANDING THAT
MICROPLASTICS CAN TRANSFER
HARMFUL CHEMICALS DURING
EXPOSURE. SOME OF THESE
CHEMICALS THAT DISRUPT THE
ENDOCRINE SYSTEM AND CAUSE
HARMFUL EFFECTS OF VERY LOW
CONCENTRATIONS. I EXAMPLE YOU
MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH IT IS
BUSY YOU KNOW HEY WHICH MIMICS
THE NATURAL HORMONE ESTROGEN
CAUSING IMBALANCES IN THE BODY
WE CAN SEE HEAR AND READ THE
PART OF THE CHEMICAL THAT LOOKS
QUITE SIMILAR TO THE NATURAL
HORMONE ESTROGEN AND YOU CAN
SEE THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER
PLASTIC ADDITIVES THAT RESEMBLE
ESTROGEN IN COSTS SIMILAR FACTS.
ANOTHER IN THE CONSTRUCTOR IS
UP PVD WHICH IS A FLAME
RETARDANT. AT IT'S COMMONLY
FOUND AND IN PLASTIC. AND
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND ONE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN PVD EXPOSURE
CAUSED MORE INTELLECTUAL THIS
DISABILITIES. IN PESTICIDES
MERCURY AND LEAD COMBINED IN
THE UNITED STATES. THESE HELP
BURDENS LEAD TO MORE THAN THREE
TRILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
DAMAGES. AB DE AND OTHER FLAME
RETARDANTS ARE FOUND IN MANY OF
THE PLASTIC ITEMS IN OUR HOMES
INCLUDING INSULATION
UPHOLSTERED FURNITURE CARPET
AND EVEN SOME BABY PRODUCTS SO
WHEN WE'RE EXPOSED TO
MICROPLASTICS THAT HAVE BEEN
TREATED WITH DVD AND OTHER
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTORS THIS MAY
BE A RELEVANT ROUTE OF EXPOSURE
FROM THESE. HARMFUL CHEMICALS.
THE PRESENCE OF HARMFUL
CHEMICALS LIKE PVD IS AND OTHER
COULD INTEGRATE DISRUPTORS IN
BIOPLASTICS HAVE NOT BEEN
THOROUGHLY TESTED. IN GENERAL
BIOPLASTICS ARE NEW TECHNOLOGY
THAT HAVE NOT UNDERGONE
RIGOROUS HEALTH TESTING. A
RECENT STUDY CHARACTERIZED
TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT LEACH FROM
BIOPLASTICS USING A VARIETY OF
TECHNIQUES INCLUDING ANALYTICAL
CHEMISTRY AND BIOLOGY. THIS
STUDY FOUND THAT CONVENTIONAL
PETROLEUM BASED PLASTIC
PRODUCTS ASSURANT LAST RELEASED
A SIMILAR QUANTITIES OF
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTING CHEMICALS
AS BIOPLASTICS STARTED THE
RIGHT. THIS REACHES THIS
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT WE
CANNOT CONSIDER MICROPLASTICS
GENERATED FROM BIOPLASTICS OR
CONVENTIONAL PLASTICS TO BE
SAFE FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION. BIG
DUE TO A LACK OF RIGOROUS
TESTING AND THE WIDESPREAD
OCCURRENCE OF THESE HARMFUL
ADDITIVES. NOW THAT WE'VE
DEFINED MICROPLASTICS WE DON'T
HAVE A COMMON STARTING POINT
FOR DEVELOPING METHODS AND
UNDERSTANDING HUMAN HEALTH
IMPACTS. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO REQUIRES THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO ADOPT A STANDARD
ANALYTICAL METHOD FOR
MONITORING MICROPLASTICS IN
DRINKING WATER BY JULY FIRST.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO STANDARD
METHODS AVAILABLE. STANDARD
METHODS OF MONITORING ARM
PORTENT BECAUSE WHEN WE CAN
MONITOR THE ISSUE WE CAN MANAGE
THE ISSUE. TO FILL THIS GAP
WE'RE WORKING WITH FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD TO DEVELOP AND
STANDARDIZE METHODOLOGY TO
MONITOR MICROPLASTICS IN
DRINKING WATER. AS WELL AS
OCEAN WATER FISH TISSUE AND
SEDIMENT USING A VARIETY OF
ANALYTICAL INSTRUMENTS.
PARTICIPATING ORGANIZATIONS ARE
FROM MULTIPLE SECTORS INCLUDING
ACADEMIA GOVERNMENT INDUSTRY
AND NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WITH JUST A FEW
OF THOSE REPRESENTED HERE.
AFTER STANDARDIZING METHODS THE
STATE WATER BOARD WILL PROVIDE
ACCREDITATION FOR LABORATORIES
ACCREDITATION WILL BE CARRIED
OUT BY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LABORATORY ACCREDITATION
PROGRAM WHICH IS PART OF THE
STATE WATER BOARD.
ACCREDITATION IS VITAL TO
ENSURING THAT RESULTS BETWEEN
LABORATORIES ARE COMPATIBLE.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE STATE
WATER BOARD CONSIDER ADOPTING A
HEALTH BASED GUIDANCELEVEL EAT
CONSUMERS INTERPRETING THEIR
CONCENTRATIONS IN DRINKING
WATER. IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THE HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS
FROM INGESTION OF MICROPLASTICS
ARE NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD YET.
WE'RE ADDRESSING THIS KNOWLEDGE
GAP BY WORKING WITH A NUMBER OF
RESEARCH PARTNERS AND EXPERTS
TO EVALUATE TOXICITY DATA AND
DEVELOP THRESHOLDS FOR DRINKING
WATER AND AQUATIC ECOSYSTEMS AS
WELL. BUT IT STARTED IN OCTOBER
AND WILL BE FINISHED BY PEOPLE
OF THIS YEAR. SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE THERE'S BEEN A SHARP
RISE IN THE NUMBER OF TOXICITY
STUDIES OR MICROPLASTICS FOR
BOTH THE ENVIRONMENT AND HUMAN
HEALTH. IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF HUMAN RELATED
TOXICITIES DOUBLES DOUBLED. IN
ONE YEAR. THIS RECENT EVIDENCE
ALLOWS US TO ACTUALLY CONSIDER
IMPACTS TO HUMANS. WHILE MANY
QUESTIONS REMAIN EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT SMALLER
MICROPLASTIC PARTICLES ARE MORE
TOXIC TO HUMANS. A RECENT STUDY
FOUND THAT FOUR OUT OF SIX
HUMAN PLACENTAS CONTAINED
MICROPLASTICS PROVIDING
EVIDENCE THAT THESE PARTICLES
ACCUMULATE IN THE HUMAN BODY
AND ARE NOT JUST RAPIDLY
EXCRETED. NOTABLY ONLY
PARTICLES SMALLER THAN TEN
MICROMETERS WERE FOUND IN THE
SAMPLES. EVIDENCE FOR THE HUMAN
HEALTH IMPACTS OF SMALLER
PARTICLES WILL BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN DEVELOPING
OUR PLAN FOR FOUR YEARS OF
TESTING AND ANALYSIS AND
DRINKING WATER AS REQUIRED BY
SENATE BILL. FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO. MICROPLASTIC PARTICLES
SMALLER THAN TEN MICROMETERS
ARE NOT ONLY BELIEVED TO BE
MORE TOXIC TO HUMANS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY'RE ALSO MORE
LIKELY TO OCCUR IN DRINKING
WATER. RECENT STUDIES
MONITORING MICROPLASTICS A
DIFFERENT TREATMENT STAGES AND-
DRINKING WATER TREATMENT PLANT.
FOUNDED THAT. HAS TREATMENT
INCREASES CONCENTRATIONS
CONCENTRATIONS OF
MICROPLASTICS. MICROPLASTICS
DECREASE STARTING FROM RAW
WATER ON THE LEFT IS SHOWN IN
THIS FIGURE TO FINISH DRINKING
WATER ON THE RIGHT. WELL
TREATMENT REMOVES THE MAJORITY
OF MICROPLASTICS. THESE THESE
PARTICLES SMALLER THAN TEN
MICRONS TEND TO REMAIN AND- I
GUESS THESE PARTICLES ARE
ACTUALLY THE MOST DIFFICULT TO
MONITOR ANALYTICALLY SO ANOTHER
CHALLENGE. MICROPLASTICS ARE
FOUND IN DRINKING WATER AT
RELATIVE PROPORTIONS THAT ARE
SIMILAR TO THOSE OF PLASTICS
AND COMMERCE SUGGESTING THAT
THE ORIGIN OF THESE PARTICLES
ARE LIKELY SINGLE USE PRODUCTS
AND TEXTILES. SO IN CONCLUSION
BOSTICK BREAKS DOWN INTO
SMALLER PARTICLES ENVIRONMENT
AND CAN CONTAMINATE WATER AND
LAND THESE PARTICLES ARE
EVERYWHERE AND THEY DO NOT JUST
GO AWAY. THE STATE WATER BOARDS
REGULATORY DEFINITION
STANDARDIZED METHODS AND%
LABORATORY ACCREDITATION
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED CONSISTENCY
FOR THE FIELD. WHAT ONE
THIRTIES REMAIN IN REGARD TO
HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS THE
EVIDENCE IS INCREASING RAPIDLY
AND WE WILL LEARN MORE IMPACTS-
IT A VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
SO THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
AGAIN TO SPEAK TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWER ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE- THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD THIS
BRIEFING AS WELL AND IT IS
SCARIER THAN I THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE- SENATOR BEN ALLEN HAS
JOINED US. SENATOR DO YOU WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT AND THEN
PERHAPS IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS- WILL DO WILL DEAL
WITH THEM AT THE END OF THE
PANELS- DO I MAKE A COMMENT.
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS AN THEIR ISSUE IT'S
VERY CLOSE TO MY- INTERESTED
IN- FOR ALL THE REASONS JUST
ARTICULATED AND SHOCKING DATA
FOR UP 26% OF. YEAH SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET
SOME SERIOUS WORKED ON THIS
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THEN OUR
NEXT PANELIST- WE'RE GOING TO
GO. DR REBECCA SUTTON SUTTON
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO ESTUARY
INSTITUTE TO DISCUSS FINDINGS
FROM THEIR STUDY UNDERSTANDING
MICROPLASTIC LEVELS PATHWAYS
AND TRANSPORT INTO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY REGION THIS IS
TRULY HEROIC WORK. UP UNTIL
NOW- PEOPLE ARE SORT OF ASSUMED
THAT PLASTIC STANDARD MEANT
ENTERED THE ENVIRONMENT. THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY MEASURE WHAT PLASTICS
GETTING IN- FROM WHICH WE CAN
GUESS WHAT THE SOURCES ARE. AND
YOU KNOW IT'S REAL DATA IT'S
NOT SOMEBODY'S GAS. IT'S REAL
DATA AND WHILE THIS WAS DONE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE BAY IN THE
ESTUARY- I BELIEVE THAT. WE CAN
LEARN MUCH ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
TO OUR RIVERS THE SACRAMENTO
AND SAN JOAQUIN RIVER UP FROM
WHAT ENTRIES HERE BECAUSE THE
SOURCES ARE GOING TO BE
SIMILAR- THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO WITH THAT OF DR SUTTON THANK
YOU FOR THIS YEAR EXCELLENT
WORK AND PLEASE THE PROJECT AND
YOU HAVE UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT AND VERY GENEROUS
INTRODUCTION WE ARE VERY PROUD
OF THIS THREE YEAR EFFORT THAT
I'LL BE SHARING WITH YOU I'M
WITH SAM SISCO ASSURANCE TO.
AND WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
AQUATIC ECOSYSTEM SCIENCE
INSTITUTE LOCATED IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA. THIS EFFORT IS A
COLLABORATION WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO ONE OF
OUR LABOR SPEAKERS IS FROM
THERE AND WITH THE FIVE GYRES
INSTITUTE WARNED. OUR WORK HERE
IS PART OF SFE EYES OVERALL
MISSION TO PROVIDE SCIENTIFIC
SUPPORT AND TOOLS FOR DECISION
MAKING. SO THIS IS WHY WE WANT
TO BRING THIS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO ALL OF YOU. SO
QUICK WE WILL TALK ABOUT ALL
THE MONITORING. SKEWS ME JUST
TRYING TO GET OUT THERE WE GOT
GOT MY FLIGHT ADVANCED ALL
RIGHT LET'S TALK ABOUT STUDY
DESIGN WE DID A WHOLE LOT OF
MONITORING AS PART OF THIS BIG
THREE YEAR EFFORT. SO FOR THE
BAY. WE LOOK AT MICRO PLASTICS
IN THE SURFACE WATER SEEM DISKO
BAY. WE ALSO LOOK AT MICRO
PLASTICS IN THE SEDIMENT AT THE
BOTTOM. AND THEN WE CUT FASHION
WE EXTRACTED BIVALVES ARE
FILTER FEEDERS FROM THE BAY AND
LOOK AT MICRO PLASTICS IN THESE
TISSUES AS WELL. WE WENT OUT
THE GOLDEN GATE AND WE DID
MONITORING OF THE SURFACE WATER
IN THE NATIONAL MARINE
SANCTUARIES. AND THEN WE WENT
UPSTREAM HOW WE LOOK AT THE
POLLUTION PATHWAYS SO THESE ARE
WATER CENTER BEING DISCHARGED
TO THE BANK AND FROM WHICH SOME
OF THESE MICROPLASTICS MIGHT BE
DIRECT SO. WE LOOKED AT WASTE
WATER THAT'S ALL THE DOWN THE
DRAIN DISCHARGES THAT GO TO THE
SEWER SYSTEM THE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT FACILITY THERE'S A
LOT OF TREATMENT A LOT OF
REMOVAL OF MICROPLASTICS AND
THEN THAT TREATED WASTE WATER
IS DISCHARGED TO THE BAY. WE
ALSO LOOK AT STORMONT- NO
THAT'S THE RAINFALL THAT HITS
OUR STREETS IN OUR LANDSCAPES
AND FROM THERE MOST OF THE
STORM DRAIN OR THE CREEK OR THE
STREAM. AND THEN ENDS UP IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY LARGELY UNTREATED.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S THE
MONITORING WE DID WHAT DID WE
FIND. WE FOUND HIGH LEVELS OF
MICROPLASTICS IN BAY WATER AND
SEDIMENT RELATIVE TO OTHER
WATER BODIES NEAR BIG URBAN
CENTERS. THIS LITTLE BAR CHART
IS OUR SURFACE WATER ABUNDANCE
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT OUR MAJOR
EFFORT IN TWENTY NINETEEN AS
WELL AS A PILOT STUDY IN THE
WET SEASON OF TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SHOW MUCH HIGHER LEVELS OF
MICROPLASTICS COMPARED TO OTHER
MAJOR WATER BODIES WHERE WE
HAVE SIMILAR KINDS OF DATA
DEVELOPED SO FAR. SO WHAT WE
THINK IS GOING ON HERE IS THAT
WE'VE GOT A REALLY DENSE URBAN
POPULATION AROUND THE DAY.
WE'VE ALSO GOT WELL YOU COULD
SAY THE BAY IS A SMALLER WATER
BODY COMPARED TO SOMETHING BIG
LIKE A GREAT LAKE. AND THEN WE
GOT THIS CONSTRAINT INTERCHANGE
WITH THE PACIFIC OCEAN SO
LITTLE LAST FLASHING AND
DILUTION. AND THESE FACTORS
TOGETHER TO MAKE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY A VALUABLE PLACE
TO LOOK FOR THESE PERSISTENT
CONTAMINANTS THEY CAN REALLY
BUILD UP SOME PLASTIC CAN BUILD
UP IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE TYPES OF
PARTICLES WE SAW. WE SAW A LOT
OF FIBERS. ARE STILL ALMOST
THREE QUARTERS OF THE PARTICLES
WE SON SURFACE WATER OR FIBERS
AND THEN CLOSE TO TWO THIRDS
AROUND TWO THIRDS IN SENTIMENT.
YOU CAN HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT FIBERS ON AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE OTHER TYPES OF PARTICLES
WE SAW. IT ALSO TURNS OUT THE
FISSION BIBLES WERE. PRIMARILY
INGESTING OR- HAD IN THEIR GUTS
FIBERS. SO THESE TWO BY BART
YEAH HI CHARTS ARE ON THE LEFT
IS A COUPLE OFFICIALLY EXAMINED
ON THE RIGHT IT'S THE COUPLE OF
FILTER FEEDERS AND BOTH OF THEM
ARE LARGELY THE BLUE COLOR
SIGNIFYING FIBERS WERE THAT
CONTENTS OF THAT THE TISSUES
THAT WE EXAMINED SO NOT ONLY
ARE THESE FIBERS IN OUR
RETIREMENT BUT THEY SEEM TO BE
INGESTED. BY THE ORGANISMS THAT
WE EXAMINE SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
WE'RE GOOD FIBERS BECOMING FROM.
ONE PATHWAY IT'S ALREADY SEEN
SOME SOME GOOD WORK HERE AND
ELSEWHERE IS THINKING ABOUT
FIBERS COMING THROUGH
WASTEWATER AND SO THIS GETS TO
THE FACT WE HAVE A LOT OF
SYNTHETIC GARMENTS IN OUR LIVES
ENHANCE WE THROW OUR SYNTHETIC
TEXTILES IN THE WASHING
MACHINE. THERE'S THE ABRASION
AND THAT CAN LEAD TO SOME
SHEDDING OF FIBERS THAT GOES
INTO THE WASH WATER AND THEN
HEADS TO THE TREATMENT FACILITY.
NOT TRIMMING CAMERA REMOVE A
LOT OF MICROPLASTICS WE
MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT ALREADY-
BUT THERE IS SOME LEVEL THAT
REMAINS IN THE TREATED WATER
GETS DISCHARGED TO THE BANK. SO
FOR OUR STUDY WE LOOKED AT THE
EIGHT LARGEST FACILITIES JUST
CHARGING TO THE BANK AND WE DID
FIND MICROPLASTICS IN THESE AT
IN THE SAMPLES. ARE AVERAGE
LEVELS OF POINT ZERO SIX
PARTICLES PER LITER AND FIBERS
BEING COMMENT SO THIS SUPPORTS
THE IDEA THAT FIBERS AND OTHER
MICROPLASTICS CAN END UP IN THE
BAY. THROUGH THE PATHWAY OF
WASTE WATER. THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY PATHWAY ACTUALLY STORM
WATER TURNED OUT TO BE A BIT OF
A SURPRISE FOR US A MUCH BIGGER
DEAL. SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
STORMWATER SAMPLES WE SAW FAR
HIGHER CONCENTRATIONS OF ALL
THE PARTICLES FIBRES IN ON
FIBERS IN OUR STORMWATER
COMPARED TO OUR WASTE WATER.
NOW THIS ACTUALLY MAKES SENSE
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT STORM WATER NINE GENERAL
GENERALLY IN THE BAY AREA AND
IN MUCH OF CALIFORNIA IS NOT
TREATED SO THERE'S NO CHANCE
FOR THE PARTICLES TO SETTLE OUT
OR BE REMOVED THROUGH TREATMENT
AND SO THAT THEY CAN RUSH RIGHT
INTO WATERWAYS. NOW WE CAN TAKE
THESE KIND OF CONCENTRATIONS
AND WE CAN PLUG THEM INTO
MODELS TO TRYING TO COME UP
WITH THE- ANNUAL DISCHARGE OF
THE ANNUAL LOAN FROM EACH OF
THESE PATHWAYS TO THE DAY. AND
SO WHEN WE MADE THESE ARE
MODELING ESTIMATES. WE
DETERMINED AN ESTIMATE OF
SEVENTEEN BILLION MICROPLASTIC
PARTICLES ENTERING THE BASE
YOUR WASTE WATER. WHEN WE GET
AT A DIFFERENT CALCULATION FOR
STORMWATER. IS THAT RAINFALL
THAT RUNS THROUGH THE
LANDSCAPE. WE ACTUALLY GOT A
FINAL US SEVEN TRILLION. STICKS
AND THESE MODELS THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ASSUMPTIONS THAT GOES
THAT GO INTO THESE MODELS AND
YOU CAN ADJUST THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS BUT NO MATTER HOW
WE ADJUSTED THEM. WE STILL SAW
THAT STORM WATER AND
DISCHARGING OVER THREE HUNDRED
TIMES MORE MICRO PLASTICS AND
WASTEWATER. SO ALTHOUGH THESE
PATHWAYS ARE IMPORTANT THIS
STUDY REALLY OPENED OUR EYES TO
STORMWATER WHICH HAD NOT BEEN.
INVESTIGATED VERY MUCH IN THE
LITERATURE AND SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO DO SOME FOLLOW UP
WORK FUNDED BY THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO TRYING TO
EXAMINE POTENTIAL SOURCES FOR
STORMWATER. THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL ALSO FUNDING
A STUDY ON MICRO PLASTICS AND
WASTEWATER SO A LOT OF EFFORT
HERE TO UNDERSTAND THESE
PATHWAYS BECAUSE IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT THAT. THE PARTICLES
IN THE PATHWAYS MAYBE WE CAN
GET THESE PARTICLES OUT OF THE
PATHWAYS AND PROTECT OUR WATERS.
NOW ONE OF THE TYPES OF
PARTICLE IT WE SOUGHT
ESPECIALLY IN STORMWATER. ALSO
IN OUR BASEMENT WHERE THESE
BLACK REVEREND FRAGMENTS AND WE
BELIEVE MANY OF THESE ARE
DERIVED FROM TIRES. AND THIS IS
PART OF ACTUAL THAT THAT. DON'T
THE NECESSARY FUNCTION OF TIRES
YOU KNOW THE GRIP ON THE ROAD
THIS IS HOW THE TIRES ARE
KEEPING US SAFE BUT IT ALSO. AS
THE TIRES RIVING IT'S SHEDDING
LITTLE BITS OF ROBERT AND THESE
CAN BE WASHED INTO WATERWAYS WE
SAW HIGH LEVELS IN OUR STORM
WATER ALMOST HALF THE PARTICLES
WERE THESE BLACK REFEREE
FRAGMENTS. LET'S COME TIMES
EXTRA IMPORTANT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE INGREDIENTS IN THE
RIVER. JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO A
BIG STUDY CAME OUT IN SCIENCE
WE GOT TO BE INVOLVED WITH IT
WHERE SITE TEAM OF SCIENTISTS
IN WASHINGTON STATE IDENTIFY A
SPECIFIC PRESERVATIVE CHEMICAL
ENTIRE RIVER. THAT TRANSFORMS
IN THE ENVIRONMENT TO AN
EXTREMELY LETHAL TOXICANT FOR
CO HOSTING AND- CALL SALMON ARE
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED IN A
NUMBER OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRIBUTARIES. OUR ROLE IN THIS
STUDY WE GRAB SOME STORM WATER
SAMPLES FROM THE BAY AREA THESE
DREAMS DO NOT SUPPORT COHO- BUT
WHEN WE SENT THESE SAMPLES TO
THE LAB THANK FOUND LETHAL
LEVELS UNDER TIRE CONTAMINANT
IN THESE IN THESE BAY AREA
STORMWATER SAMPLES SO THIS IS
IMPORTANT. I STRESSOR THAT THAT
MUST BE CONSIDERED IN ANY
STREAM WHERE CALL HOW ARE
CURRENTLY LIVING OR WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE REINTRODUCED WE WOULD
CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THIS. CHEMICAL STRESSOR WERE
NOT CAUSING PROBLEMS. FOR COHO
POPULATIONS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THESE PARTICLES IS
NOT JUST PHYSICAL CONTAMINANTS
BUT ALSO AS CARRIERS OF TOXIC
INGREDIENTS. I TURNED OUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL IS TAKING A LOOK AT
TIRE INGREDIENTS AS PART OF
THEIR SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM. YES SOME ATTENTION IN
PARTICULAR ON THIS PRESERVATIVE
AGENT THAT'S JUST BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS THE SOURCE OF
THIS CALL HOME TOXICANT. AND SO.
WHAT A GREAT OUTCOME FOR THIS
KIND OF EFFORT COULD BE AT TIRE
MADE US SAFER INGREDIENTS AND
THAT WAY EVEN IF IT'S SHUTTING
LITTLE BITS OF PLASTIC OR
RUBBER IN THESE THESE. PIECES
OUT OF. RIGHT CONTAMINATION ARE
NOT HARMING THE WILD. NOW WE
SAW OTHER SOURCES OF
MICROPLASTICS AS WELL BESIDES
THE TIRES OBVIOUSLY MENTION
FIBERS WE SEE POLYESTER ACRYLIC
MANY OF THE SORT OF CLOTHING
TYPE FIBERS IN OUR CLOSETS
TODAY. DOCTOR COTTON MENTIONED
CELLULOSE ACETATE ARE BACK CAN
BE IN CIGARETTE FILTERS SO WE
SAW THE NUMBER SIX RANKED
CELLULOSE ACETATE FIBERS THAT
COULD BE DERIVED FROM CIGARETTE
POLLUTION. WE DID SEE SOME
MICROBEADS AS WELL IN OUR WASTE
WATER I NOW IN THE US.
MICROBEADS ARE BANNED AND RINSE
OFF PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS. SO
THESE MICROBEADS COULD BE
DERIVED FROM OLDER PRODUCTS
STILL IN USE OR PERHAPS FROM A
TYPE OF PRODUCT THAT'S OUTSIDE
THAT RINSE OFF PERSONAL USE. OR
PERSONAL CARE GROUPING OF
PRODUCTS. AND THEN FINALLY WE
SAW PARTICLES THAT COULD BE
DERIVED FROM SINGLE USE
PLASTICS OF THIS LITTLE EXAMPLE
UP HERE IT'S THAT SOME PHONES
POLYSTYRENE SO YOU COULD
IMAGINE THAT COULD BE DERIVED
FROM YOU KNOW SOME THAT FOAM
PACKAGING SURROUNDING A PRODUCT
FOR PROTECTIONOR PERHAPS AT.
FOAM TAKEOUT CONTAINER- SO WE
SEE PARTICLES LIKE THAT THAT
COULD BE RELATED TO SINGLE USE
PLASTIC IN OUR PAIN FACT. SO
JUST TO SUMMARIZE THE KEY
FINDINGS HERE- WE DID SEE HIGH
LEVELS OF MICROPLASTICS IN OUR
SAN FRANCISCO BAY. FIBERS WERE
PARTICULARLY WIDESPREAD AMONG
THE DIVERSE TYPES OF PARTICLES
WE OBSERVED. WE SEE STORM WATER
ISN'T AS AN IMPORTANT PATHWAY
FOR FURTHER WORK IN ONE THAT
HASN'T BEEN STUDIED QUITE AS
MUCH AS WASTE WATER YEAH.
EVERYTHING OF TIRES AS A SOURCE
OF MICROPLASTICS AS WELL AS
TOXIC CHEMICALS SO WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO THINK ABOUT.
NOT JUST THESE PHYSICAL
PARTICLES BUT THE INGREDIENTS
THAT MAKE UP THE PLASTIC. IF WE
CAN MAKE PLASTIC LESS TOXIC
THAN THE MICROPLASTICS
THEMSELVES WILL ALSO BE LESS
TOXIC TO OUR WILD WHICH- I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR STUDY
FUNDERS. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THERE'S A U. R. L. UP
THERE FOR MANY MORE DETAILS ON
THIS LARGE STUDY FINDINGS AND
THIS IS MY FINAL SLIDE IF THAT.
IF THAT COAST WANTS TO TAKE
BACK THE SELECTION. ALL THANK
YOU FOR THAT EXCELLENT- TALK ON
THE EXCELLENT WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE- THE NEXT SPEAKER IS
DOCTOR VIOLENT. DR VIOLET
ROENICK WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
SANITATION TO TALK TO US ABOUT.
WHAT IS KNOWN OF MICROPLASTICS
BEING FOUND IN WASTEWATER- SO
DR ROENICK YOU MADE UP FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WHICH I SEE YOU HAVE UP ON THE
SCREEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO REMEMBER DR QUIRK AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE INVITATION AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
AND THANK YOU ALSO TO ALL OF MY
FELLOW PANELISTS. MY NAME IS
VIOLET ROENICK I'M A SENIOR
SCIENTIST AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA. I'VE SPENT THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WORKING ON
MICROPLASTICS WERE FOCUSED MY
ATTENTION TO HELP DEVELOP
METHODS TO MEASURE THESE
PARTICLES. AND I'VE WORKED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THIS EMERGING
CONTAMINANT WASTE WATER AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND TODAY MY GOAL
IS TO PRESENT A BRIEF SUMMARY
OF WHAT WE KNOW AND WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE PREVALENCE
OF MICROPLASTICS IN WASTE WATER.
THE ORANGE COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT OR OC ST PROVIDES
WASTEWATER COLLECTION TREATMENT
AND RECYCLING SERVICES FOR OVER
TWO POINT SIX MILLION PEOPLE.
OF CENTRAL AND NORTHERN ORANGE
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA. WE TREAT
OVER A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
MILLION GALLONS PER DAY OR AND
GT. AND ARE PROUD PARTNERS WITH
THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT IN THE PRODUCTION OF
OVER A HUNDRED M. GT. OF
TREATED RECYCLED WATER FOR OUR
GROUNDWATER REPLENISHMENT
SYSTEM. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF MANY OF OUR WORK AS
A RESOURCE RECOVERY AGENCY. AND
WE'RE ALSO MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES ARE KASA.
AN AGENCY THAT'S BEEN A STRONG
AND EARLY SUPPORTER OF
MICROPLASTIC POLICIES. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN COSTA CO
SPONSORED SENATE BILL TWELVE
SIXTY THREE THE STATEWIDE
MICROPLASTICS STRATEGY AUTHORED
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO. AS WELL
AS THE TWENTY FIFTEEN STATEWIDE
BAN ON MICROPLASTICS. THE CORE
OF ASSISTANCE MISSION CENTERS
ON THE PROTECTION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT
OUR ROLE AS ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDS AND OUR MISSION HAS
BEEN OF PARTICULAR DRIVING
FORCE MOTIVATING US TO
INVESTIGATE MICROPLASTICS AS AN
EMERGING ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE.
AND WE CREDIT A LOT OF OUR
SUCCESS IN THE QUALITY OF OUR
DISCHARGE TO OUR EXTENSIVE
SOURCE CONTROL PROGRAM WHICH I
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AS JUST
ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT WE USE TO
PREVENT CONTAMINANTS FROM
ENTERING OUR TREATMENT PLANTS
IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO BEFORE
WE DISCUSS THE PREVALENCE OF
MICROPLASTICS IN WASTE WATER I
DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT THE BIG PICTURE. AND
CONSIDER ALL THE WAYS THAT
MICROPLASTIC CAN ENTER THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS ON THIS GRAPHIC MADE BY
FELLOW PANELIST DR CHELSEA
ROCKMAN THAT DEPICTS THE
DIVERSITY AND SOURCES AND
PATHWAYS OF MICROPLASTIC. AND
HERE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THESE WO TERMS- OR
SOURCES ARE WHERE MICROPLASTICS
ARE PRODUCED AND ORIGINATE. AND
WHERE THE PATHWAYS HERE BELOW
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TRANSPORTING MICROPLASTICS FROM
THEIR SOURCE TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
PATHWAYS CAN INCLUDE RIVERS AND
WINS ATMOSPHERIC DEPOSITION
DIRECT IMPORTS DIFFERENT TYPES
OF RUNOFF AND WASTEWATER OF
COURSE. AND ONE LAST THING I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSCORE HERE IS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF DEGRADED AND
MISMANAGED WASTE AND LITTER IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE EVERY PIECE
OF MICROPLASTIC THAT MAY ONE
DAY BE A SOURCE OF MICROPLASTIC
IN THE ENVIRONMENT. AND I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AND APPLIED
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
OPC FOR THEIR RECENT UNVEILING
OF RECOMMENDED ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS PLASTIC POLLUTION AND
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL AND MARINE
ECOSYSTEM. THIS IS REALLY A
BOLD AND NECESSARY STEP TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM AND WE HOPE
TO SEE MORE OF THIS. SO IT
SWITCHING GEARS NOW TO WASTE
WATER SPECIFICALLY WHAT DO WE
KNOW. WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANTS OUR RECEIVERS OF
MICROPLASTICS FROM DOMESTIC
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
UPSTREAM SOURCES. USING
CONVENTIONAL WASTEWATER
TREATMENT TECHNOLOGIES THEY ARE
ABLE TO REMOVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF MICROPLASTICS FROM
ROSTER WHICH WHICH I'LL DISCUSS
IN MORE DETAIL IN A FEW SITES.
BUT THEY WERE NOT DESIGNED FOR
THIS PURPOSE THEY WERE DESIGNED
FOR HUMAN WASTE WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT CONCEPT WHEN
UNDERSTANDING THEIR ROLE. NOW
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF MICROPLASTIC BETTER
CONVEYED OR CAN BE CONVEYED TO
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
AND THIS CAN BE SPECIFIC TO
DIFFERENT WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANTS. THE SOURCES OF PRIMARY
MICROPLASTICS ON THIS LEFT SIDE
OF THE GRAPHIC- THESE ARE MICRO
PLASTICS THAT HAVE BEEN
PURPOSELY DESIGNED TO BE MICRO
SIZED. INCLUDE PLASTIC PALLETS
OR ACCIDENTALLY RELEASED- SORRY
PLASTIC PELLETS OR ACCIDENTALLY
RELEASED PLASTICS DURING
MANUFACTURE. INDUSTRIAL
ABRASIVES AND PRODUCTION
MATERIALS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS. AND THE VAST MAJORITY
OF SECONDARY MICROPLASTICS HERE
ON THE RIGHT SIDE. WILL INCLUDE
PLASTIC FIBERS RELEASED DURING
THE WASHING OF SYNTHETIC
CLOTHING AS WELL AS TIRE WEAR
FOR SYSTEMS THAT CO MINGLE
URBAN ENOUGH OR STORM WATER.
AND DEGRADED AND RELEASED
FRAGMENTS FROM LARGER MACRO
PLASTICS PAINTS. ALL OF THESE
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOADINGS
THAT COME INTO WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANTS AND THEIR
ROSTER WHICH. SO WHAT IS THE
GENERAL FATE AND TRANSPORT OF
MICROPLASTICS IN WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANTS YOU MIGHT
RECOGNIZE THIS AS A SIMILAR
VERSION TO WHAT DOCTOR COFFIN
PRESENTED. AND I'D LIKE TO JUST
GO INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL HERE. SO THIS SIMPLIFIED
GRAPHIC SUMMARIZES WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT DIFFERENT STAGES OF
WASTEWATER TREATMENT. AND HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE IN REMOVING
MICROPLASTICS FROM THE AFFLUENT.
IF YOU CONSIDER THE INCOMING
INFLUENCE AS HAVING 1100% OF
THE MICROPLASTIC LOAD FROM ALL
OF THESE POTENTIAL SOURCES.
PRELIMINARY TREATMENT AS YOU
CAN SEE HERE CONSISTING OF
SCREENS AND GRIT REMOVAL
REMOVES APPROXIMATELY 35259% OF
THE MICROPLASTIC LOAD. PRIMARY
TREATMENT CONSISTING OF
DIFFERENT SKIMMING AND SETTLING
PROCESS USE CAN REMOVE UP
25298% SECONDARY TREATMENT
WHICH CONSISTS OF MORE
BIOLOGICAL TREATMENT CAN REMOVE
UP 286299% OF THE MICROPLASTIC
LOAD. AND FINALLY ADVANCED
TERTIARY TREATMENTS CONSISTING
OF DIFFERENT FILTRATION
TECHNOLOGIES CAN REMOVE UP
298299% SO THE TAKEAWAY HERE
REALLY IS THAT USING
CONVENTIONAL WASTEWATER
TREATMENT TECHNOLOGIES WE ARE
ABLE TO REMOVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF MICROPLASTICS FROM
RAW SEWAGE. BUT AS DR COFFIN-
SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER THE
TREATMENT DOESN'T SIMPLY
DESTROY MICROPLASTICS BUT
TRANSFERS THEM TO THE SOLID
TRACTION. SO SPECIFICALLY THOSE
REMOVED BY PRELIMINARY AND A
SMALL PORTION OF PRIMARY
TREATMENT ARE SENT TO LANDFILLS
AND THE REMAINDER ARE
TRANSFERRED TO SLUDGE WHICH IS
FURTHER TREATED TO BECOME SAFE
AND RELIABLE BIOSOLIDS. NO
RESEARCH ON THE PREVALENCE AND
THE FATE AND TRANSPORT OF
MICROPLASTICS IN BIOSOLIDS IS
STILL IN THE EARLY PHASES WE DO
HAVE SOME UNDERSTANDING BUT
THERE ARE MANY DATA GAPS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS BRIEFLY
IN THE LAST FEW MINUTES OF THIS
TALK. SO IN TERMS OF THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF
MICROPLASTICS IN WASTE WATER IN
THE AFFLUENT. RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT THE MOST COMMON FORM
IS MICROPLASTICS AS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS GRAPH
HERE. FOLLOWED BY IRREGULARLY
SHAPED FRAGMENTS WHICH OFTEN DO
INCLUDE FILMS AND PHONES AS
WELL. NOW THIS TREND IS LIKELY
A REFLECTION OF THE VAST NUMBER
OF SYNTHETIC FIBERS THAT ARE
RELEASED THROUGH BOTH DOMESTIC
AND COMMERCIAL LAUNDRY
EFFLUENTS THAT ARE SENT TO
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
EVERY DAY. BUT SOMETHING ELSE
I'D LIKE TO NOTE HERE IS THE
INCREDIBLE SPREAD IN THE
ESTIMATES YOU CAN SEE BETWEEN
ERROR BARS. WHICH HIGHLIGHTS
SOME OF THE UNCERTAINTY AND
VARIABILITY IN THESE NUMBERS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND. AND IN PRACTICE
THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
DIVERSITY AND MICROPLASTIC
SHAPES AND COLORS AND SIZES.
THAT CAN MAKE THEIR
IDENTIFICATION VERY
CHALLENGING. SO THESE PHOTOS
ARE HAVE BEEN TAKEN FROM SOME
OF OUR WASTE WATER SAMPLES
COLLECTED AT DIFFERENT
TREATMENT LEVELS. AND THE GOAL
HERE IS TO SHOW THAT OUR
DEFINITION AND CHARACTERIZATION
OF MICROPLASTICS ARE EVOLVING.
FROM BRIGHTLY COLORED HARD
FRAGMENTS OF PLASTIC TO. CLEAR
AN ODDLY SHAPED PARTICLES TAN
COLORED PHONES AND MANY MANY
DIFFERENT COMPLEX ADDITIVES AND
FILLERS. SO NOW THAT I'VE
DISCUSSED WHAT WE DO KNOW I
WOULD LIKE TO TRANSITION TO THE
CHALLENGES ON THE KNOWLEDGE
GAPS SURROUNDING MICRO PLASTICS
AND WASTEWATER. IN OTHER WORDS
WHAT DO WE NOT KNOW AND WHAT DO
WE NEED TO DO BETTER. AND
IMPORTANTLY WHAT ARE WE DOING
NOW TO TACKLE THESE UNKNOWNS
AND WHAT CAN BE DONE IN THE
FUTURE. SO THE FIRST MAJOR
CHALLENGE IS REALLY RECONCILING
THAT HIGH VARIABILITY THAT WE
SEE IN THE SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE ON ESTIMATES OF
MICROPLASTICS IN WASTE WATER.
THIS VERY ABILITY COULD BE DUE
TO MANY DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT
WE NEED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
BUT ONE OF THE MOST BASIC IS
THAT WE LACK COMMON AND
STANDARD METHODS TO SAMPLE AND
MEASURE THESE CONTAMINANTS. AND
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE'RE
TACKLING THIS IS THE
PARTICIPATION IN EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP. EVALUATE AND RECOMMEND
STANDARD METHODS FOR DIFFERENT
SAMPLE TYPES. AND HEARD LIKE TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COASTAL
WATER RESEARCH PROJECT OR
SQUARE. THEY'VE REALLY BEEN
LEADING THE EFFORT IN
CALIFORNIA. DR COFFIN TO
DESCRIBE THIS A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER AND WE ARE JUST ONE OF
THE MANY LABORATORIES INVOLVED.
THIS EFFORT IS CURRENTLY
FOCUSED ON DRINKING WATER FOR
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO- AND
DOES NOT INCLUDE SIMULATED
WASTEWATER SAMPLES BUT WITH
GREATER FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
AND REQUIREMENTS FOR
STANDARDIZED METHODS WE COULD
REALLY SOLIDIFIED INFORMED
RELIABLE ESTIMATES ACROSS
SOURCES AND DIFFERENT PATHWAYS
INCLUDING WASTEWATER AND
BIOSOLIDS. A SECOND KNOWLEDGE
GAP HERE IS UNDERSTANDING HOW
ALL OTHER FACTORS AFFECT THE
PREVALENCE AND MICROPLASTICS IN
A WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
FROM THE PROPORTION OF
INDUSTRIAL INPUTS TO THE
CONTRIBUTION OF STORM WATER
DIVERSIONS OR URBAN RUNOFF. AND
TO UNDERSTAND HOW ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT FACTORS AFFECT
OVERALL REMOVAL FROM THIS
PATHWAY TO THE ENVIRONMENT. NOW
TO TACKLE THIS KNOWLEDGE GAP
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL OR
OPC HAS RECENTLY FUNDED SQUARE
UP TO CONDUCT A PRELIMINARY
STUDY TO ADDRESS THESE
QUESTIONS. WE AT OC SAD ARE
ENGAGED WITH KASA AND SEVERAL
SISTER WASTE WATER AGENCIES AS
PARTNERS ON THIS ENDEAVOR. AND
TOGETHER WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS
DEVELOPING HIGH QUALITY DATA TO
INFORM RELIABLE REMOVAL
ESTIMATES OF MICROPLASTICS IN
CALIFORNIA'S WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANTS. SO THE FINAL
BIG CHALLENGE THAT I'D LIKE TO
MENTION IS THAT WE ARE STILL IN
THE EARLY STAGES OF
UNDERSTANDING THE BIG PICTURE
AND RELATIVE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
ALL SOURCES AND PATHWAYS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND ONE OF THE
CENTRAL DATA CAPS BUT I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT HERE IS THE FATE
OF MICROPLASTICS IN LAND APPLY
BIOSOLIDS ESPECIALLY AS IT
COMPARES TO OTHER AGRICULTURAL
SOURCES SUCH AS THE USE OF
PLASTIC TARPS. I WHICH HAS
BECOME QUITE COMMON FOR THE
CONTRIBUTION BY ATMOSPHERIC
DEPOSITION WHICH I BELIEVE WILL
HEAR MORE ABOUT LATER ON IN
THIS IN THE SECOND PANEL. THIS
IS A MAJOR UNKNOWN AND WHILE
TREATED BIOSOLIDS ARE ONLY
CURRENTLY APPLY TO LESS THAN
ZERO POINT 5% OF ALL
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN
CALIFORNIA. IS SOMETHING WE DO
NEED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND. TO
TACKLE THESE QUESTIONS WE THINK
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE
THE METHODS IN PLACE TO
CONFIDENTLY MEASURE THESE
CONTAMINANTS FROM ALL PATHWAYS.
USING HIGH QUALITY STUDIES. I'D
LIKE TO CLOSE BY STRESSING THAT
WE CANNOT IGNORE SOURCE CONTROL
IS A KEY COMPONENT IN ITS
EFFECTIVENESS AND ITS INFLUENCE
IN SOLVING THIS EMERGING ISSUE.
AND THE BEST WAY REALLY IT IS
THE BEST WAY REALLY TO REDUCE
MICROPLASTICS- IS TO REDUCE OUR
OUR USE OF PLASTIC OVERALL. WE
ALSO NEED STANDARD VALIDATED
AND ROBUST METHODS FOR
WASTEWATER AND BIOSOLIDS
SAMPLES. MOVEMENTS WE ARE MORE
CONFIDENT IN OUR METHODS WE CAN
BE MORE CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE
COMPARING APPLES TO APPLES. ARE
FRAGMENTS TO PREGNANCY. AND
FINALLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SUPPORT AND PROMOTE
COMPREHENSIVE SOURCE
IDENTIFICATION AND MANAGEMENT
THROUGH INCREASED FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESPONSIBLE
LEGISLATION. SO I THOUGHT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND WE IN CASTLE
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN
FURTHER DIALOGUE ON THIS IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AND- I WANTED
TO INTRODUCE OUR A CHAIR THE
CHAIR OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE THREE OF US. WALL MY
CONCERNS- IN MY COMMITTEE DEAL
WITH DRINKING WATER- THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
DEALS WITH- THE OVERALL
POLLUTION THAT WE HAVE FROM
PLASTICS. AND THE SENATORS ALSO
HAVE- YOU ARE HERE TODAY ALSO
HAVE- RESPONSIBILITY TO LOOK AT
DRINKING WATER AND OVERALL
POLLUTION. WHICH IS WHY I'VE
ASKED THEM HERE TODAY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVERSED YOU WANNA MAKE
A COMMENT. AND THEN WE'LL GET
TO QUESTIONS. I JUST I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU DOCTOR CORK FOR
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING VERY
INFORMATIVE FOR ME AND JUST AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE- FOR BOTH OF
OUR COMMITTEES AS YOU MENTIONED
THANK YOU. OKAY NOW OPEN IT UP
FOR- QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- AND THE OTHER
ATTENDEES. AND MR STERN IF HE
WANTS TO SAY SOMETHING MISTER
VICE CHAIR RICHARD
CLARIFICATION AS TO HOW BIG IS
A NANOMETER. IS THAT THE SIZE
OF A RICE OR SIZE OF A PENNY
HOW BIG IS A- VERY VERY SMALL
IT IS ONE OF OUR- EXPERTS- I
JUST. WANT TO ASK YOURSELF FOR
EVEN IF YOU ARE. RIGHT NOW IT'S
MUCH SMALLER THAN THE WIDTH OF
YOUR HAIR OKAY SO YOU CAN'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND AYE SO IT'S
UNDER A MICROSCOPE IS WHETHER
THEY'RE ON WITH THE ATHLETES
MICROSCOPIC SO I AM VERY
MICROSCOPIC VERY VERY SHORT
OKAY VERY VERY SMALL COMMENTED
IN THE MOUNTAINS FOR MYSELF FOR
PEOPLE LOOKING AT HOME. YEAH.
SO YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. ONE
ONE HUNDRED. MILLIONTH OF AN
INCH. AND THEN UP WITH THEM THE
BILL LANGUAGE OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TO HAVE THESE DATES.
HAVE THEY MET THE DATES OF THE
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE IT SAYS
THE STATE BOARD WILL CALL
CLARIFIED JULY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY. SHALL ADOPT A
DEFINITION AND IF THEY HAVE
THEY MET MET THOSE ARE HAVE A
OF IT SHE IN OFFICE LET'S SEE I
SEE SOME NOT EXCELLENT I HAVE
OKAY YES FOR AND OF COURSE WE
HAVEN'T MET THAT JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YET. BUT WE SHOULD
BE GETTING PRETTY CLOSE WITH A
FEW MORE MONTHS. OKAY PERFECT
THANK YOU OKAY- DOCTOR ARE. DO
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW THE WORK HAS
BEEN GOING. YES SO THE WORK SO
FAR HAS BEEN ARE IT'S BEEN VERY
FAST PACED. THE SAY THE LEAST-
BUT WE ARE ON TRACK TO MEET THE
JULY FIRST DEADLINE FOR THE
REMAINING REQUIREMENTS OF
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
AND I'LL JUST ADD THAT THE ONLY
REASON THAT WERE ABLE TO MEET
THESE DEADLINES IS DUE TO OUR
INCREDIBLE GROUP OF
COLLABORATORS AROUND THE WORLD-
OVER FORTY LAPS FROM SEVEN
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
PARTICIPATING IN THE METHOD
EVALUATION STUDY. ALLEN'S
REALLY THE WORLD'S EXPERTS FOR
MICROPLASTICS ARE FOR THE HUMAN
HEALTH EFFECTS PANEL. YES AND
I'LL SAY- IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS-
COMMITTEE WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
LEGISLATION THAT WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT- INTERNATIONAL
SOURCES OF INFORMATION
PARTICULARLY THE EUROPEAN
UNION- IT'S ONE WORLD- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- REBECCA. OUR QUE HAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WELL I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS SO FAR THIS IS
INCREDIBLY DEPRESSING BUT
INTERESTING SO THANK YOU FOR
ENLIGHTENING US TODAY. THE VAST
PROBLEMS WERE FACING WHEN IT
COMES TO MICROPLASTICS AND ONE
QUESTION FOR I'M REBEKAH SUTTON
IF WE COULD GET HER BACK. HOW
THIS ALL WORKS BUT. YES I'M
HERE THANK YOU REBECCA AND SO
DOCTORS AND YOU MENTIONED- HOW
MANY OF THE FIBERS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY WERE RELATED TO
RELEASE FROM TIRES- AND IT'S
INTERESTING TO ME I HAD A
CHANCE TO. CONVERSE WITH DR
GRANT YESTERDAY WHO IS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF OREGON WHO'S DONE
THE RESEARCH OFF THE COAST OF
OREGON AND SHE SAID IT WAS A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE. OF WHAT
THEY FOUND IN THE CLAMS AND
ANIMALS THEY LOOKED OUT IN
OREGON SO I'M WONDERING WHY
THERE WOULD BE SUCH A BIG
DIFFERENCE ON THE SOURCE OF
MICROPLASTICS HERE IN THE BAY
AREA. FIRST IS WHAT WE'RE
SEEING ELSEWHERE IS THAT AS A
RESULT OF THE URBAN ENVIRONMENT
OR WHAT. HAVE YOU LOOKED AT
DIFFERENT STUDIES AND WHAT
MICROPLASTICS ARE PRESENT AND
WHAT MIGHT EXPLAIN THOSE
DIFFERENCES. SURE YEAH THESE
ARE IT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
WE DIDN'T GENERALLY SEE FIBERS
AND THE COUPLE SPECIES THAT WE
EXAMINED. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TIRE PARTICLES WHERE WE OBSERVE
DOES WAS THE STORM WATER AS
WELL AS THE SENTIMENT. NOW THEY
HAVE BEEN OBSERVED IN.
CHARLESTON I BELIEVE IN IN FISH
SO THERE ARE NOW OBSERVATIONS
OF TIRE PARTICLES IN SOME
SPECIES AND I SUSPECT WE JUST
DID NOT PICK THE RIGHT SPECIES
THAT WOULD BE CONSUMING THE
TIRE ARTICLE SO WE MAY HAVE
PICKED. SPECIES THAT CONSUMES
MORE TYPICAL TYPES OF
MICROPLASTICS RATHER THAN SLAP
OUT. OR WERE. SENTENCED
ORIENTED TOWARD. THAT TIRE
SHAPED PARTICLES. THANK YOU AND
THEN I HAD ANOTHER QUESTION
WHICH IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE PREVALENCE OF THIS IN OUR-
A. WATERS AND THAT ORGANISMS IN
OUR- WATERS BUT- I DIDN'T HEAR
ANYONE MENTIONING THE
PREVALENCE OF THIS IN OUR
DRINKING WATER. WHICH I IMAGINE
COULD ALSO BE THE CASE GIVE ANY
INSIGHT INTO THAT. WE DID NOT
EXAMINE DRINKING WATER IN OUR
STUDY BUT I BELIEVE DOCTOR
COFFIN COULD SPEAK TO THAT.
PROFIT ARE WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
MONITORING DATA FOR DRINKING
WATER IN CALIFORNIA AND TO BE
QUITE HONEST THERE'S REALLY
ONLY A HANDFUL STUDIES THAT
I'VE EVER LOOKED AT
MICROPLASTICS IN DRINKING
WATER- THAT HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED.
BUT WE WILL BE MONITORING- THIS
LATER THIS YEAR AS WE ADOPT OUR
FOUR YEARS SIMPLY ANALYSIS PLAN
BY JULY FIRST. THANK YOU IT
SEEMS LIKE WE NEED SOME DATA ON
THAT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S BEING
CONSUMED BY OUR CONSTITUENTS
EVERY DAY SO. NEED TO MAKE SURE
THERE ARE NOT A SIGNIFICANT
SORT OF REASON- ALTHOUGH WE
WERE LOOKING HERE AT THE BAY.
AND DR SUTTON'S PAPER THAT
AGAIN MANY OFFERS ON THAT AND
LOTS OF CONTRIBUTORS INCLUDING
FORMER SCIENCE FELLOW OF MINE
DI<c.cyan> A LAND. VERY PROUD OF-</c>
WE LOOKED AT THIS BECAUSE- IT
SHOWED HOW IN AN URBAN AREA YOU
COULD GET POLLUTION INTO WATER-
SINCE THERE ISN'T A COMPARABLE
STUDY INTO WHAT GETS INTO THE
SAN JOAQUIN OR THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER. I REALLY HAD TO RELY ON
THIS WHICH I THINK IS JUST AN
INDICATION I MEAN WE OFFER HAD
TIRES. AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT I ALWAYS SORT OF NEVER
CARED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED WAS
MY- TIRES WHERE GAP. NOW I KNOW
IT HAPPENS IT GETS CAUGHT UP IN
STORM WATER GOES INTO THE- INTO
THE LAKES AND RIVERS AND BAYS
OF- CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING PARTICULARLY NOW THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED A TOXIC
SUBSTANCE. I JUST CAN'T THINK
OF ANYTHING THAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW THERE AND-
THEN THIS WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE BY THE ESTUARY INSTITUTED.
REALLY REVEALED A LOT- YES
CENTER BALANCE. YEAH I MEAN ON
THAT NOTE AND THERE'S ALSO AN
ENORMOUS PROBLEM ASSOCIATE
WHICH I GUESS IS NOT
TECHNICALLY A MICROPLASTIC BY
ZINC. IS AN IMPORTANT
INGREDIENT IN TIRES AND IT'S
ACTUALLY CAUSING ENORMOUS.
CLEAN WATER ACT LIABILITY
CHALLENGES FOR A LOT OF OUR
CITIES I KNOW I'VE GOT TO SIT
IN MY DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
GOT. YOU KNOW TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL BUDGET
THE TUNER FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
LIABILITY OF THE CLEAN WATER
ACT AND SOME OF IT LOOKS OF
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THAT.
HAS TO DO WITH ZINC I RUNOFF.
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE WE SPELL
TIME LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE. I'M
TRYING TO SEE THIS AND SOLICIT
A FIX I THINK THAT THE ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT. FOLKS IN
THE IN THE- TIRE INDUSTRY
RUBBER INDUSTRY IT'S A TRIBE
AND COME BACK TO US AND SAID
THERE'S NO VIABLE ALTERNATIVES-
TO TAKE CARE OF WHAT THINK
TAKES CARE OF IN TERMS OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF A TIRE- BUT- I
WOULD. I GUESS I'D LOVE TO.
THAT MAY POSE THE QUESTION THE
PAST MAYBE THE SECOND ONE BUT
BUT- I THINK ALL THE PARENTS
COULD PROBABLY SPEAK THIS I'D
LOVE TO. DIGITAL DEEPER ON ON.
OUR END- ANTI POLLUTION IN WHAT
SORT OF WHAT INFORMATION YOU'VE
GOTTEN FROM OTHER.
JURISDICTIONS WITH REGARDS TO-
PREVENTING TIRE RELATED
POLLUTION WHETHER BE ON THE ON
THE MICROPLASTIC SIDE OR IN THE
SINK SIDE. ARE THERE ANY BEST
PRACTICES OUT THERE- IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY THAT WE OUGHT TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. AS ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR PART OF THE PROBLEM.
DR KAUFMAN PERHAPS YOU COULD-
GO INTO THAT. BOB OBSOLETE AND
THIS ONE TO DOCTOR SUTTON
ACTUALLY DO A BETTER JOB. DR
SUTTON. SURE SO WHAT I AM VERY
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT COMES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROLS SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS EFFORT WHEN
IT COMES TO TIRES BECAUSE THAT
IS ACTUALLY PRIMARILY FOCUSED
ON ZINC AND THIS NEWARK MORE
NEWLY IDENTIFIED PRESERVATIVES
IT'S TOXIC TO THE COLORADO IT
IT'S A NEWER ISSUES SO THEY'RE
GONNA HOPEFULLY EXAMINE BOTH OF
THESE TOXIC INGREDIENTS IN
TIRES. AND SEE IF THERE ARE
WAYS TO REFORMULATE ARTIST THIS
IS A SORT OF IT THE PROCESS
ISN'T AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
WITH MANUFACTURERS WHERE. THE
AGENCY CHALLENGES THEM TO
DETERMINE. WHETHER THERE MAY BE
SAFER ALTERNATIVES- BUT DO YOU
KNOW OF I PROJECT- PLAN I HAD
AND BETTER CARE WHAT I DO I
FORGOT TO MENTION TO ME I DO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
INVITATION- AS- TO THIS IS VERY
INTERESTING HEARING- DID YOU
KNOW OF. OF OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AROUND THE COUNTRY OF THE WORLD
THAT HAVE. BEEN DOING BETTER
WORK IN THIS AREA THAT WE OUT
OF LEARN FROM MORE KNOW ABOUT.
WELL THAT THE RESEARCH TEAM
THAT WORKED ON THIS-
PRESERVATIVE CHEMICALS BASED IN
WASHINGTON STATE AND THAT
THEY'VE BEEN EXAMINING TIRES
LARGELY BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF RESTORATION TO BRING
CALL CALL BACK TO THE STREAMS
AND IN SOME CASES THE STREAMS.
HAVE NOT BEEN HOSPITABLE
THERE'S BEEN THIS REALLY ACUTE
TOXIC REACTION AFTER STORM
EVENTS THAT'S BECAUSE THE CO
HOSTED TO DIE WITHIN HOURS OF
TIME EXPOSURE TO THIS ASSET TO
STORMWATER RUNOFF FROM ST LARGE
HIGHWAYS AND MAJOR ROADWAYS. SO
I WOULD SAY FOR THE
CONSULTATION WITH THAT FOLKS IN
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON MIGHT
BE. GOOD WEIGHT AND SAID GET
MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT BEST
PRACTICES MOVING FORWARD OKAY
SO YOU'RE SAYING THERE THEY'VE
COME UP WITH SOME SORT OF
PRESERVATIVE CHEMICAL THAT
MIMICS THE BENEFITS BENEFITS OF
ZINC. THAT IS POTENTIALLY A
BETTER ALTERNATIVE IS THAT JUST
YOU KNOW IT UNFORTUNATELY IT
DOESN'T MIMIC THE BENEFIT IT'S
AN ADDITIONAL PROBLEM SO I
THINK THE PROBLEM AND THEN ALSO
THIS PRESERVATIVE IS A NEW
PROBLEM THAT YOU JUST
IDENTIFIED. SO NOW WE'RE NOW
WILL GET BACK TO PROBLEMS. OKAY
SO WE DON'T. SO. SO THERE ISN'T
EFFECTIVE ANYTHING IT JUST. I
WAS HOPING FOR SOME HELP BUT I
GUESS YEARS YEAH YOU GIVE ME
LESS HOPE. WITH YOUR ANSWER BUT
IT'S- PROBABLY. I CAN'T SAY IT
SO SEEMS ESPECIALLY WHERE
INSTITUTE I WAS INVOLVED WITH
THIS WITH ONE STUDY THAT IS A
BIT HOPEFUL IN TERMS OF.
EXAMINING GREEN STORMWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE OR A RAIN GARDEN
AND I THINK ONE OF THE LATER
SPEAKERS WILL TALK ABOUT THIS
MORE. FULLY BUT I BASICALLY IF
YOU PASSED IF YOU PASSED ON
WATER THROUGH A RAIN GARDEN.
THEN I DON'T THAT CAN FILTER
OUT SOME OF THE PARTICLES
RIGHT. RIGHT SO WE DIDN'T ONE
SMALL STUDY IN A RAIN GARDEN IN
THE BAY AREA AND WE ARE ABOUT
TO START CONNECTING MORE ROBUST
STUDY IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. SO THIS IS ONE KIND
OF BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICE
THAT COULD BE USEFUL FOR. BOTH
PARTICLES AND THE CHEMICALS
ASSOCIATED. WITH THESE
PARTICLES BUT THAT. SCIENCE IS
STILL. SO I DON'T WANT TO.
EXAGGERATE THE EFFICACY OF THIS
AFTER AT THIS TIME IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT- MISTER
MORNING FOR STRUCTURE IS IT CAN
BE QUITE COSTLY SO IT CAN BE
MORE EFFECTIVE IF WE CAN.
ADDRESS THESE CONTAMINANTS AT
THE SOURCE YOU KNOW REDUCE USE
REFORMULATION OR RATHER THAN
CATCHING THEM FURTHER
DOWNSTREAM WELL LET ME ASK ALL
THE PANELISTS THAT YOU'RE JUST
AS I THINK YOU HIT ON THE ISSUE
RIGHT A MANY SO WHAT HOW HOW
MUCH PROGRESS WE MAKING ON
REALLY IDENTIFYING THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTORS. I WE DO WE JUST
TALK ABOUT TIRES YOU KNOW
PRESUMABLY CLOSE PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE LEAST A
LOT OF THE MICROFIBERS THAT
WERE MENTIONED. AB YOU KNOW SO
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE EFFORTS
UNDER WAY TO REALLY HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHERE. THE PROBLEM
IS ON THE SOURCE SIDE. AND THEN
ONCE AGAIN I YOU KNOW. IS THERE
ANY GOOD EXAMPLES OUT THERE AND
IN OTHER PLACES- OF FOLKS WHO
HAVE FIGURED OUT A GOOD WAY OF
ADDRESSING THIS I MEAN IS
THERE. AND NO. WAY TO ATTEMPT
TO TRY TO PUSH MANUFACTURERS TO
BE MORE RESPONSIBLE YOU KNOW TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE- FOR
ACOSTA THEIR ULTIMATELY-
PUSHING OFF ON TO THE ON TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. I'M TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY I DON'T WANT TO TAKE.
TAKE TIME FROM MY CO PRESENTERS
BUT- I THINK THE FACT IT. FOR
EXAMPLE DOCTOR KAUFMAN'S WORK
ON A DEFINITION AND ON MESSAGE
IS LEADING ACTUALLY THE WHOLE
WORLD IN SOME WAYS THAT. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S REALLY OUT IN
FRONT ON THIS ISSUE. SO AT.
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO BE
LEADERS I SUPPOSE I. ON THIS ON.
INTERESTING MICROPLASTICS.
THANK YOU SENATOR- AND I ALSO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR- DOCTOR
SUTTON- SO IS THERE ANY
INDICATION OF. PLASTICS COMING
FROM OUR LANDFILLS I KNOW THAT-
IN THE SOUTH PART OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY YOU DO HAVE A LANDFILL
RIGHT NEXT TO THE BAG. ANY
INDICATION THAT WE GET LEAKAGE
FROM THE LANDFILLS INTO THE DAY
IN TERMS OF PLASTICS. I AM NOT
AWARE OF ANY CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC SCIENCE ON THAT I DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE STUDIES.
ELSEWHERE THAT HAVE OBSERVE
MICRO PLASTICS IN LANDFILL
LEACHATE. I BELIEVE LEACHATE.
IS TREAT IT DOESN'T IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO. EXIT POLLING AND
FEELING GOING TO THE BANK-
PERHAPS OTHERS. MORE ON THIS OR
FROM IF THE REGULATIONS ARE
WORKING THERE G. R. PLASTICS
COMING FROM THE LANDFILL SO
THESE PRESUMABLY THAT AND-
WHAT'S GETTING IN THE PLASTICS
THE SOURCES FIRST OF ALL TIRES.
THE LEAST IN THE BAY AREA THAT
WAS THE BIGGEST CONTRIBUTOR.
AND THEN PROBABLY LATER ILLEGAL
DUMPING- WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY
CAN RELATED TO THE QUESTION
SEVERAL RALLY BROUGHT UP. WHAT
IS IT WE NEED TO CONTROL TO
KEEP OUR STORMWATER- MORE FEWER
OTHER THAN THE TIRES. SH WELL
THE OTHER THING BESIDES TIRES
IN OUR STORM WATER WERE FIBERS
IN SO SOME OF THOSE FARMERS
COULD BE DERIVED FROM OUR
CLOTHING. AND ONE PATHWAY FOR
THEM TO GET OUT INTO THE
LANDSCAPE COULD BE FOR EXAMPLE
OUR DRYER VENTS. AND ANOTHER
TYPE OF FIBER WE SAW OUR THAT
THE ONES ASSOCIATED WITH
CIGARETTES SO THAT CELLULOSE
ACETATE. SO THAT COULD BE
ANOTHER TYPE OF SPECIFIC SOURCE
THAT THAT ONE COULD ADDRESS AT
IN TERMS OF REDUCING STORMWATER
YES MA'AM. I LIKE THE IDEA BUT-
YEAH I BELIEVE IT WAS ONE OF
THE TOPICS OF THE OPC THEIR
THEIR DRAFT TOP TEN LIST OF
WAYS TO ADDRESS. COULD YOU GET
THAT REPORT TO- ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THE DRAFT REPORT TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL
AS- SENATORS ALLEN AND STERN
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER. LUIS RIVAS.
SO OKAY- I THINK IN THE- I
THINK WE CAN NOW GO ON TO THE
NEXT PANEL. THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH- THIS IS TRULY BEYOND- FOR
ME- WILL HAVE A LIFE CHANGING.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
RESEARCHERS ABOUT WHAT IS KNOWN
ABOUT THE IMPACT MIKE CARTER
FROM THE ENVIRONMENT INCLUDING
AQUATIC LIFE FROM ECOSYSTEMS
AND HOW MIGHT THEY CURRENTLY
BEING DIRECTLY. INTERFERING
WITH HUMAN HEALTH- I'VE HEARD
RIGHT- GRANT S. BRONTE
PROFESSOR IN THE STATE
UNIVERSITY- TO DISCUSS YOUR
GROUND BREAKING RESEARCH ON THE
ATMOSPHERIC DEPOSITION OF
MICROPLASTIC IN REMOTE AREAS
UNITED STATES. AGAIN IF YOU CAN
YOUR QUESTIONS TO REMEMBER
PANELS AND- YOU FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTES FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH DR
QUIRK AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INVITING ME TO BE A PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT PANEL REALLY
EXCITED TO BE HERE. SO I'D LIKE
TO START OFF BY- ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT LESS THAN A DOZEN PAPERS
HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED ON THIS
TOPIC IN THE LAST FEW YEARS SO
WE'RE REALLY AT THE VERY START
OF UNDERSTANDING HOW PLASTICS
ARE EMITTED TO THE ATMOSPHERE
AND TRANSPORTED TO THE
ATMOSPHERE. WE ALSO DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ON NATIONAL
PLASTICS SO WHEN I SAY NANO
PLASTICS I'M TALKING ABOUT
PARTICLES THAT ARE SMALLER THAN
ONE MICROMETER AND FOR
REFERENCE A RED BLOOD CELL
SALAS ABOUT TEN MICROMETERS
THESE ARE VERY VERY SMALL
PARTICLES AND THEY WOULD HAVE
DIFFERENT EMISSION POINTS. AND
TRANSPORT PATHWAYS AND
MICROPLASTICS. I'M GONNA STICK
TO MICROPLASTICS HERE. SO WHAT
DO WE KNO ABOUT HOW
MICROPLASTICS ENTERING THE
ATMOSPHERE AS WE'VE HEARD.
PLASTICS ARE VERY PERSISTENT SO
THEY IN THE ENVIRONMENT THEY
WILL RESIST ALL FORMS OF
NATURAL TO KAY. INSTEAD
BREAKING APART INTO SMALLER AND
SMALLER PARTICLES UNTIL FINALLY
THEY'RE SMALL ENOUGH TO BE
TRANSPORTED BY THE WIND. SO
SIMILAR TO SOIL DUST
MICROPLASTICS NEED TO BE
ADMITTED TO THE ATMOSPHERE
THROUGH SOME. PHYSICAL
MECHANICAL PROCESS. UNLIKE SOIL
DUST HOWEVER MICROPLASTICS ARE
A LOT LESS DANCE SO THAT MEANS
THAT THEY CAN TRAVEL MUCH
FARTHER IN A MUCH LARGER SIZES.
BUT WE CAN USE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW SOIL DUST
IS EMITTED TO THE ATMOSPHERE
AND OTHER AEROSOLES TO CREATE
HYPOTHESES ON HOW MICROPLASTICS
MIGHT BE ENTERING THE
ATMOSPHERE. SO VERY LIKELY
SOURCE ARE IS THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF PLASTICS IN THE OCEAN
STATE TAX THERE ARE OFTEN LESS
DENSE THAN WATER. STILL BUBBLE
BURST ACTION AND WAVE ACTION
COULD BE AT I WANTED MECHANISM
THAT MICROPLASTICS ARE BEING
ADMITTED. TO THE ATMOSPHERE.
ANOTHER LIKELY MAJOR SOURCES
ROADS THE ROADS ARE LONG AND
WHEN YOU'RE IN THAT PROVIDES AN
UNOBSTRUCTED PATH FOR A WIN.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ROADS AT
CARS DRIVING ON THE ROADS
PROVIDES MECHANICAL ENERGY TO A
MINUTE PARTICLES HIGH INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE. THIS ISN'T JUST THE
TIRE WEAR PARTICLES IN THE
ROBERT PARTICLES WHICH ARE PART
OF THIS BUT ALSO ANY
MICROPLASTIC FROM A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT COMMODITIES THAT
COULD BE IN THAT ROAD TAX. AS
WE'VE HEARD AGRICULTURE COULD
BE A REALLY IMPORTANT SOURCE TO
THE ATMOSPHERE NOT JUST FROM
BIOSOLIDS APPLICATION BUT ALSO
FROM PLASTIC MOLDS AND PLASTIC.
TARPS THAT ARE ADDED TO AND
USED IN THE AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES- AND STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT CLASSICS ARE
PREFERENTIALLY WINNOWED FROM
THE SOILS AS COMPARED TO
SWELLED PAST. AB POPULATION IS
A LITTLE BIT OF A STRANGE TERM
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT HOW
PEOPLE ARE REALLY EFFECTIVE AT
MOVING STAND AWAY FROM THE
BEACH HUMANS ARE ALSO LIKELY
REALLY EFFECTIVE AT REMOVING
MICROPLASTICS AWAY FROM SEATS.
SO ANY AREAS ON THE EARTH THAT
PRODUCED A LOT OF DUST THAT
HAPPENED TO BE NEAR. LARGE
URBAN CENTERS HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO MOVE PLASTICS INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE. AND THEN ONCE WE
HAVE CITIES AND CITIES IS WHERE
A LOT OF OUR PLASTIC WASTE IS
GENERATED. BUT IT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE WHERE PLASTICS
ARE EMITTED TO THE ATMOSPHERE
SECURING DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN
SOURCES TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND
SOURCES TO THE ATMOSPHERE. SO
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT DUST IF FOR
EXAMPLE IS THAT CITIES PRODUCE
A LOT OF DOT OFTEN EIGHT AND AT
IN ORDER TO. MANAGE YOU TO
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE MORE THAN
CHASING RURAL OR REMOTE
LOCATIONS. THIS IS BECAUSE
THESE ARE PRODUCING A LOT OF
DUST BUT IT'S NOT MOVING HIGH
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE SO. IT'S
NOT GETTING TRANSPORTED VERY
FAR. SO IN TERMS OF HOW
MICROPLASTICS IS TRANSPORTED
THROUGH THE ATMOSPHERE WHERE IT
IS IN THE ATMOSPHERE HOW FAR IS
TRACK IT'S BEING TRANSPORTED-
WE'RE REALLY JUST STARTING TO
SCRATCH THE SURFACE THAT THAT
QUESTION AS WELL AS IF YOU'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT THE STUDY-
THAT I CONDUCTED. AND I WAS
REALLY ONLY ABLE TO START
ADDRESSING THESE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I CAPITALIZE ON AN
EXISTING NETWORK. I DEVELOPED A
SAMPLER THAT COULD WORK WITH
THE NATIONAL ATMOSPHERIC
DEPOSITION PROGRAM THAT ALLOWED
ME TO SAMPLE. BOTH WHITES AND
DRY DEPOSITION SO WHAT IS WHAT
FALLS OUT WITH THE BRAIN. AND
DRIES WHAT FALLS OUT UNDER DRY
CONDITIONS AND I WAS ABLE TO DO
THIS AND- REALLY- HIGH TEMPORAL
RESOLUTION WEEKLY FOR RAIN. IF
IT RAINS AND LUCKY FOR DRY. AND
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT WHITE
DEPOSITION WAS REALLY DIFFERENT
AND DRY. SO WHAT THE POSITION
TENDED TO BE SOURCED FOR MORE
NEARBY LOCATIONS SO IF IT AIR
MASS PASSED THROUGH IT AND
URBAN CENTER WE SAW MORE
PLASTIC OR IF IT HAD A LOT OF.
SOIL DUST IN IT. AND WHAT WE
THINK IS HAPPENING HERE IS THAT
AS STOREFRONTS MOVE THROUGH AN
AREA THEY GENERATE A LOT OF
PLANS AND A LOT OF ENERGY THAT
CAN. PICK UP A LOT OF TACTICS
OFF THE GROUND WHICH CAN THEN
BE. RAINED OUT IN THAT STORE.
AND SOON I KNOW I JUST SAID
THAT WE DON'T THINK CITIES ARE
A SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR. SO
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT-
CITIES. ALSO HAVE A LOT OF ROAD
NETWORK NETWORKS COMING IN AND
OUT OF THAT. BUT ALSO WE WERE
ONLY ABLE TO ASCRIBE ABOUT 10%
OF OUR DEPOSITION TO CITIES AND
THIS IS BECAUSE 80% OF OUR
DEPOSITION CAME OUT. AS DRY
DEPOSITION. SO DRIED UP AS- OUT.
VERY DE. IT WAS MUCH SMALLER IN
SIZE. IT WAS INVERSELY RELATED
TO SOIL DUST SO THE LAST OIL
DESK THAT WAS IN OUR SAMPLE
SOME MORE PLASTICS THE STOCK.
AND WE ALSO SAW A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP TO ELEVATION SO
THE HIGHER OUR SAMPLE SITES
WHERE THE MORE CLASS THAT WE
SAW. AND THEN FINALLY- ARE THE
PLASTIC DEPOSITION RATE. WAYS
WAS CORRELATED TO THESE BROAD
CLIMATE SCALE PATTERNS LIKE THE
LOCATION OF THE JET ST. SO IF
THE JET STREAM. REALLY FAR
SOUTH. AND INTERSECTED WITH
THEIR SITES AS IS IN THIS IMAGE
HERE WE SAW MORE PLASTIC. AND
SO WHAT THIS IS TELLING US IS
THAT PLASTICS ARE MOVING AROUND
HIGH IN THE IN THE ATMOSPHERE
COLUMN. AND THEY'RE INFLUENCED
BY THESE BROAD SCALE PATTERNS
MEANING THAT. THEY'RE BEING
TRANSPORTED VERY FAR. SO TERMS
OF TIME DEBRIS. RATES AGAIN WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF DATA AS TO
WHAT'S BEEN PUBLISHED AS SHOWN
HERE. AND WHAT YOU CAN SEE IS
THAT THE DEPOSITION RATES
WITHIN URBAN CENTRES ARE ONLY
SLIGHTLY LARGER THAN WHAT WE'VE
QUANTIFIED IN REMOTE LOCATIONS.
AND SO THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNING BECAUSE IT SUGGESTS
TO US THAT A LOT OF THE
ATMOSPHERIC DEPOSITION OF
PLASTICS IS DERIVED FROM LEGACY
POLLUTION. SO IF WE DID A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO WHAT WE
ACTUALLY FOUND IT WITHIN OUR
SAMPLES. ROUGHLY 226% OF THE
SAMPLES WE ANALYZED WERE
COMPOSED OF PLASTIC I'M JUST
INCLUDED DOMINANTLY FIBERS BUT
ALSO- MICROBEADS AS WELL A A
VARIETY OF OTHER DIFFERENT-
TYPES OF PLASTIC LAKE ROAD
TIGHT. IT MIGHT SOUND LIKE A
SMALL NUMBER 226% BUT IN FACT
THIS IS A VERY LARGE AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL. LOOKING AT OUR
DEPOSITION RATES ACROSS THE
AMERICAN WEST WE SAW BETWEEN
FORTY EIGHT AND FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE. PIECES OF
PLASTIC BEING DEPOSITED EVERY
METER SQUARE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
SO WE'VE WE SCALE THIS UP TO
THE SIZE OF THE PROTECTED AREAS
WE WERE STUDYING THIS
TRANSLATED TO POINT YOU TO
TWELVE TONS OF PLASTIC PER YEAR
WITHIN THE SITES. AND THEN IF
WE CONSIDER THE- PROTECTED
AREAS IN ELEVEN WESTERN STATES
THAT THIS IS A DARK GREEN AND
LIGHT GREEN AREAS WE ESTIMATED
THAT BETWEEN A THOUSAND AND
FOUR THOUSAND TONS ARE BEING
DEPOSITED EVERY SINGLE YEAR. SO
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO INTEGRATE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT MANTA PLASTICS AT THIS
POINT SO THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. I'M A LOT MORE
QUESTIONS AND WE HAVE ANSWERS
TO- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'LL ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PEOPLE. OKAY ALL RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH- IT'S HARD TO SEE
WHAT KIND OF SOLUTION WE CAN
HAVE TO THIS OTHER THAN BANNING
PLASTICS BUT WE'LL GET INTO
THAT LATER- SO THE NEXT SPEAKER
IS. PART OF OUR INTERNATIONAL-
DAY TODAY- DR CHELSEA ROCKMAN
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO
TO EXPLAIN MICROPLASTIC
PATHWAYS IN AQUATIC ECO SYSTEMS
AND KNOWN IMPACTS TO MARINE
LIFE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YEAH. OKAY
WONDERFUL WELL THANK YOU DR
CHAIRMAN AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M I'M THRILLED
TO BE HERE TODAY YES I'M IN IN
CANADA BUT I SPEND A LOT OF
YEARS AND I CALIFORNIA. AND THE
NAME IS DR CHELSEA ROCK MAN I'M
A PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF TORONTO AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE ISSUE OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE- WHICH INCLUDES MANY
YEARS I'M IN CALIFORNIA AND I
CONTINUE TO WORK. IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. AND YES IF YOU'RE
WEATHER. SO I'M GONNA TALK
TODAY ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH
MICROPLASTICS CAN IMPACT. OTHER
SPEAKERS THAT CONTAMINATION IS
WIDESPREAD. THIS IS NO LONGER A
QUESTION THAT WE'RE GRAPPLING
WITH IN THE FIELD. AND WE'RE
STARTING TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS WIDESPREAD CONTAMINATION
HAS LED TO CONTAMINATION AT
EVERY LEVEL OF THE FOOD CHAIN
THIS INCLUDES IN PRIMARY
PRODUCTIVITY WITH PLANTS- WE
HAVE CONTAMINATION. AS WELL ALL
THE WAY UP TO APEX PREDATORS
LIKE SHARKS. SOMETIMES THE
CONTAMINATION IS QUITE
STRIKINGLY LARGE SO I WE HAVE
FOUND NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
PARTICLES IN ONE BROWN BOWL HAD
FISH HERE IN THE TORONTO AREA
IN LAKE ONTARIO. AND DR THOMAS
MAYES REPORTED ALMOST FOUR
THOUSAND PARTICLES IN A SPECIES
OF SHARK. SO WE KNOW THE
CONTAMINATION IS OCCURRING AND
WE'RE EVEN STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE CLASSIC MOVE
AROUND A FOOD WET WHEN THEY
CONTAMINATE- ORGANISMS IN IN.
THE ENVIRONMENT WE KNOW THAT
THESE ARE THESE PLASTICS CAN BE
INGESTED WE'RE ALSO STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY CAN BE
INHALED THIS WOULD BE THROUGH
THE GILLS OF FISH. WE CAN TALK
ABOUT HUMAN HEALTH LATER-
ANSWER STAFF STUFF RIGHT WILL
DO THAT- WE KNOW THAT IT CAN BE
IT CAN BE YOU JUST AND THERE
CAN BE EXCRETION. I PLASTIC CAN
TRANSFER FROM A PARADE TO A
PREDATOR THROUGH TRAFFIC
TRANSFERRED. BUT WE'RE ASKING
ABOUT NOW IS TRYING INTEREST
THAT. INCREASE OVER TIME IN
CONCENTRATION OUTSIDE OF THE
GUY IN THE TISSUES. AND DOESN'T
INCREASE THE FOOD. I
CONCENTRATION WAVER SYSTEM LIKE
POLLUTANTS DEAL. THIS IS STILL
QUESTION WE AREN'T SURE
ACTUALLY I'M NOT SURE I THINK
MY HYPOTHESIS WOULD BE THAT IT
DOESN'T INCREASE. IN
CONCENTRATION OF THE FOOD WEB.
BUT WE KNOW THEY CAN'T
CONCENTRATE OUTSIDE THE CAT AND
THERE'S EVIDENCE OF CLASSIC IN
THE FLAT IN THE LIVERS OF FISH
TISSUE. AND FOR A WHILE THIS
WAS HARD TO BELIEVE- BUT WE'VE
EVEN FOUND IN FISH THAT WE'VE
SAMPLED IN OUR OWN LAB SO THE
ONLY THING I WANT YOU TO NOTICE
FROM THIS GRAPH. IS THAT THE
ORANGE IN THE PURPLE BOXES-
THOSE BOX PLOTS ARE EVIDENCE OF
MICROPLASTICS IN THE FILLET AND
IN THE LIVER OF SPORT FISH
TAKEN FROM LAKE SIMCOE. AT HERE
IN ONTARIO AND THE GREEN IS THE
MICROPLASTIC IN THE GOT YOU CAN
SEE THAT OF COURSE THE
MICROPLASTIC IN THE GUT WAS
MORE ABUNDANT. BUT THAT WE WERE
SEEING. THIS EVIDENCE IN THE
FLAG. AND IN THE LIVER WHICH
WAS QUITE. SO THIS LEADS TO THE-
WHAT ARE THE IMPACT. HOW DOES
THAT IN IN- AFFECT WILDLIFE.
WHEN IT ENDS IN THE IN. AND
THERE'S THREE SORT OF OVER
ARCHING MECHANISMS I WILL SPEAK
UP. AND ONE IS PHYSICAL WHEN A
MICROPLASTIC LEADS THE GUY THAT
GOES INTO AN ORGAN GOES INTO A
TISSUE. IT CAN BE A SOURCE OF
INFORMATION WHICH COULD
EVENTUALLY INTENTIONALLY LEAD
TO TUMOR FORMATION. ALSO WE'VE
SEEN IN FISH THAT ARE EXPOSED
TO MICROPLASTICS IN A TANK IN
THE LAB. BECAUSE THEY START
EATING LESS OF THEIR FOOD AND
THEY START EATING MORE OF THE
PLASTIC THAT PHYSICAL PRESENCE
OF PLASTIC IN THE WATER CAN
CAUSE A THREE DAY MISSION A
FACT. WHICH CAN LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN MORTALITY OR DEATH.
YOU CAN ALSO HAVE A CHEMICAL
BACK DR SUTTON WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS WITH THE CHEMICALS
AND TIRED ASKED. WE SEE THAT
FATHEAD MINNOW A CRAYFISH LOSE
THAT PIGMENTATION IN THEIR
EYES. WHEN THEY'RE EXPOSED TO
THE LEACHATE FROM TIRED TASK
WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS IMPACTS THEM AS THEY AS
THEY GET OLDER. AND SAYS
POTENTIALLY A SIMILAR STORY TO
THE SALMON. THERE'S ALSO
EVIDENCE THAT WHEN PEOPLE
EXPOSE MICROPLASTICS ORGANISMS
IN THE LABS THAT ITS THE
ADDITIVES THAT ARE CAUSING THE
TOXICITY THIS IS A- CASE
WITHOUT C. ELEGANS AS A WORD IN
SO I'LL- MAKER. ALSO THE IN BY
AND OF TRANSFORM INTO THESE
MULTIPLE STRESSORS WHERE THEY
START TO ACCUMULATE THE METALS
AND THE PERSISTENT ORGANIC
POLLUTANTS FROM THE WATER
COLIN. THEY MIGHT EVEN GAIN A
MICROBIAL COMMUNITY THAT MIGHT
INCLUDE DISEASE OR PARASITES.
WHEN YOUR CLASSIC IS THEN EATEN
THE QUESTION IS HOW DOES THAT
MIXTURE OF THE PLASTIC IN THE
CHEMICALS IMPACT THE ORGANISMS.
HERE I'M SHOWING YOU WORK
ACTUALLY FROM CALIFORNIA DURING
MY PHD I. PUT PLASTIC M.
CONTAINED IN THE SAN DIEGO BAY
ALLOWED IT TO ACCUMULATE
CONTAMINANTS EXPOSED FISH AND I
FOUND THAT THE PLASTIC- IN THE
PLASTIC THAT WAS PUT IN THE SAN
DIEGO BAY WAS MORE TOXIC THAN
THE PLASTIC THAT WAS NOT.
YOU'RE IN SHOWING YOU A TUMOR
IN THE LIVER OF A FISH THAT WAS
EXPOSED TO THAT MICROPLASTIC
FROM THE BANK. WHEREAS FISH
THAT WERE EXPOSED TO THE CLEAN
PLASTIC STILL HAD WEIRD LESIONS
IN THE LIVER BUT THEY WEREN'T
AS FAR AS TUMOR PROMOTION. AND
MY PHD STUDENT KENNEDY BUT SHE
HAS ALSO FOUND THAT
MICROPLASTICS FROM LAKE ONTARIO
CAUSES MORE DEFORMITIES IN FISH
THAN PLASTIC. TAKEN OFF THE
SHELF. THESE ARE JUST KIND OF
WANNA STUDY THAT I'M YOU ALSO
TO TALK YOU ABOUT A THEN I.
THAT I'VE DONE. THIS MEANS I
LOOK ACROSS LITERATURE THAT HAS
JUST REALLY EXPANDED OVER THE
YEARS AND TRY TO WRITE PAPERS
THAT STAND THE SIDE ALL OF THAT
LITERATURE TO SAY. WHAT DO WE
KNOW ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
MICROPLASTICS SO I'M GONNA TRY
TO GO QUICKLY THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE RESULTS AND THEN I WOULD
LOVE TO ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT LATER. SO WHAT WE DO
IS WE LOOK THROUGH THE
LITERATURE. AND WE CHECKED THE
BOX FOR THE SIZE OF PLASTIC
FROM THAT NANO SCALE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER IT TOO BIG
FISHING NETS. AND WE LOOK
ACROSS LEVELS OF BIOLOGICAL
ORGANISATION I WANT YOU TO
NOTICE HERE IS THESE ARE SUB
ORGANISMAL SOMETHING
PHYSIOLOGICALLY IN THE BODY
HERE THIS WOULD BE DEATH TO AN
ORGANISM CHANGING THE SIZE OF
THE POPULATION OR THE CHANGE IN
THE COMMUNITY. THE DARKER THE
SHADING THE MORE EVIDENCE OF
DEMONSTRATED IMPACT THEIR ART
TO THAT SIZE OF PLASTIC AND TO
THAT LEVEL OF BIOLOGICAL
ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE
MICROPLASTICS HERE YOU SEE
BLUE. AT ALMOST EVERY LEVEL.
INCLUDING UP TO THOSE ONES THAT
ARE MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY EAGLE
ARE SORRY ECOLOGICALLY RELEVANT
SO WE KNOW THAT MICROPLASTICS.
CAN IMPACT. IN THE MALLS ACROSS
MANY LEVELS OF BIOLOGICAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND ACROSS MANY
SIZES AND THIS EVIDENCE HAS
BEEN INCREASING OVER THE YEARS
THIS IS THE SECOND. SYSTEMATIC
REVIEW AND META ANALYSIS I'VE
WORKED ON. WHAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING. IS THAT WE ALSO
SEE STUDIES THAT TRYING TO
QUANTIFY THE EFFECTS OF
MICROPLASTICS IN THE LAB AND
THEY DON'T DETECT IN EFFECT SO
THAT THEY DON'T THIS DOESN'T
ALWAYS OCCUR SO THE QUESTION IS
WHY I WILL MAKE A POSITIVE
THEIR COMPLEXES DR KAUFMAN
POINTED OUT. THE CONCENTRATION
MATTERS THIS SIZE MATTERS THE
SHAPE MATTERS THE TYPE OF
PLASTIC WE TALKED ABOUT TIRES.
AND THE TAX THAT IN MY LAST
THIRTY SECONDS I THINK I MIGHT
BE OVER I JUST WANT TO SHOW TO
YOU WHEN WE TRY TO COLLAPSE ALL
OF THE. VARIABILITY OF THE
PLASTIC TOGETHER AND TRY TO DO
A RISKY. THE SAME CON. OF MY
GROUP. NOW SOME REAL GREAT WORK
THAT BEEN LET BY DOC ALBERT
COLEMAN IN THE MATTER. HAS
FOUND. NUMBERS THAT THEY- MIGHT
CAUSE A THE FACT ANYWAY FROM A-
TO FIVE TWENTY ONE PARTICLES
FRESH WATER. IN EIGHT TO
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND NINETY IN
MARINE THOSE ARE HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS WE FOUND
CONCENTRATIONS WITHIN THAT
RANGE AND STORM WATER IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY FOR EXAMPLE.
THE DOCTOR BECKY SAT AND TALKED
ABOUT- SO THESE CONCENTRATIONS
ARE ARE NOT ON HER DEATH. AND
THAT SUGGEST THAT MAYBE WE
SHOULD START MITIGATING- I'M-
HERE IN CALIFORNIA OF COURSE
THE SQUARED WORKING GROUP THAT
I'M INVOLVED IN IS GOING TO
COME OUT WITH NUMBERS MORE
SPECIFIC TO CALIFORNIA BY
WORKING ON A RISK ASSESSMENT
FRAMEWORK. AND THE O. S. D.
REPORT SHOULD COME OUT AND THIS
MONTH. AND THAT WILL TALK ABOUT
PRIORITIES FOR MEASURING
CONCENTRATIONS IN NATURE SO WE
CAN COMPARE EXPOSURE TO REST.
AND I'M SORRY WENT OVER BUT I
REALLY. APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE EVERY WAS
ABOUT. I YOU'RE ONLY ONE OVER
BY SO. OKAY WHEN- AND IT'S SO
THAT THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
AND WE THANK YOU ALL AS WELL AS
ALL OUR OTHER PEOPLE FOR TAKING
THIS TIME- GOING ON IN OUR
INTERNATIONAL FLAVOR HERE WE'RE
GOING TO TALK WITH DOCTOR STEPH
STEPHANIE RIGHT FROM IMPERIAL
COLLEGE LONDON. AND SHE'S GOING
TO SHARE WITH US YOUR
UNDERSTANDING MICROPLASTICS
PATHWAYS TO HUMANS BY A
DRINKING WATER AND ALSO SEWAGE
SLUDGE APPLICATIONS IN AN
ELATION. AND EVEN DETECTIONS IN
HUMAN PLACENTAS AND THIS WHOLE
QUESTION OF SEWAGE SLUDGE WHEN
I FIRST SAW. THE ESTUARY
INSTITUTE SAID ALMOST NONE OF
THE PLASTICS THAT GET INTO THE
BARRIER ONE THIRD OF 1% COME
FROM. SEWAGE I STOPPED WORRYING
ABOUT- SEWAGE TREATMENT I STOP
WORRYING ABOUT IT AND THEN
SOMEBODY POINTED OUT TO ME
PADDED ENDS UP IN THE SLUDGE
WHOOPS. SO WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM DR
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HATE
FOR THE YOU CAN ALL SEE MY
SLIDE DECK HEY AND YOU CAN HEAR
ME I QUE ADEM I'M GONNA TRY AND
KEEP THE WEIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT ELEVEN PM EST FOR HABITS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME AB SITE BE MAKING ON THE
TOPIC OF MICROPLASTICS FOR
ABOUT. CLOSE TO TEN IS NOT
TODAY- OF THE LAST FIVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN FOCUSING MY RESEARCH
ON HUMAN EXPOSURE I AM ON THE
FACTS AND PARTICULARLY FIVE
YEAH. I'M SORRY. TO BEGIN WITH-
WE'VE JUST HEARD FROM DR BRYONY
ABOUT- THE FACT THAT
MICROPLASTIC IS IN NEED OF
RECOGNIZED ATHLETES IN. AND SO
YOU OF COURSE THAT RAISES ALARM
BELLS THAT WE MIGHT BE EXPOSED
TO THIS BECAUSE WE BREED THAT.
AND BUT I JUST WANT TO STRESS
THIS DOUBLE THE IMPORTANCE OF.
A DYNAMIC SITES WHEN IT COMES
TO HUMAN EXPOSURE. NOW THIS IS
TODAY BUT SIDE BECAUSE IT.
DEMETRIC SIZE SHAPE AND
MATERIAL DENSITY INTO THIS
MEASURE AND IT REALLY MATCHES-
INDICATES HOW THESE PARTICLES
BEHAVE AND ACT. AB SE PARTICLES
HAVING DIFFERENT DIE PENSIONS
AND SHAPES MAY BEHAVE THE SAME
IN THAT AND BASS WILL HAVE TO
SAVE EVERY DYNAMIC SIZE. WHY IS
THIS IMPORTANT IT'S IT SAYS WHY
IT THIS PARTICLE MAKER IN THAT
WAY AND THAT'S WHERE IT COULD
LINES AND THE FULL WHERE
EXPOSURE MIKE K. SO THIS PHASE
WHICH CAN REACH THE CENTRAL AT
WAYS OR TRUCK YEAH. AB DID IT
HAPPEN IRATE DYNAMIC DAMAGE
LESS THAN TEN MICRONS AT US
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS SAT IN
SIZE AT APPROXIMATELY AND THOSE
THAT CAN REACH THE DEEP PLAN
COVERED IRATE DYNAMIC DYNAMIC
TO. LESS. THAN TWO POINT FIVE
MICRONS. AB ARE THESE REPORTS
SIZE FRACTIONS WHICH WILL SAVE
WILL WHEN WE MEASURE UP PARTICK
ACT THE BEST M. HE EXPECTS.
THERE IS EMAIL MY BY NOT NAY
APTLY IS YET FIFTH. A RISK
FACTOR FOR MOST GOOD. EVAN OF
IRAQ. SPECIFIC KEPT AND POINT
FIVE THAT'S LINKED TO S. TO SEE
FROM PRIVATE TO AMONG TO. SITE
THIS IS GRAY OF ITS PINT AS
YOU CAN SEE ON THIS GRAPH HERE
AND HE CAN SEE THIS INCREASED
RISK. FOR CARDIOVASCULAR
RESPIRATORY DISEASES. BUT IT'S
A PERCEIVED AS SMALL FOR. OF
THIS APART MATTER DR TOXICITY
THIS IS NOT YOU STILL BE
RECESSED IN THE LONG
ESTABLISHED EQUITY COMMUNITY.
AND THE MICROPLASTIC CONTENT IN
THESE AFRICANS HAVEN'T BEEN
QUANTIFIED YET AND SAY THE
RELATIVE CONTRIBUTION OF
MICROPLASTIC INHALATION
EXPOSURE TO RESPIRATORY AND
CARDIOVASCULAR HEALTH HEALTH
OUTCOMES. IS STILL AT NINE. I'M
THAT'S WHY MY LOT FIFTEEN
ABDUCTING APPLYING DIFFERENT
ANALYTICAL METHODS TO
INVESTIGATE THE MICROPLASTIC
CONTENT OF THESE IMPORTANT SIZE
FRACTIONS AND CURRENTLY- WHILE
WORKING ON INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
AT. SAFETY INHALABLE
MICROPLASTICS OKAY IT YES BUT
WITH SOME UNCERTAINTY AS PROOF
OF PRINCIPLE FOR OUR ANALYTICAL
MESSAGE ME ANALYZED IF YOU HAVE
TEN SAMPLE M. I. WE FOUND DAVID
TWO AND A HALF THOUSAND
MICROPLASTICS TO KEEP IT MAKES
A- I'M JUST THE PERSON CONTEXT
FOR EQUIPMENT. AB SIZE RANGE
FOR TOTAL PARTICULATE MATTER.
YOU CAN SEE IT IS ALMOST TEN
MILLION PEOPLE PARTICLES THEY
KEEP IT MAKES OF ASK FEDERAL
MICROPLASTICS BUT THERE ARE OF
COURSE LOTS OF COPY AT SIERRA.
FIRSTLY MICROPLASTIC IS TALKED
NUMBER A SECONDLY THIS IS
REALLY CREATE ESTIMATE WE NEED
SOME RIGHT BEST EXPOSURE
CONCENTRATIONS IN DIFFERENT
TYPES F ENVIRONMENTS IN
DIFFERENT. LOCATIONS OVER TIME.
HOWEVER WHAT'S IMPORTANT EVEN
IF THIS REPRESENTS A SMALL
FRACTION OF AMBIENT PARTICULATE
MATTER IS THAT MICROPLASTIC IS
PERSISTENT. SIR IF IT WORKS TO
KEEP AN EYE IN THE BODY ACROSS
THE STATE A TIME IT COULD REACH
CONCENTRATIONS THAT BECAME
DETRIMENTAL TO HEALTH AND
BECAME A HOUSE IT. IS IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE RELATIVE
CONTRIBUTION TO POTS TO
EXPOSURE BUT ALSO THE RELATIVE
PAY AGENCY THAT COMBATS OF THE
PARTICLES RACKSPACE TO AND. OF
COURSE SEVEN THOUSAND EXTRA
FACTS. SO THERE IS SOME OF THAT
MICROPLASTICS IN THAT WAY CAN
CAUSE HARM AB OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE TO HIGH LEVELS OF
PLASTIC TEST WHICH ARE SMALL
ENOUGH TO REPLACE DEEP POT THE
POTS OF THE LINK. AB CAN CAUSE
ADVERSE EFFECTS DISRAELI'S THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THERE WERE
OUTBREAKS OF DISEASE AND
SYNTHETIC TEXTILE WORKERS THE
VICE WELL DEFINED ITS CLOCK
BECAUSE LUCK. AB THIS IS THE
NYLON FLOCKING INDUSTRY WHICH
IS ESSENTIALLY A SHORT CUT
NYLON FIBER. AND WHEN IT'S CUT
WITH A MALE IT GENERATES THE
DUST WHICH IS VERY VERY FINE
REACH THE LOWER. EAST TO THE
DISEASE AB ASIDE FROM PATIENTS
PRESENTING WITH CHEST PAIN AND
SHORTNESS OF BREATH COUGH THE
DISEASE CAUSES CHRONIC
INFLAMMATION AND TISSUE
SCARRING. IN THE LIVER ADVICE.
NO THIS IS A REGISTER IT
USUALLY TO AFTER REMOVAL
EXPOSURE BUT IN SOME WAYS CASES
IT KIND OF FALLS INTO YOUR
SPIRIT TO FIGHT YEAH. AND HIGH
EXPOSURE CONCENTRATIONS HAVE
BEEN OBSERVED SITE THESE ARE
MUCH GREATER THAN WHAT WE TAX
EXPERIENCE IN THE ENVIRONMENT-
BUT OF COURSE IT RAISES THE
QUESTION OF WHY BAYERN MENTAL
EXPOSURE A FULL A FOR A LONGER
TIME PERIOD. WHAT D. S. M. IT
SHOWS WHAT THESE PARTICLES LOOK
LIKE BECAUSE YOU MAY THINK THAT
FIVE IS AND SOME OF THEM
CERTAINLY OFF FIBROUS BUT SOME
OF MY OLD SITE PARTICULATE AS
WELL. IT'S NOT JUST BEING
OBSERVED FOR NINE FLOCK BUT FOR
POLICE. POLY AND RIGHT ON WHICH
IS SIMILAR TO CELLULASE
ACETATES AS WELL. AS OF COURSE
THIS RAISES QUESTIONS IS THIS
EFFECT BECAUSE IT'S A
PERSISTENT MATERIAL IN THE LONG
OR CERTAIN ATTRIBUTES OF THE
MATERIAL WHICH MAKES IT
PARTICULARLY INFLAMMATORY.
THERE'S ALSO EVIDENCE FROM
ANIMAL STUDIES REGARDING MY
CAUSTIC TOXICITY IN THAT IT THE
LONG SORRY THE RIGHTS BECAUSE
YOU CAN SEE RELATES TO WHAT IS
BEING TOXIC FACTS. SPECIFICALLY
HIGHLY TOXIC EFFECTS THE
ETHYLENE OXIDE PROPYLENE OXIDE
BUT LUCKILY WE DEBT RATING
COUNTS THE IN THE APARTMENT. IT
JUST STAYS UP AB. BASED IN
OCCUPATIONAL SETTINGS ON ANIMAL
STUDIES MICROPLASTICS. APPEAR
TO CAUSE TOXICITY. HOWEVER THE
VERY FEW STUDIES WHICH OFTEN
LAST AB IS OF AND SAID IT'S IN
SPECIE STRESS. HOW THIS RELATES
TO HUMANS AND SPECIES WE'RE
COMPOSED AND THEY ARE OUT DAY
SITS WITH MAJORITY BEING TODAY
FOR TWENTY IS A GUY WHO SAYS
DEFINITELY IN NEED OF AN UPDATE
AND WE DEFINITELY NEED TO FILL
IN SOME OF THESE CRUCIAL
KNOWLEDGE GAPS. SO HOW MUCH
MICROPLASTIC CAUSE HARM WELL
TELL SEIZE ALREADY TOUCHED UPON
INFLAMMATION SO IF A
MICROPLASTIC WITH SEE YOU
INTERACT WITH AND I WAY STYLE
OR INTERVENE STYLE. THIS WOULD
TRIGGER A PRIOR INFLAMMATORY
RESPONSE WHICH COULD LEADS TO
TISSUE DAMAGE. HAD BEEN UP
AUDIO TRYING TO REPAIR THAT
TISSUE DAMAGE THAT BECAUSE I'VE
AT THE STIMULUS IS CONSTANT OLD
PERSISTENCE AS MICROPLASTICS
SAW. THIS TISSUE REPAIR ELEMENT
COULD BECOME HEIGHTENED DAVID
TIME AND THAT'S WHAT WITH THE
TO SCARRING AND EVENTUALLY IN
WEST CASES LOSS OF FUNCTION FOR
THE TISSUE ORGAN. OF COURSE
THIS IS A HYPOTHESIS WHICH
NEEDS TO BE TESTED FOR
MICROPLASTICS BUT IT IS A
PROPOSED. ADVERSE OUTCOME
PATHWAY FOR OF A CONSISTENT
PARTICLES. BUT ENTITLED. BUT IN
A DAY CARE AND ISOLATE WHEN I.
THEM AND I. OF THERE ARE
PARALLELS OF THE PARTICULATE
MUST SAY WE IN ITSELF IS A-
MIXTURE SO THE RIGHT CHEEK SEE
A REPRESENTATIVE COSTS. FOR A
MINUTE BEEN SACKED GOAL FOR
TRAFFIC COMMISSION YOU CAN SEE
IS A- COAL METALS AND DIFFERENT
CHEMICAL SPECIES ON THE
SURFACE. AND THE SAME CAN
HAPPEN FOR MICROPLASTICS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT SO WHETHER THESE
PARTICLES ALSO CONTRIBUTE HOME
BY DELIVERING DAY USES OF THESE
M. AMBIENCE THAT. SPECIES IS
ALSO OF CONCERN. I JUST WANTED
TO THE GOOD AS WELL BECAUSE M.
AS WELL AS I'VE MENTIONED MESA
THE PARTICLES THAT HAVE BEEN
OBSERVED IN ASPHALT
MICROPLASTIC PARTICLES WHAT WE
CONSIDER COSTS OR LARGER THAN
THE COURSE MIGHT. IN A BIG OF
AT TEN MICRONS IN SIZE IS
DOESN'T MEAN THE WHITE AND
HILUM IT JUST MEANS IF WE DO
THEY'LL PROBABLY TO POSIT OUT
NAY USE ENOUGH FOR IT TO THE
MOUTH I WILL SOLELY THEM AND
THAT LEADS TO EXPOSURE AT THE
CUTS. AND OF COURSE JOIN OF A
SOURCES SUCH AS FROM THE DIETS
FROM DRINKING WATER FROM THE
DUST. OF THE IS EVIDENCE OF
THIS TALK OF EXPOSURE. WITH
OBSERVATIONS OF HUMAN. SO IS A
VERY SMALL. STUDY ADMITTED IT'S
EVIDENCE THAT. FIERY JUST. ANAK
QUESTION. WHAT'S IS THIS.
DISTRIBUTION IN JUST POTS. AND
REFER. WHAT COMES SCOTT. AND
BECAUSE THE SMALL THE PARTICLE
THE MORE LIKELY THAT RESPECT.
FOR INTERACTION WITH CELLS AND
TISSUES EIGHT INTO UP TAKE. A
REVIEW FROM THE GUIDANCE TO
CHEESE. THANK YOU TOXIC EFFECTS
A KID IN THE CUT OF IT JUST AND
ADAM AND OF THESE OF AND FOR.
REDUCE MUCUS SECRETION AND-
AFFECTED TO GET TO MY CAR BY A-
THERE'S ALSO EFFECTS IN THE
LIVER WHICH CAN OCCUR WHICH
EXCEEDS OF CHANGES AT THE TOP
OF THE SAID AND IN FACT
COMPOSITION. BUT ALSO EQUALLY
THERE ARE SOME CITIES WHICH IS
OBSERVED BY. I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
EFFECTS AS WELL. I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE CITY'S WORLD
AND WAY OF. JUST ONE OR TWO
POLHEMUS SAY THE MAJORITY THAT
COUPLE OF STYRENE ON THE
ADMINISTERED THESE. PARTICLES
BORSA AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS.
IT'S VERY HARD TO MONITOR THE
DICE THAT'S DELIVERED TO THE
ANIMAL BECAUSE SADDAM HOLES
HELP THEMSELVES TO WATER ACT
HAWK. AND ADDITIONALLY IT IS A
QUESTION AIFA AT. THE DATE THE
TASTE IN TERMS OF HOW THE
PARTICLES WERE DISPERSED IN THE
WATER LEVEL SACRAMENTO OUT OVER
TIME DELIVERING A VERY HIGH
DAIS. AND EXPOSURE IS ALWAYS
SOME. COPYCATS SO M. I'M GONNA
SAY AWAY FROM THE FACT THAT
OUGHT TO GET IN A- STOP ONCE
WHEN IT COMES MY CLASS AND HOW.
I THINK ONE OF THE MASON. ONES
IS HOW TO REACT. TO AB HOW DOES
THIS DE BY JOE. AND GIVE THESE
AND DAY. OF COURSE WE NEEDS A
MORE ABOUT THE POTENTIAL.
EFFECTS IN HUMANS HOWEVER THE
SYSTEM AB DRIVEN BY CAUSTIC
TIGHT OF SHAPE HOWEVER THEY
SUCH THE ON IMPORTS A TOTAL. I
WHAT ABOUT THE- FILE. WITH A
LIST OF MY- TO COURSE THESE.
KNOWLEDGE GAP IN MY I JUST IT
ARE YOU THE POINT THAT. THE MAY
BEEN IN WE ALL ALL LABOR.
FACEMASK THAT TO. THIS IS
LIKELY GOING TO A PART OF A
FUTURE THE NEXT YEARS. THESE
MATERIALS. I WOULD BE SAID
ABBOTT SUGGESTS NOT SHUTTING OF
THESE FIVE IS SERVICE MASKS
INTO THE NASAL CAVITY. COULD
TRIGGER IT KEEPS INFORMATION.
AB SIMPLISTIC BUT ITIS.
ADDITIONALLY WILL MAKE. SOME
WITH THE WITH A GOOD JOB REDUCE
THE OVER SOURCES A EMISSIONS OF
APPLICATIONS SUCH AS THE- X.
AND- SOLID FUEL BETTING. BUT
WAS STILL GOING TO BE USING
PLASTIC AND A STILL LEGACY LEFT
SAID IT'S PLASTIC LESSER THE
ENVIRONMENT WHICH WILL CONTINUE
TO DEGRADE. TO THE ACTIVATION
PROFILE IS GOING TO CHANGE AND
POSSIBLY FLUX TOWARDS A HIGHER
LEVEL OF MICROPLASTIC. AS THERE
IS AN EMERGING ISSUE. I'M SORRY
FOR SPEEDING THREE THEM I HAD A
FAVOURITE I'M VERY SORRY BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND PARTICULARLY FOR STAYING UP
TO LA ELEVEN FIFTEEN ALL. IN
LONDON- WHAT DO HAVE QUESTIONS.
OKAY THREE OF US. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE PER- SO YOU MENTIONED
THAT SINCE WE'RE ALL WEARING
THESE FACE MASKS AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE YOU KNOW THAT THAT
WAS THE BIGGEST CONCERN RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE IT'S- CURRENTLY OUR
REALITY- WHAT COULD WE BE DOING
WE ARE WE IN A YEAR ARE WE
GOING TO SEE THE EFFECTS OF
THIS SOME MEDICAL AFFECTS. AND
I'M IS A REALLY GOOD QUESTION
AND I THINK IT IS A SITE IS
JUST A MANAGING IT IS ONE PAPER
THAT'S COME OUT TO SHOW YOU.
THE TO SHOW YOU THIS AB. AND I
THINK PATIENTS PRESENTED WITH
INFLAMMATORY EFFECTS IN THE
NASAL CAVITY SIMILAR TO YOU AS-
WELL IT'S COLD AT A RECENT RUN
ITIS OR NON ALLERGIC RHINITIS.
AT SYMBOL TAX MARINO I WASTED
ISN'T IT NICE COMMITTEE AND
THIS WAS POSITIVELY ASSOCIATED
WITH. THE NUMBER OF PLASTIC.
FIBERS IN THE NIGHTS. I THINK
ONE OF THE ISSUES IS THAT.
OBVIOUSLY NEED TO BUY A PTA
PART OF MANAGING THIS POPPED UP.
BUT DOES ALSO OF. YOU KNOW
WE'VE NOT HAD TO THE SPEED AT
THIS TIME SAID AS PER A LOT OF
MY OUT WHICH WE REALLY KNOW
MUCH ABOUT THE QUALITY. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW I THINK IT DOES
AND WE DON'T RATING EVEN I WILL
BOTH NOT SHUTTING IS WHAT
SOCIETY THINKS ABOUT. IF IT'S A
POSSIBLE DRIVING THIS IF IT'S
ASSOCIATED ADDITIVES AB SO WE
DEFINITELY NEED STABLE MORE
RESEARCH RATING FIGURE OUT BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO
MANAGE THE PANDEMIC'S AYE I
THINK UNTIL. MORE EVIDENCE
COMES OUT OF IT WE CAN'T REALLY
MAKE A CONCLUSIVE DECISION I'VE
AWAY AS TO AS TO WHAT. WE DO
WHICH IS THE BEST WAY FORWARD.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU EVERY IT'S
VERY CONCERNING TO ME I HAD. I
HADN'T THOUGHT ABOUT THAT YOU
KNOW US AND HELEEN. OF
MICROPLASTICS. VIA THESE MASKS
THAT WEAR AND WEARING AND- THAT
IS DEFINITELY IT LIKE YOU SAID
IT'S NOT REGULATED ON WHAT TYPE
OF MATERIALS ARE BEING USED IN.
WERE JUST ALL BEING ASKED TO
JUST PROTECT OURSELVES RIGHT
AWAY OR SOMETHING- AND SO THANK
YOU FOR ALERTING US DEFINITELY.
THAT'S OKAY WELL I WOULD SAY IS
THAT THAT IT SENATE KEATS
AFFECTED SAY IF THE MOMENT HE
D. FEEL DISCOMFORT FROM YOUR
FACE MASK YOU CAN YOU KNOW YOU
COULD PERHAPS CHANGE INTO IT TO
A DIFFERENT MATERIAL OR A
DIFFERENT TYPE AT LEAST TO SEE
IF THAT WOULD ALLEVIATE THE
PROBLEM. THANK YOU. WELL FOR A
FEATHER ALAN ALL RIGHT WORK BUT
I'M SINCE YES YOU MENTIONED
THIS IS OUR INTERNATIONAL PANEL
AND I'M I GUESS MY QUESTION TO
THE LAST PANEL HOW TO DO IT-
WHAT. THE BEST PRACTICES RATHER
JURISDICTIONS AND I'D LOVE TO
ASK OUR- FRIENDS FROM THE UK OR
CANADA ELSEWHERE IF THERE ARE
SOME GOOD EXAMPLES THAT THEY
LIKE US TO KNOW ABOUT ON THE
PUBLIC POLICY SIDE RELATING TO
THESE. IT INTENSE. SCIENTIFIC
CHALLENGES- THAT THE WE OUGHT
TO BE AWARE OF YOUR IN
CALIFORNIA WITH A B. IN THE U.
AND U. K. CANADA OR ELSEWHERE.
I GUESS I CAN I CAN GO AHEAD
AND ANSWER FIRST- FIRST OF ALL
I WOULD SAY THAT I.
CALIFORNIA'S AHEAD OF THE CURVE
RIGHT NOW I THINK IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO. BETTER UNDERSTAND-
THE EFFECTS OF DRINKING WATER
REGULATING TO BE A TO HAVE TO
MEASURE IT EXAGGERATED AND YOU
KNOW BOTH. DR RIGHT AND MYSELF
ARE BOTH ON HIS WORK WORKING
GROUP'S WITH AND SCORED. I
WOULD SAY SOME POLICIES THAT
CANADA IS STARTING TO TAKE THAT
I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED WITH OUR
I'M- MORE AROUND SOURCE
REDUCTION WILL END AND
INCREASING AND SCIENTIFIC.
AWARENESS SO THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FUNDING THAT'S GONE TOWARDS
SCIENCE AND IN CANADA. TO ASK
QUESTIONS THAT RANGE FROM THE
SOURCES THE FATE THAT AFFECTS
TO BOTH WILDLIFE AND HUMANS- SO
SCIENTIFIC FUNDING IS OBVIOUSLY
VERY USEFUL BUT WE'RE ALSO
STARTING TO SEE AN- LEGISLATION
THAT INVOLVES BOTH DEBT
REDUCTION OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC
ITEMS THAT ARE. NOT AS
SUSTAINABLY MANAGEABLE SO THEY
CAN'T BE RECYCLED THAT ARE
COMMONLY FOUND IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND- POSE RISKS TO
WILDLIFE- AND WE'RE ALSO SEEING
RECYCLING STANDARDS TO TRY TO
INCREASE RECYCLABILITY TO TRY
TO BUILD A MORE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY. OR SEEN OR EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY GOING
ACROSS THE PROVINCES AND MORE
HARMONIZED WASTE MANAGEMENT YOU
CAN GET. GREAT I'M- AND I AM
HAPPY TO. ANY OF THAT IN. WITH
YOU BUT I THINK I THINK THERE
REALLY GREAT THINGS COME OUT OF
CALIFORNIA WAS AND DAHLE BEING
WRITTEN SO DEATH. YOUR INTO
SPACES WELL- AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ON THIS. RECYCLING MY CONCERN
WITH RECYCLING IS. THAT IT
DOESN'T MATTER A WHOLE LOT
WHETHER A PLASTIC GOES INTO
LANDFILL. OR WHETHER IT GETS
RECYCLED IN TERMS OF THE
POLLUTION THAT'S BECAUSE- SO
OUR BIG PROBLEM IS REALLY-
TIRES- LEADER- ILLEGAL DUMPING
BECAUSE IT GOES INTO A LANDFILL
THE CHANCES OF IT GOING
SOMEWHERE ELSE IS VERY SMALL IF
THE LANDFILL IS PROPERLY
MANAGED. SO I THOUGHT I DON'T
THINK RECYCLING IS GOING TO
HELP WITH THIS PROBLEM BUT I'D
BE GLAD FOR YOU TO CONTRADICT
ME. SURE NOW I APPRECIATE THAT
I THINK FROM A- REALLY A
MICROPLASTIC PERSPECTIVE AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW MUCH PLASTIC
IS GOING INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
I SURE WHETHER IT GOES INTO A
CONTAINS LANDFILL OR INTO A
RECYCLING FACILITY IT'S NOT
GOING INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
HOWEVER I SOMETIMES WHEN WE
RECYCLE OUR WASTE IT GETS
SHIPPED ELSEWHERE AND SO IF IT
GOES INTO GOES TO A COUNTRY
THAT DOESN'THAVE THE SAME. I
WASTE MANAGEMENT STANDARDS AS
THE UNITED STATES THAN THAT
MATERIAL AND CAN BE DUMPED INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT- SO YES BUT I
ALSO THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TRY TO CREATE
MATERIALS THAT ARE MORE
RECYCLABLE THAT DO BUILT INTO A
MORE CIRCULAR ECONOMY BECAUSE
IT GETS RID OF SOME OF THOSE
SINGLE USE. ITEMS THAT ARE
OFTEN JUST HOSTAGE BECAUSE WE
DON'T VALUE THE MATERIAL AND
WE'VE SORT OF- CREATING
MATERIALS THAT ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE LITTERED SO I THINK AND
MEDIAN LEE I AGREE WITH YOU IN
THE LONG TERM- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU A LOT OF
OTHER ALLEN WHICH IS WHATEVER
WHEN I MET YES IF THERE'S ANY
THOUGHTS FROM OUR OUR FRIEND
FROM- THE U. K. RIGHT I WANT TO
JOIN MY THANKS. AND YOU FOR
STAYING UP- WE SHOULD HAVE THIS
THIS YEAR IN THE MOST HERE.
THAT'S FINE SIR COULD YOU ME OF
THE A AFTER JUST A YOU COULD
SPEAK TO SOME SOME. THAT WE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO VIEW YOU
THINK MIGHT BE THIS WE CAN
LEARN FROM IN THE U. K. OF THE
YEAR OR ELSEWHERE THAT YOU'VE
BEEN TRACKING I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE YOU KNOW YOU'RE COMING
AT THIS FROM A SCIENTIFIC
PERSPECTIVE BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE- COMING OUT FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE I'D LOVE TO HEAR.
SOME BEST PRACTICES YOU MIGHT
BE AWARE OF. YEAH SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY- I'M SORRY. AS SUCH
TALK ABOUT THE- THEY HAVE. SAVE
IT UP TO ADD PRECAUTION
PRINCIPLE WHICH I THINK IS YOU
NAY WHEN THERE'S A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF SCIENTIFIC
UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING
SOMETHING AND SAY THEY'VE-
RECOMMENDED STEPS TO MINIMIZE
MICROPLASTICS RELEASED TO THE
ENVIRONMENT SWITCH TO NOT
SETTING REGULATE THREE STEIN
BUT ITS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
MEMBER STATES TO YOU FOR LIFE.
IN THE U. K. WE'VE GOT A FEW
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES SAY-
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
WE BONDS WILL HAVE A TAX ON
LIKE PLASTIC BAGS STRAWS AB OF
COURSE IS A QUESTION A FAT HOW.
MUCH THAT WILL M. HELP THE
MICROPHONE IS. DOES NOT
SUMMARIES. M. AS WELL AB UNLESS
IT REALLY WENT WE'RE NOT IN A
WAY THAT THE THING THAT I DON'T
GET FRUSTRATED THAT IS THE I
THINK A LOT OF THE STEPS THAT
TAKEN. AT IN TERMS OF POLICY
REGULATION AT THE MOMENT SEEMS
TO BE FOCUSED ON REDUCING
SINGLE USE PLASTIC **** IN ART
SO TIGHTLY GOODS BUT ALSO
RECYCLING OF BY PHASE ARENA
STATE REALLY. HELP THE FIBRO TO
CA. AS A TWO. I THINK YOU KNOW
ONLY SEEMS LIKE WE'RE DOING
BECAUSE WE'RE TACKLING PLASTIC
CHEAP IT FROM MY- ONLY NAY THAT
PAVE TIRE ON FIVE ZERO THEY-
SOURCE. AB I THINK I JUST NEED
BRING AGAINST THE CONVERSATION.
AS WELL OKAY- WE NEED TO GET ON
TO THE PANEL THREE UNLESS SOME
OKAY WRITTEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALLOCATE. HALF THANK YOU ALL
THIS IS. REALLY INTERESTED AND
BEGAN REALLY DEPRESSING- BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT WE MOVED AND
FIND. SO I FOR DR OCKMAN WHO I
KNOW HAS DONE- RESEARCH ON
SOURCES AS WELL AND COMING BACK
TO THAT QUESTION OF. SAID WHERE
SURE ENERGY PLACED FIRST DO YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT THE MOST.
PREVALENT SOURCES OF
MICROPLASTICS ARE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT IS IT THE FIBERS IS
OF THE TIRES WHERE SHOULD WE BE
FOCUSING OUR ENERGY. YEAH
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION I
WAS. HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY PROJECT I'VE
ALSO DONE SOME WORK UPSTREAM IN
THE SACRAMENTO BEE DELTA- I
THINK I WOULD SAY I COMPLETELY
AGREE THAT TIRE DUST AND-
MICROFIBERS NEED TO BE-
SOMETHING THAT WE FOCUS ON I
THINK WE CAN THINK ABOUT-
RETIRES A BIT OF A WICKED
PROBLEM AND IT'S A TOUGH ONE
FOR MICROFIBRES AND PUTTING
FILTERS ON WASHING MACHINES
WILL ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. WE HAVE THE FILTERS
ON THE WASHING MACHINES OF- TWO
HUNDRED HOMES IN THE SMALL TOWN
OF PARRY SOUND UP HERE FEEDS
10% OF THE WASTE WATER KEEP
TREATMENT PLANT WE'VE SEEN A
REDUCTION OF MICROFIBERS BY 10%
SINCE WE'VE DONE ESTO- IT MAKES
THE DIFFERENCE. THE OTHER THING
I WOULD SAY TO YOUR QUESTION IS
IF WE WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
QUICK AND I'D BE INTERESTED
WHAT ON OTHERS THAT WOULD HAVE
TO SAY ABOUT THIS FROM THE
PANEL. IS FOCUSED ON PATHWAYS
INSTEAD OF THE PRODUCT UPSTREAM
I AGRICULTURAL RUNOFF
STORMWATER RUNOFF AND
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANTS ARE
ALL PATHWAYS THAT MICROPLASTICS
GO THROUGH TO ENTER THE
ENVIRONMENT- BY A RETENTION
CELLS AND RAIN GARDENS ON STORM
DRAINS WILL. PREVENT
MICROPLASTICS FROM GETTING INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT- CHANGING WASTE
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS ARE
TWENTY EIGHT I KNOW THAT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE BUT THE FILTERS ON
WASHING MACHINES CAN CERTAINLY
HELP WHAT GOES INTO THEM. AND
WITH ADDED RUNOFF WE CAN THINK
ABOUT AND USING MAYBE WETLANDS
ARE OTHER WAYS TO FILTER THE
WATER BEFORE IT GOES OUT INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND THIS IS
WHAT THE O. S. D. REPORT THAT
COMES OUT THIS MONTH WILL FOCUS
ON. I'M IN A MAJOR WAY IS WHAT
ARE THOSE PATHWAYS AND HOW CAN
WE PREVENT. OKAY L. THREE IS
GOING TO FOCUS ON THIS AREA. SO
WHY DON'T WE GET TWO PANEL
THREE UNLESS SOMEONE. HAS A
BURNING QUESTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YEAH- GOOD. TO LAUNDER. SO
PALE THREE. WOMEN EXPERTS IS A
VERY STRONG STRATEGIES FOR MASS
MY- POLLUTION. AND I USE THE
TERM MAN LIVE BECAUSE THE SIZE
STILL EMERGING ON MICROPLASTICS
IS STILL MUCH TO STUDY AND
UNDERSTAND ABOUT HOW
MICROPLASTICS IMPACT OUR
RESOURCES AND OUR BODIES. AND
WITH THAT WE WILL NEED TO LEARN
ABOUT AND POTENTIALLY DEVELOP
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN REMEDIATE
MICROPLASTICS IN WATER SOIL.
AND- PERHAPS EVEN THE AIR. IN
THE MEANTIME WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT CAN BE DONE TODAY TO
ADDRESS THIS TOXIC POLLUTION
SOURCE REDUCTION WOULD BE THE
MOST EFFICIENT. AND WASTE
MANAGEMENT IS ALSO A GROUP
CRITICAL STRATEGY. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO INVITE DOCTOR FERAL
LAVENDER LAW WITH THE SEA
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION TALK TO
US ABOUT THE NEED FOR SOURCE
REDUCTION. LITTER MANAGEMENT
AND ILLEGAL DUMPING ABATEMENT-
DOCTOR LAW YOU HAVE A FIVE TO
SEVEN MINUTES FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ACTUALLY
DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SHARE MY PRESENTATION. OF HER
UP THERE WE GO. OKAY. OKAY I'M
HOPING EVERYBODY CAN SEE YES
LINE. EXCELLENT THANK YOU WILL
HAVE TO NOON GOOD EVENING GOOD
NIGHT AND THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHAIRPERSON DR QUIRK
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IMPORTANT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. I ORIGINALLY CAME TO
THIS PROBLEM FROM THE END OF
THE PIPE SO BY THAT I MEAN THE
OCEAN AND NOT ONLY FROM THE
OCEAN BUT FROM THE DEAD END OF
THE OCEAN THE SO CALLED GARBAGE
PATCHES I'M A RESEARCH
PROFESSOR OF OCEANOGRAPHY I'M
TRAINED IN OCEAN PHYSICS AND
I'VE BEEN ON THE FACULTY OF SEA
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION R. S. C.
A. SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. I SEE IS A NONPROFIT
EDUCATIONAL ORGANIZATION OUR
PRIMARY OFFERING IS THE SEA
SEMESTER PROGRAM FOR
UNDERGRADUATES FROM COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND INTERNATIONALLY
STUDY WITH US FOR A SEMESTER
BOTH ON OUR CAMPUS IN WOODS
HOLE MASSACHUSETTS AND I'M ONE
OF OUR TWO TALL SAILING SHIPS
LIKE YOU SEE HERE THAT ARE ALSO
OCEANOGRAPHIC RESEARCH VESSELS.
SO WHEN SAILING IN THE
SUBTROPICAL LATITUDES OF THE
NORTH ATLANTIC IN THE NORTH
PACIFIC IN THE SO CALLED
GARBAGE PATCHES AS WE DO WITH
OUR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS.
WHAT YOU WOULD TYPICALLY SEE
FROM THE DECK OF A SHIP OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT STOP A NICE
CALM DAY YOU'LL HAVE LIGHT
WINDS AND NOT REALLY SEE
ANYTHING BUT- WATER SKY CLOUDS.
YOU WILL SEE FLOATING DEBRIS
DRIFT BY AND THESE ARE
TYPICALLY SINGULAR ITEMS
SOMETIMES IDENTIFIABLE LIKE
THIS BOOT. MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
THESE ARE FRAGMENTS OF SOME
ONCE LARGER OBJECT. BUT THERE
MOST DEFINITELY PLASTIC
FLOATING IN THE SEA SURFACE.
BUT IF YOU TELL PLAN TO NOT
THROUGH THE WATER AT THE SEA
SURFACE FOR JUST THIRTY MINUTES
AND SIFT THROUGH ITS CONTENTS
YOU FIND SOMETHING THAT LOOKS
LIKE THIS THESE ARE OF COURSE
THE MICROPLASTICS THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT. IN THIS
CASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MICROPLASTICS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
QUITE LARGE COMPARED TO THE
MICROFIBERS AND SOME OF THIS
THESE PARTICLES WERE. THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT IN THE LAST
SESSION THAT ARE CARRIED BY
ATMOSPHERIC DEPOSITION. SO ARE
THE SEMESTER STUDENTS HAVE TEN
POINT AND THAT'S THROUGH THE
SERVICE OCEAN THE NORTH
ATLANTIC AND PACIFIC OCEANS IN
THE CARIBBEAN SEA FOR DECADES
AND EXAMINE THEIR CONTENTS. AND
IN THE REGION'S DUMP GARBAGE
PATCHES THIS IS WHAT THE VAST
AMOUNT OF DEBRIS COLLECTED
CONSISTS OF ARE THESE PARTICLES
SO COURSE YOU WANT TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT WHERE THEY CAME FROM.
MOST OF THESE PARTICLES DID
ORIGINATE FROM LARGER PLASTIC
ITEMS THAT WEEKEND AND BROKE
APART WHEN EXPOSED IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT WHERE THIS
DEGREE COMES THESE TINY
FRAGMENTS- IT IS UNKNOWN HOW
LONG THEY'VE BEEN THERE. WHERE
THEY ORIGINATE GEOGRAPHIC
ORIGINATED GEOGRAPHICALLY OR
WHAT WHAT KIND OF ITEM THEY
ORIGINATED FROM. WE DO HAVE
PASSED THE SIZE THAT MOST OF
THIS ORIGINATES ON LAND IN THIS
IS REALLY WHERE WE'RE GETTING
TO ON THE TOPIC OF THIS PANEL.
SO FIVE YEARS AGO IN A STUDY
LED BY MY COLLEAGUE JENNA
JAMBECK AT UNIVERSITY OF
GEORGIA GEORGIA THAT WAS A
PRODUCT OF A WORKING GROUP I
MARINE DEBRIS AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR ECOLOGICAL ANALYSIS
AND SYNTHESIS- CENTER AT. UC
SANTA BARBARA. WE ESTIMATED THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC WASTE
MUNICIPAL SOLID WASTE GENERATED
ON LAND THAT ENTER THE OCEAN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TEN. AND THE
CANONICAL VALUE THAT EIGHT
MILLION METRIC TONS OF SINCE
BECOME A BENCHMARK OF THE
ANNUAL SCALE OF OCEAN PLASTIC
POLLUTION- THIS DOESN'T ACT
THANK YOU. I'M FOR ALL OF THE
SOURCE ABOUT ALWAYS GENERATED
ON LAND. SO THE ESTIMATED
PLASTIC WAIT. I'M PUT. FOR
THANKS IS ALWAYS. THE RANKS IN
SPADES. ON THE ACT TREES THIS
MESSAGE ABOUT AN INFORMAL WASTE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO THIS COULD
BE DUE TO A LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF OR IT
COULD BE DUE TO ACCIDENTAL OR
INTENTIONAL LITTERING. IN THIS
STUDY WE FOUND THAT THE TOP
EMITTING COUNTRIES WORLD IN
SOUTH AND SOUTHEAST ASIA DO
THEIR RAPIDLY GROWING ECONOMIES
AND ASSOCIATED WASTE GENERATION
BUT WITHOUT THE CAPACITY TO
MANAGE THIS INCREASING AMOUNT
OF WASTE. AND SO CONSEQUENTLY
THIS REGION BECAME THE FOCUS OF
MANY IMPORTANT AND URGENT
REMEDIATION EFFORTS. HOWEVER AN
OFTEN OVERLOOKED RESULT OF THAT
WORK WAS THAT THE UNITED STATES
RANKS TWENTIETH AND IT'S
CONTRIBUTIONS OF PLASTIC WASTE
OUT OF ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO
COUNTRIES. AND THE COASTAL
COUNTRIES OF THE E. U.
COLLECTIVELY RANKED EIGHTEENTH
ON THIS GLOBAL LIST. SO DESPITE
HAVING HIGHLY DEVELOPED AN
EFFECTIVE WASTE MANAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THE UNITED
STATES WAS A TOP CONTRIBUTOR.
FOR A FEW REASONS ONE OF ITS
LARGE COASTAL POPULATION. AND
TO ITS VERY HIGH PLASTIC WASTE
GENERATION RATES. SO IN THIS
ANALYSIS THE VERY LARGE AMOUNTS
OF MISMANAGED WASTE IN THE U.
S. WERE SOLELY A CONSEQUENCE OF
LITTERING WHICH WAS COARSELY
ESTIMATED AS 2% OF PLASTIC
WASTE GENERATION. ONE OF THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE JAMBECK
STUDY WAS THE VERY SPARSE DATA
AVAILABLE FROM MANY COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD AS WELL AS A
LACK OF STANDARDIZED
MEASUREMENT AND REPORTING
PROTOCOLS. AND EVEN WHEN THE
DATA WERE AVAILABLE ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS ILLEGAL DUMPING AND
INTERNATIONAL TRADE OF PLASTIC
WASTE THE DR RUCKMAN MENTIONED
WERE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR. SO THIS
MOTIVATED A NEW STUDY THAT WAS
PUBLISHED TO OUR LAST OCTOBER
WHERE WE LOOKED AT CLOSER LOOK
AT PLASTIC WASTE GENERATION IN
THE UNITED STATES SPECIFICALLY.
AND THE FATE OF THAT WASTE WITH
THE GOAL TO ESTIMATE ARE A
RESPOND ESTIMATE OF THE LEAKAGE
OF PLASTIC WASTE GENERATED IN
THE UNITED STATES TO THE
ENVIRONMENT GLOBALLY. SO FIRST
WE IS NEWLY AVAILABLE DATA-
WITHIN OUR COUNTRY TO REFINE
THE ESTIMATE OF PLASTIC WASTE
GENERATED. AND WE FOUND THAT
NUMBER TO BE A STAGGERING FORTY
TWO MILLION METRIC TONS IN THE
YEAR TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT'S THE
DATE OF THE MOST RECENT DATA
AVAILABLE. AND THIS WAS THE
HIGHEST OF ANY COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD IN THE UNITED STATES WE
MAKE MORE PLASTIC TRASH THAN
ANYONE ELSE. NEXT WE
INVESTIGATED HOW MUCH OF THE
WASTE WAS INADEQUATELY MANAGED
IN THE UNITED STATES DUE TO
BOTH LITTERING. AND ILLEGAL
DUMPING. AND TOGETHER THESE
PRACTICES ACCOUNTED FOR
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
METRIC TONS OF PLASTIC WASTE
DISPOSED INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
WITHIN OUR OWN BORDERS. FINALLY
WE ESTIMATED THE EXPORT OF
PLASTIC WASTE COLLECTED IN THE
UNITED STATES FOR RECYCLING. SO
FOR MANY YEARS WE HAVE EXPORTED
BALES OF PLASTICS CALLED
PLASTIC SCRAP TO COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD FOR
REPROCESSING OR RECYCLING.
USING TRADE DATA WE DETERMINED
THAT 51% OF THE PLASTICS
COLLECTED FOR RECYCLING IN THE
U. S. FOR EXPORTED EIGHTY NINE
TRADE PARTNERS MOST OF. HIS
NAME MOST OF WHOM ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO MANAGE THEIR OWN
DOMESTIC WASTE SO THE WAY I
LIKE TO THINK OF THIS IS HALF
OF WHAT I PUT IN THE BLUE BIN.
WAS SHIPPED LARGELY TO CHINA
AS- WELL USING THE DATA FROM
DATA FROM STUDIES OF THE
COMPOSITION OF THE SCRAPPY ELS
WE CONSERVATIVELY ESTIMATED THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC MATERIAL THAT
WOULD LIKELY HAVE BEEN
DISCARDED- IN THOSE PROCESSING
FACILITIES BECAUSE IT WAS OF
LOW VALUE. AND IN THOSE
COUNTRIES WITH HIGH PROPORTIONS
OF MISMANAGED WASTE WE
ESTIMATED THAT BETWEEN TWENTY
FIVE AND 75% OF THAT DISCARDED
MATERIAL WAS DISPOSED OF
DIRECTLY INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
BY OPEN. DUMPING OR OPEN
BURNING BURNING. SO THE
ESTIMATED AMOUNT OF PLASTIC
WASTE COLLECTED THE U. S. FOR
RECYCLING. THAT WAS EXPORTED
AND LIKELY ENTERED THE
ENVIRONMENT OF THE COUNTRY
PROCESSING THAT WASTE. ABROAD
IS UP TO AN ADDITIONAL ONE
MILLION METRIC TONS. AND
FINALLY FOR COMPARISON TO THAT
TWENTY TEN JAMAICAN ALICE'S WE
CALCULATED THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC WASTE GENERATED BY
COASTAL POPULATIONS. IN THE
FIFTY COUNTRIES THAT GENERATED
THE HIGHEST AMOUNTS OF PLASTIC
WASTE AND WE FOUND THAT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN UNITED STATES
RANKED AS HIGH AS THIRD
GLOBALLY AND IT'S CONTRIBUTIONS
OF MISMANAGED PLASTIC WASTE THE
COASTAL ENVIRONMENTS. WELL I
THINK IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
BUT I'LL SAY IT ANYWAY THAT
WE'RE FACING A GLOBAL CRISIS OF
RAPIDLY INCREASING AMOUNTS OF
PLASTIC WASTE FAR TOO MUCH OF
WHICH ENDS UP IN OUR SOILS OUR
WATERWAYS AND THE OCEAN. AND AS
THE LARGEST PRODUCER OF PLASTIC
WASTE IN THE WORLD THE UNITED
STATES MUST ACT TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF WASTE WE GENERATE
PLASTIC WASTE THAT WE GENERATE.
BUT ALSO TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ITS
REPROCESSING AND OUT ALTERNATE
DISPOSAL WITHIN OUR OWN BORDERS.
SO SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT WAYS
FORWARD TO PREVENT PLASTIC
POLLUTION. I THINK THE MOST
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOLUTION HAS
ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED TO THE
PLASTIC WASTE PROBLEM IS TO
CREATE LESS WASTE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. SO THERE ARE MANY
APPROACHES TO REDUCE PLASTIC
WASTE GENERATION SOME OF THESE
MIGHT INCLUDE BANDS OR
DISINCENTIVES FOR UNNECESSARY
USE. SO EXAMPLES ARE THINGS
LIKE THE BIKER READ FREE WATERS
ACTOR THE FEES FOR BAGS OR
STRAWS OR EVEN FEES TO PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS TO INCENTIVIZE
USING LESS PLASTIC THAT WILL BE
DISPOSED OF. YOU CAN ALSO
DESIGN PRODUCTS FOR REPAIR
REUSE TO DELAY DISPOSAL OR
CREATE NEW SYSTEMS FOR PRODUCT
DELIVERY AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
SINGLE USE PACKAGING. I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WITHIN THE
U. S. WE ADDRESS LOCATION
SPECIFIC DRIVERS OF ILLEGAL
DUMPING AND LITTERING SO ASKING
WHY ARE PEOPLE LITTERING WHY
ARE PEOPLE PARK PARTICIPATING
IN ILLEGAL DUMPING AND CAN WE
REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO PROPER
WASTE MANAGEMENT. I THINK WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT- DESIGN OF
EXISTING PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING
AND POTENTIALLY REDESIGN OF
MATERIALS SO THAT THESE ARE
CREATED WITH END OF LIFE
MANAGEMENT AND LINES AND
IDEALLY MAXIMIZING RECOVERY OF
THOSE MATERIALS IN A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY IS AS AS ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED. AND JUST TO-
REEMPHASIZE THAT IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE EVALUATE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCES OF
THE MATERIAL LEAKAGE SO THE
PERSISTENCE. THE BREAKDOWN
WHICH REALLY MEANS THE
FRAGMENTATION INTO SMALLER
PARTICLES AND THINGS THAT AND
ALSO THINKING ABOUT THE
CHEMICAL DEGRADATION PRODUCTS
AND ALSO THE IMPACTS ON THE
ECOSYSTEM AND HUMAN HEALTH SO
THAT WE CAN START TO PRIORITIZE
PARTICULAR ITEMS ARE
APPLICATIONS. AND BEGIN TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DR LAW AND
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ELISABETH. DR ELIZABETH FAST
MAN BACK. WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COASTAL WATER
RESEARCH PROJECTS. TO TALK
ABOUT STORMWATER AS A CONDUIT
FOR PLASTIC POLLUTION AND
CURRENT STORMWATER BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. OKAY JUST.
SHARE MY SCREEN. THANKS
EVERYBODY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. SPEAK WITH YOU I AM ONE
WELL THAT'S COMING OUT. MY NAME
IS DR ELIZABETH FASTENING BACK
I AM A PRINCIPAL ENGINEER WITH
SQUARE YOU'VE HEARD SCRIPT
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES I THINK-
MY RESEARCH FOCUSES ON STORM
WATER TREATMENT SYSTEMS WHICH
ARE KNOWN COLLECTIVELY AS BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES SO I'M
GONNA TALK TO YOU TODAY OF-
BRING UP SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER. D. N. P. IS OFFER US-
SOLUTIONS ARE FEASIBLE
SOLUTIONS FOR MANAGING
MICROPLASTICS. THERE ARE THREE
KINDS OF OPPORTUNITIES I SEE
BROADLY SPEAKING AS FOR
MANAGING MICROPLASTICS AS THEY
MOVE THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENT
ONE OF COURSE YOU JUST HEARD A
WHOLE. YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
ITS SOURCE CONTROL WHERE WE TRY
TO ELIMINATE OR MINIMIZE THE
PROBLEM WHERE IT STARTS. I
WE'VE HEARD A LOT THAT STORM
WATER IS A MAJOR- I HAD
MECHANISM FOR MOVING PLASTICS
MICROPLASTICS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT TO THE OCEAN SO I
NEXT OPPORTUNITY IS WITHIN THE
URBAN DRAINAGE SYSTEM WHERE
FROM A SOLUTION STANDPOINT
WE'RE TRYING TO ELIMINATE MY
CAR CHECK PLASTICS TRANSPORT BY
EITHER TREATING CAPTURED
STORMWATER. OR MINIMIZING HOW
MUCH STORM WITH- SLOWS DOWN THE
STREAM. AND THESE TWO
OBJECTIVES ARE REALLY WHAT M.
P.'S LONG TO DO FOR OTHER
REASONS- FOR VIRTUALLY ALL
OTHER TYPES OF POLLUTANTS. IN
RUN OFF. AND FINALLY THE LAST
SOLUTION IS FILTERING MASS
QUANTITIES OF OCEAN WATER AT
THE END OF PIPE WHICH I DON'T
THINK IS REALLY A VIABLE
SOLUTION SO WE'LL JUST. SEND
THAT OUT OF IT SO I'M GONNA
FOCUS AND BMPS. AND WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES THERE MAY BE OR-
THAT BRING UP QUESTIONS. I'D
THROUGHOUT THE URBAN LANDSCAPE
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
SPENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
TO INSTALL TRASH CAPTURE
SYSTEMS WITHIN THE URBAN
DRAINAGE NETWORK. CASH CAPTURE
SYSTEMS ARE FOCUSED ON REMOVING
PARTICLES AND DEBRIS THAT ARE
LARGER THAN FIVE MILLIMETERS. I
HAVEN'T AND IT BECAUSE THERE IS
A QUESTION OF SCALE HERE I
QUICKLY FIGURED OUT THAT- FIVE
MILLIMETERS IS ABOUT THE SIZE
OF YOUR PENCIL ERASER. OR
WHATEVER WHEN WE USE THESE
PENCILS I'D SAY THE QUESTION IS
THAT AT TECHNOLOGY THAT'S USED
TO THAT. IS DIRECTED AT. FIVE
MILLIMETERS OR LARGER GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE FOR MICROPLASTICS
WHICH BY DEFINITION ARE SMALLER
THAN FIVE MILLIMETRES. WE HAVE
ANOTHER SUITE OF BNP'S THAT ARE
CONSIDERED TREATMENT BMPS AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGY WITHIN THE
CATEGORIES OF CHEAP OF BMPS AND
THEIR TWO THAT KIND OF GIVE US.
MAYBE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TREATING MICROPLASTICS WATER
FILTRATION TYPE BMPS AND THE
OTHER ARE BROAD SUITE OF BMPS
THAT SOAK RUN OFF INTO THE
GROUND. AND THEN FUNDAMENTAL
THERE IS WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE ENOUGH STORMWATER THERE IS
ENOUGH STORM WATER CAPTURE BY
BMPS TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AT A
LARGE SCALE SO TRUST CAPTURE
SYSTEM HOW DO THEY WORK AS I
SAID THEY'RE DESIGNED TO
CAPTURE LARGE PARTICLES AND
DEBRIS. THERE ARE THREE MAJOR
CATEGORIES OF TRASH CAPTURE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE BEING
INSTALLED ALL THROUGHOUT THE
URBAN DRAINAGE NETWORKS IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE LOTS OF
INDIVIDUAL PRODUCTS THAT YOU
CAN FIND WITHIN EACH OF THESE
CATEGORIES BUT HERE THE THREE
WAYS IN WHICH THEY WORK. YES WE
A STORM DRAIN INSERTS WHICH ARE
BASICALLY LARGE MESH TRAPS OR
SCREENS THAT CLEAN OUT DEBRIS
WITHOUT IMPEDING THE FLOW
THROUGH THE STORMWATER NETWORK.
REMEMBER FIVE MILLIMETERS IS
BECAUSE YOUR PENCIL SO WE'RE
NOT TALKING SKILLS TYPING
SKILLS REMOVING YOUR WINDOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PRETTY
LARGE CHUNKS. BAFFLE BOXES AND
HYDRODYNAMIC SEPARATORS ARE TWO
CLASSES OF- TRASH CAPTURE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE INSTALLED
BELOW GROUND. THERE IN LINE
WITH THE STORMS THE STORM DRAIN
STORY THE STORM A STORM WATER
NETWORK- WHERE- SO IT'S IN LINE
WITH YOUR PIPE NETWORK
UNDERGROUND IN A BAFFLE BOX
USUALLY HAVE THIS ARRANGEMENT
OF THAT SAME KIND OF LARGE
SIZE- MESH SCREEN. AND THEN THE
BATTLE'S CREATE THE STAGNANT
ZONES WERE HEAVIER PARTICLES
CAN SETTLE OUT BY GRAVITY. IN A
HYDRODYNAMIC SEPARATOR IT
CREATES A SWIRLING ACTION THAT
SALARY- AND SEPARATE STATE
HEAVIER PARTICLES AND DEBRIS TO
SEPARATE OUT OF THE WATER AND
FALL TO THE BOTTOM. AND THEN
YOU HAVE A BACKTRACK AND BACK
TO BACKING TRACK THAT COMES
ALONG EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE AND
SUCKS OUT THE DEBRIS THAT'S
CAUGHT IN THE SYSTEMS. SO ALL.
I SORRY ULTIMATELY EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THE SYSTEMS ARE AIMED AT
VERY LARGE PARTICLES AND-
DEBRIS AND SO THEY ARE NOT BY
DEFINITION THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
CAPTURE MICROPLASTICS. SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO FILTRATION TYPE
BMPS. YOU HEARD A COUPLE OF OUR
PANEL MEMBERS TALK ABOUT RAIN
GARDENS AND BY RETENTION
SYSTEMS. THESE ARE TWO TYPES OF
FILTRATION TYPE BMPS WHOSE
OBJECTIVE IS TO CAPTURE RUNOFF
FROM SAY A PARKING LOT OR MAYBE
AS MUCH LAND AREA AS A CITY
BLOCK. AND IT THAT MIGHT HAVE
COME INTO- WHAT LOOKS LIKE WHAT
LOOKS LIKE A GARDEN ON THE
SURFACE. I AND THEN IT FILTERS
VERTICALLY THROUGH A MEDIA AT
THE SOIL LIKE MEDIA BUT IT'S
BEEN ENGINEERED TO TRAP VARIOUS
TYPES OF POLLUTANTS. DON'T SAY-
WE'RE LUCKY ON THIS THAT DOCTOR
SUTTON- ACT HAS OUR TO
RESEARCHER THAT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED THE ONLY STUDIES THAT
EXIST THAT SAY YES THERE'S
PROMISE FOR THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY FOR REMOVING
MICROPLASTICS. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THESE ARE SMALL SCALE BMPS
THEY TREAT RUNOFF FROM A VERY
LIMITED LAND AREA. SO TO HAVE
THAT IN IMPACT ON A ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS IS VERY
CHALLENGING. WE TAKE HAVE
REGION SCALE BNP'S. SO THESE
ARE BMPS THAT MANAGE RUNOFF OR
ACCEPT RUNOFF FROM SAKE A
COUPLE OF HUNDRED ACRES MAYBE.
OF LAND AREA- BUT THERE'S
REALLY NO MECHANISM WITH IN
THESE TYPES OF BMPS TO REMOVE
POLLUTANTS. I SAID THESE TYPES
OF BMPS IS TO TAKE RUNOFF AND
SOAK INTO THE GROUND EITHER
BMPS WE BUILD FOR GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE AND WHAT STORMWATER
HARVESTING FOR TO THE
SUPPLEMENT POTABLE USES POTABLE
AND NON POTABLE USES. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WERE THE
POTENTIAL PROBLEM IS THAT AS
WATER SOAKS INTO THE GROUND IT
MAY BRING THOSE MICROPLASTICS
WITH IT IT MAY MIGRATE THROUGH.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
IT'S NEVER BEEN STUDIED. SO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WHAT WE HAVE I
THINK IS A CHALLENGE OF SCALE
WHEN IT COMES TO BMPS AND THEIR
POTENTIAL TO MANAGE
MICROPLASTICS. THEY'RE NOT
MICROPLASTICS ARE NOT. CAPTURED
BY EXISTING TRASH CAPTURE
SYSTEMS WE HAVE SOME BMPS THAT
SHOW PROMISE FOR MANAGING
MICROPLASTICS BUT IT'S ONLY A
LOCAL SCALE. MOST B. M. P.
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL NOT SCALE
SUFFICIENTLY- TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITH THE CURRENT
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT
DRIVE THAT THAT CAUSE US TO
BUILD BMPS- AND SO THAT'S- WHAT
I HAD TO SHARE WITH YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING THE TIME. TO BE WITH US
TODAY- DR- FASTENING BACK. ARM
AND NOW I'D LIKE TO INVITE TO
INVITE DR ALEXIS JACKSON. FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY TO TALK
ABOUT EXPLORING NEAR TERM
SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE THE
PRESENCE OF PRACTICE PLASTIC
PARTICLES ON FARMLANDS. AND
LIMIT REENTRY TO WATERWAYS AND
OCEAN OF COURSE WE'VE SEEN A
COUPLE OF WAYS. FOR OUR
PRESENTATIONS ON HOW THE
PLASTIC PARTICLES CAN END UP ON
FARMLAND FROM- THE DEPOSITION
FROM THE AIR AS WELL AS
PRESUMABLY FROM- SEWER SLUDGE
SO DOCTOR JACKSON- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANKS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY I'M TODAY I'M GONNA BE
HIGHLIGHTING SOME FINDINGS FROM
A STUDY THAT WOULD BE MORE IN
COLLABORATION WITH RESEARCHERS
AT UC SANTA BARBARA
MICRODELETION CALIFORNIA ALSO
OUR VALUE ENGINEERING ON. AND
THIS IS WORK ON. MY MOTHER OKAY
WHAT IS. THANK. JUST GO- IS
THERE ANY WAY YOU LOOK AT. ALL
IMPROPER OKAY TRY. HI JUSTIN
SOMETHING AND THEN TRY AGAIN.
NOT SURE WHAT TO. BE USED ON.
OKAY. SORRY ABOUT THAT
INTERRUPTION SO WE'RE
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
SYNTHETIC FIBERS THANK IT
SHATTERED FROM THE WASHINGTON
AREA AND WEARING REALLY OUR
FAVORITE KIND OF STRETCHING
FOR. HIGHER AS WE GET ANY
BIOLOGICAL AND- MICROPLASTICS
THIS YOU MIGHT ARE. WE WANTED
TO ACTUALLY WANT BY THE PHONE
MAKER I HEARD AND HOW. OUR AND
SO WE LOOKED AT THIS. TO
EIGHTEEN I MODELED THE- I HEARD
YOU NUMBER WE WASHING- WHEN
THEY INTO ARE AGAINST AND THEN
FALLING. AFTER THERE AND- IT
OUT SLIDES I'M AND WHAT ABOUT
THIS PLACE AND TO. ENVIRONMENT
WHERE. AND SO WE DO WE BY AT.
ONE OF. OUR OUR FRIENDS BE MORE
IN TWENTY NINE AMONG THESE MANY
EXPORT NEXT ON MY EYEBROWS-
EQUAL OF THIRTEEN POINT. THREE
AND WE ALSO THAT RECORD AN
INCREASE IN AND AS LOOK BLACK I.
RATIONALLY SHIFTING THE BURDEN.
JUDGE FROM THOSE ALRIGHT
RESERVED. TO AND SO ACCORDING
TO THE FIBERS ARE ANY BRAND. IN
PART. AND SO WHAT FINDINGS ARE
REALLY TOUGH US THIS WE HAVE A
GROWING PROBLEM WITH MICHAEL
YOUR HOW AND THAT THIS IS ISSUE
NOT JUST. THIS WOULD BE A LOT
OF PEOPLE. IT'S NOT THAT
ACTUALLY I THINK START TALKING
BLUES ESPECIALLY THOSE NEEDS OF
OUR THAT WE KNOW OFF. BRAND.
THE PRESENCE OF MICROFIBERS
HAVE THE SAME IMPACT ON SOIL AS
DROUGHT CONDITIONS IMPACTED
PRODUCTION DRAMA SOMETHING WE
ALL. RIGHT AND ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT. WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT
THESE MAKE A FIVE AND MAX. I SO
OR THAT ALSO IMPACTING- RIVALS.
AND THEN THE LAST PART OF THAT
WE KNOW THAT PLASTICS. BROWN
BEGAN AS OF THE WOODS ARE THAT
WORKING- AND THAT THEY CREATE.
FOR PERSONAL STOCK. AND SO WHAT
WE DO IN LIFE AND THESE KIND OF
FINDING WHAT THE NEW YEAR HOME
OR. I'M SO ONE OF THE THINGS
WAS MEANT TO IS THAT. FIVE EVEN
THINK ABOUT DO WE DESIGN.
STYLES THEY SHOULD LAST THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT YOU DO
BRITAIN'S. NOT MAYBE LONG. LIKE
MOST. THERE WERE POLICING THAT
WAS AND ALSO HOW BETTER CITING.
AND SO WITH RESPECT TO BUILT UP
ALL OF THE ACTION YOU KNOW THE
BIG BANKS YES. YEAH THIS YEAR
WE BILLS IN- ASSEMBLYMEMBER IS
THE NUMBER. AGAIN TO THIS MY
ACT. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT DID
IN OUR IS THAT WE WANT TO MODEL
THE- ACCESS. ALL THANK YOU BE
STRUCTURED IN A NUMBER. I'M AND
SO THIS IS JUST A LABOR OF SOME
OF THIS. LOOKING AT THE STUDY
SO SOME OF THEM ARE AT WHAT
WHAT IT LOOK LIKE IT HOW IS IT
SOME KIND OF ALTERCATION BACK.
IN WASHINGTON. AND WITH THE
PROBLEM WITH YOUR- WEATHER
THERE THAT LINE. AFTER HIS AND
EARLIER SOME POLICIES LOOK AT
WHAT WE LOOK LIKE TO TRAIN FROM
A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE. GEN CHIU
HIGHER LEVEL I'M THERE ISSUES
SO SHE WOULD ALL GUNS INTER IN
ONE GET OUT. THIS IS JUST SOME
OF THE HIGH LEVEL FINDINGS-
THANK YOU MATTER THE SCENARIO
MODELING AND WE WERE LOOKING AT
WHAT DO THESE POLICY
INTERVENTIONS. TO MICROFIBER
EMISSIONS ONLINE ALSO LOOK AT
THIS WATER THIS MORNING SOME
MINUTES I AM RESPOND. SO THE
FIRST AWAY ARE YOU NOT ALLOWED
OF THESE ARE REALLY VERY SENSE
IS THAT THIS SOONER INTERNET.
START MORE EFFECTIVE OR EFFORTS
ARE TO REDUCE MY PRIVATE. AND
SO WE SEE THAT IN AREAS. WHERE.
ONE AND- HUNDRED SPEED. IS THAT
WILL TREAT NON YOU CAN BE A
PART OF SOLUTION I'M WE SEE
THAT THOSE ARE HIGHLY WE'RE
SEEING AND I DECLINE IN NUMBER
MY THERE. THOSE ARE COMING FROM
THE- IN LINE- OR WASHER. AND
THIS IS LOCAL THAT LINE IS FROM
OF. HOW QUICKLY. I'M WE'RE
THOSE SOLUTIONS AFTER
CALIFORNIA AND THE PERCENTAGE
RIGHT SO. I'M SOLUTIONS ARE PUT
OUT FOR A 100% OF CALIFORNIANS
YOU SEE A SHARPER MIND NUMBER
MY NUMBERS THAT ARE ENTERING
LANDS FIRST IS WHEN IT'S ONLY
IN THE BANK STATE. AND THEN THE
THIRD ONE THAT I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY REALLY INTERESTING IS
THE FACT THAT. THERE'S A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS AROUND WHAT
INVESTMENTS BETTER WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT INFRASTRUCTURE.
ENGINE THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT
IF ARBITRATION ADDITION BETTER
THIS WILL HELP US ALL. WE
ACTUALLY SEEMS AREAS SIX DID
THIS IS THAT SEEN IN. IN MY.
WHY IS THAT THAT'S BECAUSE THE
AFTER IS THAT USE BROWN'S LINE
BY A SOLID. IT IS ACTUALLY JUST
READ EQUAL OR MORE. AFTER WE
ABOUT SIMPSON'S IN ORDER TO
REALLY GENERAL. AND SO. IN
WANTED TO TAKE A FROM. S. ASKED
WHICH IS DON'T YOU HAVE A
GROWING MY- PROBLEM. HERE AND
HOW IT'S NOT THAT'S JUST OUT OF
HEALTH OUTSIDE OF. RIGHT VOTE
COASTAL AND INLAND. LAST
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT THE
FIRES ARE READ. THE APPLYING A
BIOS ALL NINE ALLAFRICA IS. AND
ACTIONS GLORIA OUR WATER ARE
YOU. BUT I JUST WANT YOU AGAIN-
AND I ADDRESS YOUR WELL I
AROUND THE STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR JACK'S- LASTLY
I TO INVITE DOCTOR K. O'NEILL
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF.
BERKELEY TO TALK ABOUT WHY IN
HIGH. WE NEED TO ADDRESS
BEHAVIOR AS IT RELATES TO
PLASTIC USE AND PASSED PLASTIC
WASTE GENERATION. OKAY HEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR EVERYBODY'S-
THE PRESENTATION SO FAR AND I'M
UNDERSTANDING AND LOOKING AT
THE VIEW YES LET CHAU. SUS
RIGHT- AND YEAH JUST TRYING TO
GET AT THE. SORRY I WILL SO
THANK EVERYBODY AGAIN FOR
AMAZING PRESENTATIONS I'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH IN THE COURSE
OF THE AFTERNOON BECAUSE MOST
OF MY WORK IS ABOUT WHAT YOU
MIGHT CALL MATTER PLASTICS BUT
IT'S INTERESTING TO CAN THINK
ABOUT HOW TO APPLY SOME OF
THOSE IDEAS AND IDEAS I'VE
HEARD TO THINKING CONNECTING
WITH CONSUMER BEHAVIOR I JUST
BRIEFLY- I AM A PROFESSOR AT UC
BERKELEY I WALK ON THE GLOBAL
POLITICS MOSTLY OF WASTE AND
PLASTICS- BUT INCREASINGLY I'M
DRAWN INTO THE LOCAL- POLITICS
OF PLASTICS ZERO WASTE THE
BUCKLEY LEVEL AND BEYOND
BECAUSE SIMPLY WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IN THIS. ARENA
SO CLEARLY AFFECTS THE STATE
AND THE HEALTH OF OUR PLANET.
SO- SO MY- AND CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR AND I'LL JUST KIND OF
GIVE YOU THAT THE FUNDING I
HAVE NOW IS THAT- ITS CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR IS IMPORTANT BUT IT IS
AND IT'S A NECESSARY PROTECT
HEART OF THE SOLUTION BUT IT IS
BY NO MEANS. SUFFICIENT AND IN
FACT ALL THE- LINES OF INQUIRY
LINES OF A POLICY MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE
BUT- FOR MANY FOLKS
MICROPLASTICS AND NOT THE
MAINFRAME. OF THE GLOBAL
PLASTICS PROBLEM A LOT OF
STUDIES POINT OUT THAT WHEN
THEY TALK TO PEOPLE THE FIRST
THING THEY THINK ABOUT A MACRO
PLASTICS IN THE OCEAN HAT
MICROPLASTICS ARE. KIND OF
COMPLICATED A DEPENDS ON HOW
THEY'RE FRAMED BUT PUBLIC
AWARENESS TENDS TO BE FAIRLY
LOW AND THIS SUGGESTS THAT
CHANGING CONSUMER BEHAVIOR ON
THESE GROUNDS IT IS QUITE HARD.
BUT I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MAYBE WE HOW WE MANAGE
THAT AND SOME OF THE
APPLICATIONS. OF MICROPLASTICS
AND ZERO WASTE EUROPE PLASTICS
POLICIES TO- THIS PARTICULAR
PROBLEM AND I WANT TO NOTE TO
THE OUTSET THAT. MICROPLASTICS
OF THE CONTRIBUTION THAT WE AS
WEALTHY COUNTRIES MAKE TO OCEAN
PLASTICS POLLUTION. ALL WHILE A
LOT OF THE COASTAL ALL FLOW IS
FROM- DEVELOPING COUNTRIES AS
PROFESSOR LAWS PRESENTATION
SHOWED- MORE MICROPLASTICS
ACTUALLY COME FROM THE COAST OF
THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
WEALTHY COUNTRIES SO THAT GIVES
US EVEN MORE RESPONSIBILITY. TO
BE THINKING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM.
SO EXISTING CONSUMER TIME TO SO.
THAT THEY'RE AWESOME- WE'VE
ALREADY SOMEONE'S ALREADY
MENTIONED THE LOWEST IN THE US
AND IN EUROPE ON'T RINSE OFF
MICROBEADS IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NATIONALLY AND EARLIER OF
COURSE IN CALIFORNIA. ARE
AWARENESS I DEFINITELY ON THE
ON THE UP A WITH MEDIA REPORTS
ABOUT MICROPLASTICS ABOUT-
BASICALLY ABOUT THE PREVALENCE
NOW OF PLASTIC IN THE
APPEARANCE OF PLASTICS IN HUMAN
BODIES. IN BLOOD. ALL THE WAY
UP THE FOOD CHAIN THAT IS
CERTAINLY A RAISE A LOT OF
AWARENESS NGOS ARE VERY MUCH
MOBILIZED AROUND THIS AND AS WE
CAN TELL FROM TODAY THE SO
MUCH. SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND I
THINK HEALTH CONCERNS HAVE
REALLY BEEN THE DRIVER. THE
MAIN DRIVER WHEN IT COMES TO
SPECIFIC ACTION AROUND MICRO
PLASTICS- WE HAVE DEVICES THAT
WASH AND DRY FILTERS THAT
DOCTOR JACKSON TALKED ABOUT
THAT'S- A BIT MORE MY NEXT
SLIDE. HOWEVER A TIRE FRAGMENTS
AND OTHER SOURCES OF MICRO.
PLASTICS A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
TO ADDRESS FROM A CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR PERSPECTIVE ON RECALL
FOR MORE HOLISTIC. APPROACH
THAT ALSO. FOCUSES ON SOURCE
REDUCTION. OTHERWISE THE DR
PHIL TO A I'M REALLY- TO.
FOLLOWING UP ON EARLIER
PRESENTATIONS HERE BUT I WAS
LOOKING AT THIS RECENT STUDY
THAT STUDY THAT LOOKED AT IN
GRAHAM DEVICES BUSES EXTERNAL
FILTERS FOUND THEM TO BE. QUITE
EFFECTIVE AND ALSO AFFORDABLE I
FEEL LIKE I'M DOING A LITTLE AD
HE IF A GUPPY FRIEND AND KORABL
BUT- THERE YOU GO THE- IDEA OF
THEM ONE OF THESE THESE
CONSUMERS CHANGES IS TO
ENCOURAGE. US TO ACQUIRE
FILTERS OR IN IN- IN LAUNDRY
DEVICES TO REMOVE- MICROPHONE
OF MICROFIBRES FROM UP CLOSE
BEFORE THEY ENTER- THE WATER
SUPPLY. AND AS I WAS-
RESEARCHING THIS AND THINKING
ABOUT IT I THOUGHT WELL MAYBE
IN A ONE INTERVENTION COULD BE
SOME KIND OF ENERGY STAR
EQUIVALENT FOR. LOTS OF PLANTS
AS IF. THAT HAVE FILTERS HAVE
THE MECHANISMS IN THEM TO
REDUCE THE ENTRY OF FIBRES INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT ENERGY STAR HAS
BEEN A VERY POPULAR. PROGRAM
AMONG CONSUMERS. BUT THEN I TO
WILL WELCOME THINK LEARN FROM
MACRO- TO USE THAT THE CAN.
TOPLESS IS REALLY MORE MY FIELD
OF STUDY. AND NOTED LEE HOW CAN
WE CONNECT THIS TO OF ALL THE
ZERO WASTE EFFORTS BAG BANS
SINGLE USE FOOD WELL ORDINANCES
THAT HAVE BECOME PART OF OUR
LIVES. AND THIS IN TURN TO
PROTECT- PREVENT MICROPLASTICS
TO THE EMISSION OF SECONDARY
MICROPLASTICS THE GOOD NEWS ON
ON THIS FRONT IS THAT GLOBAL
POLLS SHOWED CHANGING NORMS
ATTITUDES REGARDING. SINGLE USE
PLASTICS AND THESE HAVE
GENERATED LOCAL NATIONAL AND
CROSS NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL
REGULATIONS THE BAD NEWS S
THAT. THESE MEASURES ARE BEING
CHALLENGED- A COUPLE OF FRONTS
BOTH BY PLASTICS INDUSTRY IN
OTHER OPPOSITION BUT MOST
IMMEDIATELY THE PANDEMIC IT
COULD IS THREATENING TO
UNDERMINE. CONSUMER LOANS AND
SUPPORT AROUND REDUCING SINGLE.
USE PLASTICS IN OUR DAILY LIVES.
SO GIVING A CALL OF EXAMPLES OF
CHANGING. SOCIAL NORMS IN THE
U. K. YOU SEE- 55% OF
RESPONDENTS SAYING THEY CHANGE
THEIR FOOD PURCHASING HABITS
BASED ON HIS COVERAGE. ON THE
HIGH DEGREE OF CONCERN 41% VERY
CONCERNED FORTY FOUR VERY
CONCERNED. ABOUT PLASTIC AND
PLASTIC PACKAGING NOT FROM AN
ABSCESS MORI POLL IN THE UK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE U. S.
SIMILARLY A LITTLE HARD TO FIND
THE DIRECT DATA ON PLASTICS
THIS IS THIS IS- THE MOST
RECENT AND RELEVANT ALL. DATA
THAT I FOUND THAT TWO THIRDS OF
AMERICANS WOULD BE WILLING TO
PAY MORE FOR ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PRODUCTS PERHAPS IT'S
NOT SURPRISING AS A PARTISAN
BREAKDOWN HERE. THIS IS THE IN
TURN GENERATED ON NATIONAL AND
LOCAL SOLUTIONS THIS MAP TO
SHOWS THE- STATEWIDE. ACTIONS
AROUND PLASTIC SINGLE USE
PLASTIC GROCERY BAGS AGAIN
CALIFORNIA LEADING THE WAY
THERE- AND THE GREEN STATES
THEIR UNFORTUNATE CHOICE OF
COLOR I WOULD SAY FOR THIS- FOR
THIS VISUALIZATION BUT THIS
REPRESENTS SOME OF THE INDUSTRY
PUSH BACK HE'S A STATE FROM
HAVE PREEMPTIVE BACK UP
PREEMPTIVE MEASURES TO PREVENT
PLASTIC BAG RESTRICTIONS WITHIN
FROM EUROPE FROM FROM TEXAS
WITHIN THE STATE OR THAT'S NOT
SPENT A VERY AGGRESSIVE TURN AS
THAT NUMBER HAS INCREASED IN
PAST YEARS. AND THEN WE HAVE
LOCAL SYSTEM GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO BUCKLEY IT'S SINGLE USE FOOD
WEB PRODUCTION ORDINANCE FROM
AND LETTER REDUCTION ORDINANCE
THROUGH TWENTY NINETEEN- HAS
BEEN DESIGNED TO COMBAT SINGLE
USE FOOD WHERE IN PARTICULAR
WITH. BY REPLACING THE
COMPOSTABLE PLASTICS AND A
CHARGE AND WILL SERVE MUSICAL
PLATES AND CUTLERY UC BERKELEY
TO. AIMING TO ELIMINATE ALL
NONESSENTIAL SINGLE USE
PLASTICS BY TWENTY THIRTY SO
THESE MEASURES HAVE BEEN GREAT
THEY'VE BEEN BACKED BY CHANGES
IN PUBLIC OPINION. AND CHANGES
IN IN CONSUMER BEHAVIOR HAPPEN
NOTCHED A LONG BY THE
AVAILABILITY OF ALTERNATIVES.
AND FEES AND SO ON. BUT RIGHT
NOW I THINK WE'RE WE'RE IN
CRISIS. SO MANY REASONS BUT OF
THE MIND ABBAS IS DOING WORK ON
ON THE IMPACT OF THE NINETEEN
ON ZERO WASTE AND DISPOSABLE-
GETTING RID OF DISPOSABLE
SINGLE USE PLASTICS AND WE'RE
FINDING THAT RIGHT NOW- THIS IS
THIS. SINGLE USE PLASTICS ARE
BECOMING A PROBLEM AGAIN WEBER
BUT THE HOW MASKS THEMSELVES
MAY BE A DIRECT SOURCE. OF
MICROPLASTICS INTO OUR BODIES
AS WE WENT THEM WELL CERTAINLY
THAT GOING TO BE- A SOURCE OF
MICROPLASTICS IN- WATERWAYS IN
THE AIR AS AS THEY ARE DISPOSED
OF AND- BUT THINKING ABOUT
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR REALLY THIS
IS. THIS IS THIS IS BEEN A
MAJOR CHANGE WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE OPINION POLL DATA OR-
CHANGING BEHAVE DATE DATA WE
SEE RETAILERS AND. FOOD
BUSINESSES- LIVING VERY QUICKLY
TO BAMA. AND ALSO SAW WAS SEEN
THE STALLING OF LEGISLATION
FRANCISCO- REIMPOSING ITS BAG
BAN I THINK THIS IS REALLY
CRITICAL WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT POLITICAL ACTION CAN
BE TAKEN. TO REDUCE PLASTIC BAG
TO- REDUCE MICROPLASTICS GOING
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT. SO MY
RECOMMENDATIONS- THIS IS JUST
BRIEFLY FROM STUDIES THAT. WE
NEED TO RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS-
ACTIONS NEED TO ENGAGE PEOPLE
IN THEIR EVERYDAY RELATIONSHIP
WITH PLASTICS THE STUDY- ON THE
TOP THAT IT HIGHLIGHTS THAT
pOF SWIMMERS WERE BY FAR AND
AWAY THE MOST AWARE OF THE
PROBLEM. AND THEN ALSO BUT IT
ALSO MEANS TARGETING MANY TYPES
OF MICROPLASTICS MIGHT MEAN
WORKING OUTSIDE OF THE REALM OF
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR. GOING BACK
TO THIS NINETEEN EIGHTEEN DATA
ON THE FROM THE U. K. HERE
THERE ARE ASKED WHOSE PROBLEM
IS IT AND YOU SEE CONSUMERS
SAYING HEY YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
OUR WHOSE IT IS IF ALL OF THE
ABOVE BUT IT'S NOT JUST US.
PLEASE TAKE ACTION AT OTHER
LEVELS COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE
PACKAGING THE COMPANY'S CELL
PACKAGING AND THE GOVERNMENT.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S A- AN
OPINION THAT'S WORTH BEARING IN
MIND AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
THINKING ABOUT DEALING WITH
THIS PROBLEM. SO ULTIMATELY
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR IS NECESSARY
BUT BY NO MEANS CLOSE TO A
SUFFICIENT PART OF THE
SOLUTION. OBVIOUSLY WE NEED-
THE STANDARD SUITE APPROACHES
EDUCATION AWARENESS
TRANSPARENCY WHAT GOES INTO
PRODUCTS. PRODUCT DESIGNED
MULCH MATERIALS ALTERNATIVES
LAWS BUT I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC. HOPEFULLY OF THE
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH
REESTABLISH ZERO WASTE PLASTICS
GNOMES ANTI DISPOSAL THE ANTI
SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE. AND
PROGRAMS AS WE MOVE BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC AND OF COURSE MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY AT ANY BE INSTRUMENTAL
IN THAT. PROCESS SO I'LL STOP
THERE HERE ARE SOME OF THE
REFERENCES THAT I- REFERENCE
DURING THE TALK AND I'LL UPLOAD
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DR O'NEILL-
WE'RE NOW TO A QUESTION PERIOD
I'M THE ONLY ONE- WHO ARE.
SEEMS TO BE HERE THIS LATE. WE
DID RUN OVER TIME- ARE THERE
QUESTIONS FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
ONLINE. THE IF SENATOR START OR
ONE OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS
ONLINE YOU'RE WELCOME TO ASK A
QUESTION NOW. OKAY SO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO- FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL OF
YOU- PANEL OF PARTICIPANTS
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND- YOU
KNOW YOU YOU CERTAINLY CHANGED
MY VIEW ON A NUMBER OF TOPICS
AND I'M SURE OTHERS AS WELL- I
ALSO HAVE HERE- MY STAFF- AND
THEY HAVE- WHO SET THIS UP AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE. THEIR TIME.
THAT IS BEING SPENT ON. CELL BY
YOU VERY JOSH AND PAGE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE NOW GETTING INTO
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS SECTION. SO
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW TWO
MINUTES EACH I DON'T SEE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM WHO IT WANTS TO
SPEAK. SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO.
TO LET'S SEE. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS. GET
EVERYBODY'S GOT TWO MINUTES TO
SPEAK. AND PHONE MODERATOR IT
COULD YOU PLEASE PLACE OUR
FIRST CALLER ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT OVER THE PHONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IT WOULD BE JUST ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST COMMENTS.
IT LOOKS
LIKE I HAVE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT NOW AND WE'LL WATCH
THE FIRST LINE OF NUMBER TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY HI THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHAIRS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS NOW ON THE COUNTRY
REPRESENTING SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF THE ENVIRONMENT
AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY THERE IS
AMPLE EVIDENCE OF THE DANGERS
OF BOX OF MICROPLASTIC AND HAVE
ON OUR HEALTH AND VULNERABLE
ECOSYSTEMS BECAUSE OF THIS THE
SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT HAS TAKEN ACTION ON
THE ISSUE OF MICROFIBERS. AND
IS CONDUCTING A PILOT PROJECT
TO CAPTURE MICROFIBERS FROM
EXISTING WASHING MACHINE WE
KNOW EXTERNAL FILTERS HAVE LONG
PROTECTED SEPTIC SYSTEMS FROM
MICROFIBRES IN OTHER COLLISION
AND SO OUR PILOT LEVERAGES THIS
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY WE ARE
INSTALLING TWENTY EXTERNAL
MICROFIBERS POSTERS ON TO
WASHING MACHINES USED BY A
VARIETY OF SMALL BUSINESS TYPES
INCLUDING JANITORIAL SERVICES.
SMALL HOTELS HOME OFFICES NAIL
SALONS PET GROOMING FACILITIES
AND MORE ARE IMMATURE THANK YOU
THEIR ATTITUDES AND BEHAVIORS
IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES OF
INSTALLING FILTERS ACROSS THE
CITY. WE HAVE SELECTED THREE
MODELS THE FILTERS PROVEN TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
MICROFIBERS RELEASED. BY 8289%
WE BELIEVE THAT TECHNO AND I.
COLLAPSE WITH AND WATCHING ME
AND YOU. IS THE KEY TO
PREVENTING HARMFUL. POLLUTION
IN THE FUTURE. HE THEN
DISTRICTS COULD NOT ONLY BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
PRODUCT IMPACT BUT ALSO BE
ADAPTABLE TO THE CRITICAL NEEDS
OF THE PRESENT. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REQUIRE NEW
WASHING MACHINE TO BE EQUIPPED
WITH PROPER FILTRATION SYSTEM.
AND NOT THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
RETROFITS OF EXISTING WASHING
MACHINE. THE HARD WORK OF OPEN
MINDED SCIENTISTS AND LAWMAKERS
HAS MADE CALIFORNIA A CRUCIAL
LEADER. IN THE FIGHT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
JUSTICE ADOPTION ADOPTING THESE
POLICIES THAT HAS THE POWER TO
GUIDE OTHERS IN DOING SO AS
WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION- AGAIN I'M
NOT ON THE COUNTRY ON BEHALF.
OF SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF
THE ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANKS FOR KEEPING TO
THE TIME LIMIT- SO DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER- PERSON MAKING THE
COMMENT. I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS IS JESSICA
GEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
WE WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR CONVENING THIS HEARING AND
ONE AT THE THEATER COMMENTS
WITH THOSE FROM DOCTOR RUNNING
WITHOUT THE STAND. CHAPTER HAS
LONG BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
MICROPLASTICS MANAGEMENT THREE
STATEWIDE SOURCE CONTROL
INITIATIVES WE SPONSORED THE
BILL IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO BAN
THE USE OF PLASTIC MICROBEADS
IN PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS. AND
ANOTHER BILL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TO REQUIRED OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL TO CREATE A STATEWIDE
MICROPLASTICS STRATEGY. FOR
CONTROLLING POLLUTION
PREVENTION IS THE ONLY APPROACH
TO MANAGEMENT OF MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION THAT WILL ACTUALLY
KEEP MICHAEL CLASSICS FROM
ENTERING THE ENVIRONMENT. ARE
YOU HEARD TODAY WASTE WATER
TREATMENT TECHNOLOGY IS VERY
EFFICIENT AT REMOVING RIGHT
MICROPLASTICS ESPECIALLY IN
THOSE REGIONS THAT HAVE VERY
SOPHISTICATED PLAN. HOWEVER
REMOVING MICROPLASTICS FROM
WASTEWATER DOESN'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM AS YOU HEARD TODAY
PARTICLE DON'T DISAPPEAR
THEY'RE SIMPLY BEING
TRANSPORTED TO ANOTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL MEDIA BY WAY OF
SLUDGE. OR WHAT WE IN THE
INDUSTRY CALLED BIOSOLIDS THIS
IS CLEARLY SOMETHING AS YOU
KEEN INTEREST TO YOU DOCTOR
PARK AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
ISSUE. I DO HOWEVER THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
LAND APPLICATION OF BIOSOLIDS.
IS A PROVEN RESOURCE RECOVERY
PRACTICE THAT IS HIGHLY
REGULATED BY BOTH FEDERAL EPA
AND THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. AND ULTIMATELY
BIOSOLIDS LAND APPLICATION IS
AN INTEGRAL PART OF WITH WATER
MANAGEMENT IS ONLY CONDUCTED ON
POINT 5% OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL LAND. CAPITALIST
MONITORING SOURCE CONTROL
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR TO KEEP
PLASTICS AND MICROPLASTICS OUT
OF THE WASTE WATER SYSTEM.
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM REQUIRES
DO NOT FLUSH LABEL ON ALL BUT
LIKE PRODUCTS THAT ARE MADE
WITH. ALMOST ENTIRELY PLASTIC
FIBERS. AND ARE FREQUENTLY
FLASH LEADING TO MICROPLASTIC
LEADING INCLINED. WE'RE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORTING AB SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
WHICH REQUIRES MICROFIBER
FILTERS ON NEW RESIDENTIAL
WASHING MACHINES SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WILL ALSO BE
WORKING WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
BOWMAN HIS COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL FILTRATION
LEGISLATION EITHER MEANINGFUL
POLICY CHANGES THAT WILL KEEP
THE COLLISION OUT OF THE WASTE
WATER STREAM. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE WOULD BE ANOTHER
SOURCE CONTROL BUILD RECORD. IN
THE COMING MONTHS THANK YOU-
YES YOU VERY MUCH YES. AND
WE'VE CERTAIN LEARNED A LOT-
ABOUT SOURCE OF PLAY.D
FIRST TWO. COMMENTS ARE VERY
WELL TAKEN. OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
Q. RIGHT NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BONNIE THEY ALL
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR QUIRK AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE PANELISTS
HAVE DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB
EXPLAINING BOTH BROADLY AND IN
DETAIL THE PROBLEM THAT
MICROPLASTICS POSE ON HUMAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. WOMEN
LIKE PLASTIC WE MUST ADOPT
PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE
APPROACH AND NOT WAIT FOR THE
IMPACT THE BIOACCUMULATION
BEFORE TAKING ACTION. AND I
HAVE BEEN MENTIONED THROUGHOUT
THE HEARING THE MAJORITY OF
MICROPLASTICS CAN BE TRACED
BACK TO SINGLE USE ITEMS AND
TEXTILES. THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE MUST WORK IN
CONCERT TO ADDRESS BOTH OF
THESE MAJOR SOURCES ONE BY
REGULATING THE UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE PLASTIC THE AND THE
FIRST TRASH THROUGH BOTH SOURCE
REDUCTION AND USING TRULY
RECYCLABLE AND COMPOSTABLE
MATERIALS. AS WELL AS THE
DOCKING THE BEST AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY TO INTERCEPT
MICROFIBRES ARE FROM SHUTTING
BEFORE THEY ENTER INTO THE
WASTE WATER SYSTEM AND
EVENTUALLY INTO THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT I EITHER ON LAND OR
SEA- WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF
AB EIGHT O. Q. BY SOME NUMBER
BLAME THAT TEND TO TOPPLE-
MICROFIBER FILTRATION AT THE
FACILITIES AND COMMERCIAL
FACILITIES. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THIS AND THE OTHER
MICROFIBER BUILD HEARD IN THE
COMMITTEE- IN THE COMING MONTHS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
I JUST LIKE TO ADDRESS NOT ONLY
THE SINGLE. USE PLASTICS BUT
THE- I. REUSE PLASTICS TOGETHER
AND TO GET A LETTER OR
ILLEGALLY DUMPED. FOR SENT. AND
ILLEGALLY DUMPED THEIR- SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. OUR NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
WE'RE TO LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY MEMBERS- MY NAME'S
GENEVIEVE ABDON I REPRESENT THE
CLEAN P. LOBBYING COALITION IN
THE CAPITAL- AND WE ARE A
COALITION OF A DOZEN NOT ALMOST
A DOZEN NONPROFIT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA DEDICATED TO PLASTIC
POLLUTION POLLUTION.
SPECIFICALLY SOURCE REDUCTION
AND REUSE- WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
HELPING TO PASS- MUCH OF THE
MICROPLASTICS OF LEGISLATION
MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
AFTERNOON. INCLUDING DEFINING
AND MEASURING MICROPLASTICS IN
DRINKING WATER AND OPVS
MICROPLASTICS STRATEGY WE ARE
VERY GLAD TO SEE A REDUCTION IN
SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE PLASTICS
MENTIONED AS THE FIRST
POLLUTION PREVENTION STRATEGY
IN THE BACKGROUND MEMO FOR THAT
HEARING. AS WE BELIEVE THAT
SOURCE REDUCTION OF MACRO
PLASTICS IS A HUGE PART OF. THE
SOLUTION FOR- REDUCING
MICROPLASTICS- MORE UPSTREAM
RATHER THAN SOME OF. THE
DOWNSTREAM POLLUTION. I WE ALSO-
WE'RE GLAD TO CAN BUT- ON THE
LAST BUT WHY TO KNOW. THAT IN
AGREEMENT WITH ONE OF THE PANEL
THAT IT IS A TO. PART OF THE
SOLUTION BY WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT A BIG PART OF THE SOLUTION
AS HOLDING PRODUCERS OF THESE
POLLUTING PRODUCTS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE LIFE CYCLE OF THEIR-
PRODUCTS ONCE THEY PUT THEM ON
THE MARKET- AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT CONSIDERED. AND WE ARE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THEM- MACRO
PLASTICS LEGISLATION THIS YEAR
YOU- HELP REDUCE MICROPLASTIC
THAT AT THE SOURCE. AND I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO ADD SINCE THE
LAST PRESENTER AT TERRY I
WANTED TO ADD ON TO POINTS-
THAT I DON'T KNOW IF CAME UP IN
ANY OF THE SCIENTIFIC PANEL.
BUT ONE IS THAT- BOTH
MICROPLASTICS MICRO. PRODUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS
THEY BREAK DOWN A. B. HAPPY TO
SEND OVER SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING TO BE AWARE OF IN
THAT- IN THIS WHOLE THING IS
WE'RE LOOKING TO SOLUTION. AND
ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT- EVEN
THOUGH THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
HAS DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF-
SCARING THE PUBLIC INTO
THINKING THAT- DISPOSABLES ARE
SAFER TO USE DURING COLDER THAN
THE REARS OF ALL. WE HAVE TO-
GLOBAL HEALTH EXPERTS AND EVEN
NOW AND U. S. HEALTH EXPERTS
AGREEING THAT- JUST YOU KNOW AT
THE LEAST AFFORDABLE THEY'RE
NOT ANY SAFER THAN REASONABLE
SO WE- WE- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TODAY AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO DISCUSS
SOLUTIONS. TO THAT BUT THE
MACRO PLASTICS AND
MICROPLASTICS. PROBLEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT. THANK YOU
RIGHT TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ANDREA
VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
I WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIRED
QUIRK FOR A VERY GOOD HEARING-
AND VERY INTERESTING- COM AT A
PRESENTATION- I NOTICED IN.
DOING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR THAT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW NUMEROUS
BILLS DEALING WITH WASTE MUCH
OF IT NOT ALL OF IT THAT MUCH
IT PLASTIC WASTE AND WE ARE
GLAD TO SEE THAT- WE OBVIOUSLY
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACTS. OF THESE MATERIALS IN
OUR WATER AND ENVIRONMENT IN
GENERAL- SO WE APPLAUD THAT BUT
ONE THING THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THEM WHAT WE LOOK FOR IN
BILLS- WITHIN THEIR PLASTIC OR
ANY OTHER KIND OF- WASTE
REDUCTION- THINKING. IS THAT
THE FIRST OF ALL YOU KNOW EVERY
BILL AND SEVERAL OF THESE DO
YOU KNOW HAS TO REALLY LOOK AT
SOURCE REDUCTION WE JUST HEARD
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT WE
CANNOT ULTIMATELY RECYCLE OUR
WAY OUT OF OUR PROBLEMS WE HAVE
TO STOP USING MATERIALS- SIMPLY
DISPOSABLE- AND SO WE LOOK FOR
THAT IN BILLS THAT ARE THERE
THINGS THAT WILL. YOU KNOW THAT
CAN BE PUT INTO LEGISLATION
THAT WILL HELP PROMOTE FAT THE
OTHER IS THAT WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL WITH ITS PLASTIC
OR ANYTHING ELSE WHAT WE'RE
RECYCLING ARE WE RECYCLING
TOXIC CHEMICALS BACK INTO THE
MARKET PLACE ARE WE JUST
KEEPING THEM IN THE MARKET
PLACE. AND YOU KNOW SO I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS WE ALSO
LOOK FOR IS LANGUAGE THAT WILL
ADDRESS THAT CERTAIN THINGS WE
DON'T WANT IN THE RECYCLING-
ARENA WE DON'T WANT THESE
THINGS COMING BACK TO US
INCLUDING OUR WATER OUR BODIES.
I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT SIMPLE
MESSAGE OUT TO OUR LEGISLATORS
ISSUED CRAFTING LEGISLATION AS
YOU'RE CONSIDERING IT- WE ARE
ALWAYS HAPPY TO WEIGH IN AND
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS ON THAT
AND WE WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHO IS. YOU
KNOW REALLY LOOKING AT THESE
ISSUES AND TRYING TO MOVE
SOMETHING FORWARD SAID THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
SAY MY KEYS TO NOW. YES- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FROM WATER ACTION-
I WANT TO SAY THAT YOUR POINT
ABOUT RE DOT AS WELL TAKEN ALSO
CAN GET SOLUTION FOR REDUCING
PACKAGING PLASTICS AND
PACKAGING AND EXPORT THEM
AROUND THE WORLD WOULD HAVE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT- NEXT SPEAKER
SHE- THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAITLYN
COLUSA I AM THE POLICY MANAGER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER
ALLIANCE AND- THE FIRST LIKE TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR HOSTING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND
PLACING A SPOTLIGHT ON THIS
IMPORTANT INCREASING
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE. OUR ORGANIZATION FOCUSES
ON- PROTECTING RESTORING WATER
QUALITY AND WE ENCOURAGE
MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS BE PREPARED
PROGRESS THE NUMEROUS SOURCES
AND PATHWAYS WITH REGARDS
AFTERNOON OF THIS MICRO AND
PERVASIVE- MY MACRO POLLUTION.
CALIFORNIA TO PURSUE BOTH LONG
AND SHORT TERM SOLUTION TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
POLLUTION. AND RELATIVES ARE
OUR ORGANIZATIONS WORK WE
ACTIVELY SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
REDUCE THE PRESENCE OF
MICROPLASTICS FROM THREE
SPECIFIC PATHWAYS- ONE BEING
PERMITTED DISCHARGES. SECOND
BEING FOR MOTOR RUNOFF AND IN
WASTE. OUR ORGANIZATION THREE
HUNDRED PROTEIN CLOSE RECYCLING
DIRECT OCEAN WASTE WATER
DISCHARGES STORMWATER CAPTURE
TREATMENTS AND THE TIMELY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD TRUST POLICY TO
MANAGE THE PRESENT THE TRASH
AND STORM WATER RUNOFF. AND
THIRTY TO REDUCE MICROFIBERS.
IN WASTE WATER. UNDER THIS YEAR
WE ARE TO BE SPONSORING BILL
TWO WITH A MEMBER FOR. TORE
APART BILLS RATIONING OUR
WASHING. AND ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE TWO TWO WITH MEMBER REED.
SHOULD ANSWER HARD WATER
CAPTURE AND WATER CALL. POLICE
ARE NOT EXHAUSTIVE BUT OF A
GREATER ST ACTIONS THAT TAKE
NOT REDUCE THE OF MY- POLLUTION.
I'M LOOKING AT WHERE THIRTY
FURTHER SO ARE. FUNDED INACTION
IMPLEMENT. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. YOUR ATTENTION
AFTERNOON TO THE SPECIAL. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
VERY MUCH ON TARGET- DISCUSSION.
THE DO WE HAVE ANOTHER CALLER.
SHE THANK YOU THE LAST COMMENT
I HAVING CUTE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
I'M SORRY TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JOHN
BOTHER AND I'M A LONG TERM
RESIN CALIFORNIA STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ASIAN AND ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR EDUCATING US
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF PLASTICS-
I THINK ONE THING I KNOW THREE
PEOPLE HAD MAKE COMMENT ABOUT
LANDFILLS. LANDFILL DUE TO
LEACH STATE AFTER POLICE EVEN
THE BEST- THE BEST REGULATIONS.
SO THAT IS SOMETHING TO PLEASE
CONSIDER- EVEN THE BEST LINING
OVER TIME WILL BE- EVEN WHEN
THEY WENT LATER DETECTED. YEAH
THE REMEDIATION EITHER IS NOT
DONE PROPERLY OR LONG TERM SO
THERE'S THAT THAT CAN BE
SOURCED FOR NOT JUST MINE
MICROPLASTICS. THE CHEMICAL
THAT COME. THE SECOND THING I
WOULD LIKE TO TOUCH ON IS AS
OTHER PEOPLE MENTIONED THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOURCE REDUCTION-
YOU KNOW FOR DECADES CONSUMERS
HAVE BEEN BLAMED. AND CARRIED
THE BILL FOR ALL THE PLASTIC ON
THE PLASTIC BOTTLES AND THAT
AND WHAT NOT BUT- JUST THE FACT
IS THAT THE BOTTLING INDUSTRY
AND PLASTIC MANUFACTURERS ARE
THE ONES. WHO ARE TAKING THE
PROFITS FROM IT IN AND PAYING
ALL OF THIS AS CONSUMERS SO WE
REALLY NEED TO WORK WITH
MANUFACTURERS AND MAKING THEM-
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY AND TO FIND
DIFFERENT. PACKAGING AND OTHER
PRODUCTS- AND I DEFINITELY WANT
TO SAY I YOU KNOW SUPPORT ALL
THE BILLS ARE BEING MENTIONED.
ABOUT THE FILTER WE HAVE TO DO
SOME CONNECTS APPROACH TO NOT
JUST REDUCE THE SOURCE BUT ALSO
TOLD HER WHAT WE CAN. AND TALK
ABOUT SORT PRODUCTION I WANT TO
TOUCH ON BRIEFLY IS COMPACT
HER. SO IMPACT HER NOT ONLY ARE
THE BLADES PLASTIC THE CRUMB
RUBBER ITSELF- THE AVERAGE
YIELD IS FOUR THOUSAND POUNDS
OF CRUMB RUBBER WHICH IS JUST
ALL RIGHTS TIRES- NO TIRES-
CONTAINED OR JUST USE TIRES
TODAY CONTAIN. LEAD AND OTHER
HEAVY METALS INCLUDING SIX PBT
AQUINNAH WHICH IS- WHEN THE
PALACE TALK ABOUT KILLING A CO
HOST SALMON SO- THAT'S ANOTHER
THING THAT NEED TO BE REGULATED
AND CONTROLLED THE RUNOFF FROM
THOSE AND TO COMMEMORATE ALL
RUN INTO OUR WATER SYSTEM SO.
YOU KNOW FOUR THOUSAND POUNDS
OF IT PER FIELD IS A LOT OF
SOURCE- I THINK THAT IS THE
LEGISLATIVE NOT BANNED- HUNTLEY
BE EDUCATED ABOUT I- ALSO A LOT
OF OTHER PARTS. IMPACT FIX. YOU
CAN TAKE A MOTHER. YOU SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TO AND I
FORWARD TO IN TO YOU
LEGISLATION BEING PASSED IN AND-
LEADING THE WAY. STOP BEING
MICHAEL. AND PLASTIC. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND I
BELIEVE FEWER THE PERSON WHO
SENT US THE LETTER ON- ASTRO
TURF AND- SHE GOT A LETTER-
WELL FOR. OF ALL THANKS A- WHO.
THE MEETING TODAY AND THANKS
VERY MUCH TO BE GREAT
SCIENTISTS. WHO WERE KIND
ENOUGH TO GIVE US THEIR TIME
AND AGAIN COMING FROM AROUND
THE COUNTRY IN THE WORLD- AND
AS THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS
LEGISLATION ON MICROPLASTICS I
KNOW AS THE CHAIR OF THE ONE OF
THE COMMITTEES DEALING WITH
THIS THAT IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
USEFUL TO ME- AND LOOKING AT
THE BILLS TO COME FORWARD AND
SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH- AS A
REMINDER WILL KEEP THE
COMMITTEE RECORD OPEN FOR TWO
WEEKS UNTIL MARCH SIXTEENTH HER
ADDITIONAL WRITTEN COMMENTS.
SHOULD YOU LIKE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
CONTACT MY STAFF- ARE DENNIS
STRADER IS PIA ESTRADA- AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE JOSH
TUCKER PAGE BROKAW. M. AND ALL
OF THE SERGEANTS FROM THE
SERGEANTS STAFF THERE WERE HERE
TODAY- TO MAKE SURE THIS-
HEARING WAS RUN WELL- ONCE
AGAIN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.